talking about uh
attempted attacks some murders happening
against israelis
in africa and several other places what
can you tell us and what's your first
impression when you see this
i'm not surprised i've spent most of the
last year
covering al qaeda sales in europe
primarily in france belgium spain some
work in england and then north africa
and from all of the intelligence chiefs
that i've interviewed
consistently throughout the past year
they have
felt that these kinds of attacks are
inevitable
and indeed they worry about much more
catastrophic attacks i think what a lot
of people forget is that the
attacks of 911 took two years to plan
and
there's
a group of very dedicated capable people
uh capable in the sense of being able to
commit acts of terrorism uh out there in
europe the french estimate that about
400 uh french
dual nationals uh one must remember
there are four million uh primarily
north african muslims that live in
france have made their way back to
europe from afghanistan and it's a
matter of regrouping setting up new
cells but especially the french are very
very worried so it's not a surprise
there's no question in your mind that
this is al-qaeda
well that is of course for the
intelligence communities to determine
but
it has all the fingerprints of al qaeda
yeah i mean one must remember that al
qaeda is not uh it's not the national
rifle association people don't uh
uh walk around carrying membership cards
uh it's a much more amorphous and a
looser kind of network and al qaeda
cells i
when we look at for instance the paris
embassy bombing plot that was broken by
the french they were given fairly
amorphous orders uh from
afghanistan from the leadership
even in terms of timetable in terms of
how they were going to do it in terms of
who they were going to recruit
so these cells have a lot of autonomy
they tend not to after a particular
attack they tend to dissipate and form
new groups new small cells
they're very protean um they change
shape uh the the chief investigating
judge in france bruger says it's like
the aids virus you know they constantly
mutate and for that reason they're very
hard to track down um and very hard to
control because the
there's minimal contact between them and
the al-qaeda leadership they have a lot
of autonomy with the new york times
since 1990 and prior to that in the
middle east for the dallas morning news
so where
where have you uh reported from
i've i was overseas for 15 plus years
six years in latin america spent five
years covering the war in el salvador in
nicaragua
uh took a sabbatical to study arabic
went to the middle east for the dallas
morning news
covered all of the middle east and then
the collapse of the communist
regimes in east germany czechoslovakia
and romania
worked in india and africa was hired by
the new york times in 1990 covered the
gulf war
and then in 1991 i became the middle
east bureau chief
for the new york times based in cairo
and then the balkan bureau chief covered
the war in
in
sarajevo and
in kosovo
and when you say covered the war
how did you do that
in the balkans in any of these places oh
i i lived i didn't go in and out i lived
there i mean i lived in san salvador and
uh
i was in sarajevo i had a room in the
holiday inn like the other the other
journalists were there covering the war
so it was right right in the thick of it
i mean i i was in the middle of the
fighting what does this mean
this title of your new book war is a
force that gives us meaning
um
i
had
always liked and been very influenced by
a book by the historian crane britain
anatomy of revolution where he had tried
to dissect generically
what is it that creates
revolution what are the and he looked at
several revolutions to do that so it
remains for me a fascinating book and i
wanted to do the same thing with war i
wanted to and i've covered you know a
dozen conflicts
um i've spent i was a seminarian so
i thought about this in in moral and
ethical terms
um you know i had to read just war
theory and uh christian ethicists from
knee bird abarth
and uh i wanted to do the same thing for
war what what
creates
the disease of war within a society what
are the factors that do it how does
war come about how does war corrupt both
individuals and societies how does it
work and
so i
i
spent i took a fellowship at harvard and
um
that's where it really began and i began
to piece it all together and that's what
i attempted to do war forms its own
culture war is a drug
yes
yeah it does form its own culture um
it's a subculture which makes it so
fascinating um and it has i think like
any kind of extreme activity it has a
kind of intoxication
um not only for societies that support a
war that go into war
but for the participants themselves it
has a very it's a very dark
and frightening elixir even with its
destruction you write and this carnage
it can give us what we long for in life
yes it in on many levels it banishes the
sort of trivial in the commonplace it
ennobles us it raises us
to
to to create this kind this communal
sense of bonding this this kind of
corporate sense this comradeship where
suddenly we feel at one uh elias
canadian crowds in power writes about
this you know where suddenly when you
have that external threat
one feels as part of a whole and and he
writes i think correctly that death
becomes easier to bear or the threat of
death because one fit no longer faces it
alone uh you know you you give up
individual consciousness for the the
goals of the of the war enterprise and
which reduces i think a lot of common
anxiety i mean there
there is in war unfortunately especially
for
people in modern society who often are
profoundly alone and and live very
atomized
there is in war um a sense of belonging
a sense of purpose that can escape
people in everyday life more from your
book war fills our spiritual void i do
not miss war but i miss what it brought
i can never say i was happy in the midst
of the fighting in el salvador or bosnia
or kosovo but i had a sense of purpose
of calling and this is a quality that
war shares with love as we are in love
also able to choose fealty and
self-sacrifice over security
yes war at its inception always looks
and feels like love the chief emotion
that war destroys
and um you know the the ancient greeks
and romans understood that war was a god
and that war called at the beginning for
the sacrifice for others um but war
uncontrolled um
uh uninspected
uh untamed ends with self-sacrifice
self-annihilation and that's why it's so
dangerous phone lines are open for
christopher hedges if you'd like to join
us democrats
202-585-3881 republicans
202-585-3880 and all others 202 585-3882
so you went about this as understanding
that this was going to be kind of an
unusual
type of war book
or war reporting book yes it's not a war
reporting book i i never really liked
narratives by journalists about i mean i
thought that i there's a very dark side
to what we do
um
and i i find that you know in the press
and wartime
is part of the myth-making machine and
always has been and journalists are not
only good at at sustaining the national
myth but the myth about themselves
so the points where i did bring myself
up or i did pull sort of anecdotes from
my own i tried to be very hard on myself
and on the profession because this is
about the disease of war
um
um yeah it's it's uh
it's it's certainly not a traditional
book in any sense it's it's a meditation
on war the notion i i think i found
where it is the notion that the press
was used in the war i think you're
talking about the gulf war here
is incorrect the press wanted to be used
it saw itself as part of the war effort
that well that's always been true the
press uh the first casualty taking this
quote from the senator hiram walker
about
the first casualty in war is truth
and he looked at the way nationalist
press reporting on their own conflicts
from the crimea war up through the
present day
and um in every single conflict the
press sees itself as part of the war
effort as uh as an entity which must
sort of sustain the morale and support
the cause
chris hedges our guests from the new
york times will go to the phones los
angeles first up good morning hi good
morning and uh happy thanksgiving
um i am sure you thought a lot about
this in the course of writing your book
and i'm sure you also had to grapple
with the issue of
what you know what war does that's also
good and
that might be antithetical to your your
your book but certainly we have to look
back and see that good things also were
accomplished and i'm not championing war
but i i immediately am thinking as
you're talking about uh
the uh choice during world war ii for
example to
ultimately destroy
the will of germany and japan to
continue fighting we recognize the need
to
i don't know another word but
exterminate the will
to launch these genocidal wars and we
did it and that strikes me as a terribly
good outcome of war
and i might have a follow-up i'd like to
uh listen to your response
yes i'm not a pacifist i think that war
is a tragic and inevitable part of the
human condition
um but i don't believe that there
there is a good war uh war some wars
have to be fought i supported the
intervention in bosnia i supported the
intervention in kosovo i feel that we
failed as a country by not intervening
in rwanda when you have the capacity to
stop genocide and if we learned anything
from the holocaust we should have
learned this and you do not you are in
some way culpable but war is always
tragic and war
uh reeks
not only a physical devastation but a
psychological and emotional devastation
that takes generations to heal
um so certainly i understand why we
fought world war ii was the outcome good
uh you know reinhold niebuhr the great
christian ethicist wrote that moral
choice is
uh very rarely almost never probably
between what is moral and what is
immoral but what is a one immoral choice
and one more immoral choice and for me
that's the moment when you have to
choose war you're choosing an immoral
choice over an option which can be of
course appeasement or the failure to act
as as a more immoral choice
um
so and and i lived my father and all of
my
most of my uncles fought in the war one
of whom was
devastated by the war in the south
pacific
and that was a burden that my family
many families carried them there was and
there was there is no good war
many journalists
get affected by the war
yes many war correspondents tend to be
their own fraternity and they wander
from war zone to war zone so that i was
covering the war in kosovo with people
who i had covered the war with in el
salvador 20 years before
and that's part of their sickness
you know aid workers have it of course
combat soldiers soldiers that have it
and that's
they they need the rush of war uh they
um have a hard time coping in peacetime
society um they
uh they're very traumatized by it and
news organizations
have never been particularly good at
knowing how to handle that so a lot of
them come back with drinking problems
friends of mine
especially after the war in bosnia that
was so brutal have never recovered you
mentioned a specific story in a book of
someone who who didn't didn't make it
after coming home who was it
um
well i there are a couple instances in
the book of people who didn't make it
including the end of the book where i
talk about my friend kurt shork who was
a reuters correspondent who was killed
in sierra leone along with miguel gil
moreno
and there there was i i
talked about a photographer in the book
who
had covered the war in el salvador and
tried to give it up and came back and
and couldn't and essentially we knew
when he came back that he'd come back to
die sterling virginia your next
republican uh good morning how are you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
with mr hedges uh mr hedges who said you
were in sarajevo during
the conflict now
in 1995 we bombed the bosnian serbs over
what was described as the marcalla
marketplace massacre however joseph
ledanski in his book and i'm reading
directly from his book said that this
was a self
callous self killing which was designed
to
shock the west especially sentimental
and gullible washington in order to
raise the level of western sympathy to
bosnian muslims and further demonize the
serbs now my my question is
we
continually lied about the atrocities
committed over there vedanski is a very
honorable man he said that the bomb that
was used to bomb the markula marketplace
was designed with the help of hezbollah
now the al qaeda has been in there for
over a decade and that we deny the serbs
the right to defend themselves and i
would like to uh follow up on your
answer well that's a caller we have a
lot of folks on the line so we'll just
take your question thank you i don't i
looked at that market place bombing and
uh and this has been a persistent claim
on the part of the serbs that this bomb
was designed by
hezbollah or designed by the muslims
themselves there's no evidence to
support that the u.n carried out a long
investigation you know the fact is there
were one thousand two thousand heavy
shells coming into sarajevo daily and
the notion that um
you know that somehow the serbs would
not have said well let's not put shells
there there's a marketplace is a
patently absurd those shells landed all
over the place including on hospitals um
so that that's just not true and i think
the other misconception is that we went
into sarajevo because of the marketplace
bombing we went into sarajevo and this
is all in richard holbrook's book uh
because the u.n mission was collapsing
and and president clinton had made a
commitment to nato that if there was an
extraction of forces u.n
or u.s soldiers would go in to help with
that extraction
rather than do that because they worried
about suffering heavy casualties they
decided to bomb that's why we went in we
went in to save the un mission because
it was falling apart glenview illinois
democrat
uh good morning and thanks for
and the opportunity to speak with mr
hedges uh i have a uh a a question i
have an opinion on it and then i'd like
to see what you think about it or your
answer to it uh it kind of ties together
this segment with the last one
we've just had events uh in 2001 that
brought us to war were likely to go into
further war
and uh in the last segment they brought
up the investigation and what an
investigation that will be conducted on
it and a large number of the of calls
concerned conspiracy theories uh and
they didn't like the fact that it was
kissinger and um
and uh michael's edge of mitchell
looking into it because of their past
politics my question is an investigation
is going to be done
and but
that seems to me to be like likening um
being upset that a about a former
politician would investigate a crime in
a city because he might have helped
produce poverty that create that creates
crime and it seems to me this
investigation isn't about the causes of
the of what happened it's not about the
root causes and whatnot it has to do
with finding out who did it how they did
it how we keep it from happening again
and i'm wondering if do you believe do
you think that this there was an
overwhelming number of calls in that
area and i want to know if you find any
validity to their criticism that these
people uh kissinger mitchell are not
qualified to do that based on their
politics
that's an interesting question of course
henry kissinger having spent six years
in latin america and covered chile
myself is a very controversial figure
um i think you're right to point out
that that what this is is an
intelligence failure and what the uh
inability to capture osama bin laden and
break the leadership of al-qaeda is as
well as an intelligence failure and
um um yes certainly a figure especially
i think uh by uh
by mr kissinger certainly a figure by dr
like dr kissinger is pretty suspect um
but that doesn't mean they can't find
people on their staff who have that
expertise to do it i i wouldn't be so
quick to dismiss the effort um but i
think the questions are valid ones next
is chicago republican
good morning good morning uh el cajeta
is a really diffuse organization how do
you think the best way
would be to find
and defeat it and even if we do defeat
al-qaeda is that enough to safeguard our
security what about
groups like hezbollah and
related groups
um
al qaeda is
is different from many of the other
terrorist groups you know
al-qaeda came out of the
um
the nationalist islamic movements in the
middle east for instance the feasts and
the gia in algeria
but they brought together
people from various countries and no
longer were they
concerned primarily for instance like
the gia the armed islamic group and
algeria with the so-called liberation of
algeria the creation of islamic state
but a much more nihilistic kind of rage
against everything
western um so how do you fight al qaeda
it really has to be two-pronged on the
one hand it it is a very difficult
intelligence war one of the complaints
the french make about the american
intelligence community is that we don't
uh have enough human assets we rely uh
too much on electronic surveillance
satellite photos that kind of stuff and
they the french who are very good
because one must remember in the 1980s
that the gi was setting off bombs in the
paris metro and in bank robbing banks
and shooting policemen i mean there was
real havoc for and they and they really
successfully broke
um
the gia
and they did it through old-fashioned
intelligence work i mean if for instance
uh in their wiretaps when they when they
are following a suspected cell there are
23 different dialects arabic dialects in
algeria and and they have uh real-time
translators in each one of those
dialects um they have just set up an
operation uh that and that that that um
allows them to get real-time information
and then they have worked deciduously at
infiltrating people into
uh various terrorist networks and they
feel that the americans because they
didn't do that
and they have that's one of the reasons
for the intelligence failures
the french
say that every time they have broken a
plot it has not been
through
primarily through electronic
eavesdropping but through being tipped
off by
by people that they had inside the
organizations or close to the
organizations i think the other
frightening thing
is that we still can't read a lot of the
traffic that al qaeda is sending back
and forth um it it's very sophisticated
it's
um although the french have a lot of
disks so one sees the arrests now over
these uh
um
men who had assisted uh reed and the
with the shoe bomber who had stopped in
paris but they they've had those discs
for months and it's taken them quite a
when i last time i was in paris they
still hadn't deciphered them so
we're dealing with people who have a
level of technical expertise that's far
beyond as well the
uh homegrown islamic movements that we
have seen before page 80 of your new
book the destruction of culture plays a
crucial role in the solidification of a
wartime narrative when the visible and
tangible symbols of one's past are
destroyed or denied the past can be
recreated to fit the myth and i guess i
take you to today's
news stories uh which is not it's not a
tangible thing but uh some might say
it's something that's no longer going to
be had and that is the there's going to
be a request that the federal government
pay for all the security for both the
democratic and republican conventions in
2004. is that is that a a part of the
culture that
is just uh
going away not necessarily the paying
for it but the whole idea of how we
oversee security yes i think i'm talking
more
i think that is part of it but i think
i'm speaking more about uh
sort of
let's call it authentic or dissident
culture and one sees and once saw this
after 9 11 that cultural events become
infused with the jingoism of patriotism
and that's very dangerous i mean one of
the things that i've learned by covering
various conflicts there's you know we we
had that issue of cultural genocide in
bosnia where
the serbs would dynamite mosques and of
course they destroyed the the uh that
great library in sarajevo um but what
people forget is that in wartime the
destruction of culture always begins
with the destruction of one's own
culture
that in wartime we are
uh forced to
speak with the language the state gives
us the nation gives us the cliches the
axis of evil showdown with iraq and it
becomes very hard to express yourself
outside the box there is a hijacking of
language and wartime that's very
frightening so whatever disquiet you
have
you're robbed of the vocabulary to
express it and this isn't an esoteric
idea
because until you can recreate a common
narrative there is no peace if you go to
a country like bosnia or cyprus
you don't have peace what you have is
the absence of war because there is no
common common narrative by which people
can communicate i mean the the entities
in bosnia and the schools teach
radically different
versions of the same historical event
and what they're doing is grooming a new
generation that can no longer speak with
each other
the truth and reconciliation commission
that was set up in south africa was
absolutely vital because although of
course it gave an amnesty to the killers
who had carried out these crimes for the
apartheid regime
in order to get that amnesty they had to
lay bare what they did the crimes that
they had committed and it makes it that
much harder to deny it and it gives
people a way to speak back and forth
around a common reality so that's what
i'm talking about the destruction of
culture is in the hijacking of language
which of course i you know have two
chapters in my book that deal precisely
with those themes
are um are very pernicious and very
frightening aspects of a wartime society
and i see that happening within our own
society
most society mr hedges rights never
recover from the self-inflicted wounds
made by their own culture during wartime
war leaves behind not memory but amnesia
next call kalamazoo michigan democrat
morning kalamazoo
uh good morning mister just good morning
uh i would like to you kind of sparked
my mind when you were talking about
culture and it reminded me when john
walters was on c-span i believe last
week and he was saying that they it
feels that they successfully now driven
the culture and the drug war underground
enough to really attack and i can see
that mr hitchinson the dea
man is going to be put in charge of
transportation in the border and mr
walters announced that they're going to
be stopping cars and giving tests for
marijuana usage and that means that any
metabolites found in an individual it
will be
grounds to give him a dwi
and what i'd like to say is that
the fbi just released its figures on
arrests for marijuana possession and it
was 700 000
people arrested last year for just
possession
now you see nevada tried to vote for
three ounces and legalize it and tax it
through the government and they got 40
of the vote and yet we never see any
responsible people being asked to come
on and defend that on the c-span thank
you for the call kalamazoo next is boca
raton florida
yes good morning good morning uh i i
think we all have you know a
philosophical repugnance for war i
uh you know again i'm reminded that you
know
uh hegel did say that uh philosophy was
a catavelt it was a world stood on its
head
my concern is that we are in a war
that has been thrust upon us i mean we
we are dealing with
fanatic
islamists
uh who uh abide by the laws of hudabaya
the treaties of quraj where in no treaty
with an infidel uh uh needs to be
honored where there is uh uh a a an
actual uh uh
injunction that it can be and should be
abrogated as soon as victory is in sight
and my concern is that there is a
naivete
in american diplomacy and and western
diplomacy that we can negotiate with
these individuals who perceive us as i
think the latest thing that i saw was
that we are uh pigs or monkeys and that
uh we we are to be destroyed and and
ultimately i think uh when you have
culture conf you you have to support
your your uh you know what remains even
after war as you indicated there may be
there may be a a uh
a
you know a subversion of of our own
culture but again subversion perhaps is
uh is is a preferable to a destruction
of it and
and my concern here is that this is the
the behind this wahhabism this this uh
this approach to uh
to i think that we should do as kennedy
did uh during the cuban missile crisis i
think we should make the uh the uh arab
states that support these uh these
terrorists i think we should make them
responsible that if an attack on the
united states or its allies is waged
against us that they must pay a price
they support them militarily they
support them financially why not make
them pay a price for their uh you know
for for their habits thank you
yeah
i mean the caller raises two issues that
disturb me
and that is this tendency to make vast
sweeping generalizations about the
muslim world which constitutes one-fifth
of the world's population most muslims
of course are not arabs and uh yes the
people who raid against us
call us infidels and other names and we
call them barbarians
we cannot become like them and we cannot
assume that they somehow represent uh
the tens of millions of muslims who
share the same kind of repugnance that
we do towards these terrorists
islam is a nuanced diverse
rich
tradition or religion that can't be
summed up in in cliches just like you
can about any of the monotheistic other
monotheistic faiths such as judaism or
christianity and islam unfortunately has
seen a radical fundamentalist movement
but so has christianity and so has
judaism um you know jerry falwell
doesn't speak for me uh so i feel that
you know to somehow make sweeping
generalizations against the the muslims
uh or islam in this kind of environment
is dangerous and uh it it
in many ways smacks of what those
arrayed against us are doing secondly in
terms of the war this is not a war you
can't declare war against an idea you
can declare war against a nation uh you
can declare war against iraq uh the war
on terror comes out of orwell it's this
amorphous
never-ending battle that those who wage
the war define they define who the war
is arrayed against they define how long
it will go and what is what is victory
against the war on terror this is an
intelligence battle and it has to be
waged by intelligence services
unfortunately our intelligence
agencies failed us with 911 and they
failed us in many ways in afghanistan
as you see with the israelis of with
black september it takes years to track
these people down um and it's very
difficult dropping iron fragmentation
bombs all over the place um is the worst
way to to go after a war on terror
because it only creates more terrorists
um it has to be the war any kind of a
battle against these kind of elements
has to be waged on two fronts one by the
intelligence community but secondly
politically we can't fold in on
ourselves um there has to be
a recognition that that did take place
at the end of the persian gulf war and
then unfortunately was never
followed through that
there you know many people have
legitimate grievances against us or
against the client states that we
support i'm thinking of course of the
palestinians or uh egyptians or many
saudis who are very uh
there's a great deal of discontent over
the uh saudi royal family's rule of
saudi arabia and
unfortunately in wartime with the
rhetoric it precludes self-reflection
and self-introspection which is always
very dangerous because it only fuels the
violence and fuels the antagonism this
email question is any anti-war effort a
war
well one of the dangers with anti-war
efforts uh and this comes directly out
of the first world war is there there is
a tendency to believe that we can employ
the instruments of war to end war
and war is always a disease uh and just
as a cancer patient may have to ingest a
poison
to fight off cancer there are times when
a society has to ingest the poison of
war in order to survive
but it is a poison always a poison and
it doesn't matter whether that's
that poison is ingested for a good or a
bad cause it's the same poison so i
would caution against uh people who want
to fight war with war next is park
forest illinois good morning chris good
morning uh i didn't see connie maybe you
mentioned where chris's book is
available
well let's see it it's published by
public affairs which is uh based in new
york city and it is probably
available nationwide yes it's any barnes
and nobles borders amazon
okay good uh i guess uh i forget which
philosopher greek philosopher was and
said we make war so that we may live in
peace
and one gentleman was so used so many
big words i don't know i understood half
of it just previously but anyway i i
look at it from a very simplistic point
i look at the freedoms that i work with
jew muslim christian
agnostic and everybody basically in this
country still can
practice as they want
do what they want and live live in my
opinion a free life and you as an
american writing this book i'm
interested to know how that affected you
in terms of writing this book but
basically that that being said uh i look
at it very simply is there's a choice
now we either go after these people
or we surrender to them so they've made
it pretty easy in my opinion we're going
after them and and like you said you
don't want to necessarily call it a war
but it is a war against terrorism so i'd
like to know your input in terms of how
you as an american
that affected you and write in this book
if in fact it did
well i don't have any problem going
after them the question is how we go
after them and
what we embrace as a society as we go
after them if we embrace the same kind
of intolerance the same kind of
chauvinism then we become little better
then
we don't become any different i mean i
worry about the rhetoric i worry about
the the way we are portraying the muslim
world um you know people have all sorts
of opinions
having really knowing very very little
about islam and very little about muslim
culture
i have a great deal of respect for for
islam
you know i'm hardly a scholar but
you know i do speak arabic i have lived
for seven years in the middle east
um they're you know the the the religion
along with judaism and christianity in
my mind is one of the great religions of
the world and to see it slam like this
if i were a muslim i would just be
furious and and heartbroken um and and
that worries me these vast
generalizations and that and you know
war always begins with language and it
is the dehumanization of the other the
turning of the other linguistically into
an object and once they become an object
linguistically it's not a huge step to
turn them into an object literally i.e a
corpse and we can't fight that battle we
can't uh
you know we can't clash
to steal a phrase from samuel huntington
with another civilization because
there's no need to um and it really is
done out of ignorance and i think just
as they attack us out of ignorance um
and and for that reason of course you
can't compromise with them or negotiate
with them i'm talking about these small
terrorist cells
at the same time we we have to rise
above it and we have to embrace the
values that have given us our freedoms
and that plurality and that respect for
others
which um has made our country in many
ways unique in the annals of
civilization but i see in every wartime
that is always corrosive always corroded
and it's being corroded now and and and
it worries me and in the invent of
another terrorist attack especially
possibly a cataclysmic attack i think we
will see a further swing towards this
kind of intolerance and this kind of
racism and this kind of bigotry and this
thirst for violence and if there is you
know one lesson on the globe or maybe
two that will point to the fact that you
cannot quash the national or the the
rage of of of a populist purely through
violence look at chechnya or look at
what's happening between the israelis
and the palestinians
those you know that you end up
shattering any kind of discourse pushing
societies into extremes where they no
longer can speak it's the only way they
speak is through the act of violence
itself and then everyone's doomed well
is there a finger a point of blame for
the evolution of this of this language
is it the journalist is it the
politicians who is it um
i think the press bears culpability for
it certainly the state does
excuse me the entertainment industry
does
it
it becomes in wartime uh
an alternative language is pretty much
drowned out and you know you saw that
with uh people who tried to raise
questions about the uh
uh you know the wild sort of patriotic
embrace that followed 911 they were
pretty roundly attacked and uh that
subsided somewhat but if we get another
terrorist attack on american soil those
kinds of dissident voices will be
drowned out chicago you're next democrat
good morning
good morning um
happy thanksgiving to all i actually
read your piece and the harper magazine
a little over a year ago and titled a
jazza diary was when if you tell me a
little bit more about experience
specifically at the time and i was
wondering in your mind do you see our
terrorism equivalent to the israelis uh
against the palestinian conflict thank
you elephant you've done several things
for things for harper's including a
diary i went and lived in a refugee camp
in gaza
called hanayunus
and i wrote
the cover story for harpers
and it was on a day-to-day sometimes
literally morning by afternoon what it
was like to be a palestinian who lived
in this refugee camp and it was a
a pretty searing in the end ended up
being a very syrian indictment of the
way
the israeli defense forces and the
settlers and israel itself were treating
palestinian refugees in gaza
you know i was every single day i was
there
there was shooting
often towards small children young as
young as 10 or 11
you know and then i would visit them in
the hospital later and um
is there a no i don't think that we this
is what i don't want to happen um i
think that what's happening in
between the palestinians
and the israelis is
this
complete embrace of necrophilia on both
sides and everything has become
every every act of violence uh
is
countered by another act of violence if
there's a suicide bombing on a bus then
you bomb a refugee camp and this is only
uh with each side dumping gasoline all
over the conflict
as we've seen i mean look at what's
happened for the last two years the
israeli economy has tanked the numbers
of
israeli dead are growing of course
three times as many palestinians have
been killed and once you get into this
spiral
it's very very hard to turn back and
that is what um i don't think we're
there yet um i think that if we come
under assault i don't think the israelis
are somehow reacting any differently
than any other society would uh but i
think that if we did come under assault
i would worry that
and that's part of the reason why i
wrote this book is that you know i i
don't want us to see i want us to to
open our eyes and see the disease and
the danger
of this kind of rhetoric and these kinds
of emotions that are unleashed by
conflict so that we can guard against
them because it it it ends
while it looks like the destruction of
the other it if if it's not checked it
ends with self-destruction fremont
indiana
i wish you a healthy and contemplative
and peaceful day and i hope that for
more people in our country because
there's too much of this self-driven
attitude
i i really appreciate the service that
mr hedges is providing and i would add
that war is also a force that distracts
people from realizing their need
to see life as needing to be a growth
continuum and i go to the president and
say wait a minute i don't see leadership
here even though i voted for you and i i
like to say i'm a republican but
sometimes i cringe when i see people
like karl rove acting like a dictator
and i can't get two words in except on
c-span and talk radio
and i believe i'm being principled and
pleasant in suggesting
that there needs to be a streamlining of
business as the mutual funds certainly
know
uh top to bottom to have
what dr deming talked about and that is
the resource most underused the working
person uh respected and brought into
decision making when uh streamlining and
and upgrading and improvements are made
otherwise we're not being patriotic
we're not able to defend ourselves in uh
the economy that is uh coming after us
including china
mr hedges
yeah um well it's a question of
leadership that of course has to be
something that that's perhaps not for me
to judge
you know the only thing i would say is
that
we
uh the way that we have responded to the
terrorist threat is to build an alliance
a kind of troika
with putin and sharon
and i think
many people forget
that much of the world
especially the muslim world sees us
through the prism of
palestine and chechnya and what they see
is very unsavory so rather than
engage in the kind of introspection that
perhaps we should engage in and rather
uh question the policies as we're
carrying them out we're folding in on
ourselves and embracing two people who
have uh i think very very questionable
responses to
homegrown insurrections of course now we
have putin and shiron
quite avidly describing these conflicts
in this as in the same terms that we
describe what we're going through and i
think in fact they're different i think
what what's happening in chechnya or
what's happening in uh the west bank and
gaza is not the same as what's happening
to us and by allowing them to
use the same kind of rhetoric
and and and carry out their
kinds of policies without any kind of
real criticism from washington or real
questioning throws us in with a a a
group of or let's see two leaders that
perhaps we don't want to be thrown in
with washington dc democrat
hi thanks for taking my call
i'm an american muslim and i
have been
concerned about our inability to
differentiate between friend and foe
after 9 11 i was not worried about a
clash of civilizations now i am for the
simple reason that
i'm asked by friends here sincerely why
do they hate us and i can understand
that and i try to explain that but now
when i go to my parents middle east i'm
asked over there why do the americans
hate us and that's coming from what they
read about the christian right
islamic slamming islam and that worries
me because that's the mainstream that's
what people on both sides are thinking
so i'd love to hear your thoughts thank
you well i think you touched exactly on
a point i raised earlier in that just as
osama bin laden does not speak for you
indeed does not speak for the vast
majority of muslims jerry falwell and
pat robertson do not speak for me
and i say this as a as a former
seminarian
so
i i think that just as perhaps many
muslims in the middle east are ignorant
about christianity what its tenants are
who its spokespeople are
we are ignorant as well very ignorant
about islam and uh
and the only way to
bridge that the only way to to
to build um to reach out to the other is
by understanding the other martin luther
king had a wonderful quote he said i can
never be who i ought to be until you are
who you ought to be and you can never be
who you ought to be until i am who i
ought to be and i think that by uh
respecting the dignity of the other
and um and and honoring the traditions
of the other is the only way in which we
can can fight this and that
understanding only comes
not by uh swallowing the facile and
frankly racist cliches that are peddled
by both sides but by taking the time to
study to understand to reach out to
speak
and unfortunately in wartime society
that becomes harder to do front page of
your newspaper today talks about the
united states is pressing for turkey to
help in the move to iraq and i ask you
that because of the recent elections in
turkey the fact that the
islamic groups have take are taking uh
having more of a power in turkey right
so how does that work with when we're
talking about our allies not just our
enemies right i think what people forget
about
islamic movements in the middle east is
that they're nationally based
and
and a good analogy comes with a
communism uh you know before the
collapse of communism where czech
communists or
excuse me yukuslav communists or
romanian communists
or polish communists are not russian
communists um and these uh
the the
the fact is that
islamic movements
have become the voice of the opposition
many of these i'm not particularly
talking about turkey but especially in
places like egypt or algeria
these regimes are tired bankrupt corrupt
you know they came out of nassar in the
1950s this pan-arabist socialist
philosophy and it's gone i mean they are
nothing but tired uh police states and
dictatorships and they will be swept
aside the question is
the is how and if we keep repressing the
opposition as we've seen in countries
like egypt or algeria these islamic
movements grow more and more virulent
and more and more extreme
i think the great failure in algeria was
robbing the feasts the islamic party of
the elections in 1991.
i know the fees well most of them were
lawyers and doctors uh i think that once
they it's very easy to be critical and
once you have to govern the country and
and create a viable economic policy and
everything else a lot of that luster or
those utopian visions are worn off in
by by denying them power by keeping them
out of power you create far more radical
and intransigent groups that are harder
to control so i'm not terribly
frightened about what's happening in
turkey one must also remember that
in turkey the army is a it which is
secular and really has traditionally
always been opposed to the islamists
is a very powerful force
large sectors of turkey are secular and
i i wouldn't be so quick to write
someone off just because they have an
islamic tag
chris hedges this is his new book war is
a force that gives us meaning published
by public affairs and available now
nationwide what is this cover picture
it's a picture of people uh
uh in brooklyn on the promenade
uh holding up flags and candles
um
in after the attacks on the world trade
center
thanks very much for coming in this
morning thank you thanks connie
we are going to turn now back to your
phone calls and changing a subject you
probably have heard by now that the
president has made a decision about
how he's going to handle some of the
national
[Music]
you're looking at pictures from
charlottesville virginia which is
hosting the virginia festival of the
book this week over the next four and a
half hours we'll be bringing you several
panels from the event
in about an hour and a half charles
bowden amy yarzinski and robin kirk
discuss reporting from a war zone
then in three hours we'll join the
festival live for a panel on the limits
of free speech during the war with
authors henry abraham barbara perry and
robert o'neill
but first an event we taped on thursday
on the human elements of war featuring
writers chris hedges and kate hudgins as
well as roberta culbertson director of
the institute on violence and survival
well good morning
can everyone hear me
can everyone see me or do i have these
two really bright sort of goggle eyes
because of the light there it's okay
all right um welcome my name is roberta
culbertson i'm with the virginia
foundation for the humanities and we are
among other things the sponsor of a
sponsor of the book festival we're glad
you're all here and hope you'll go to a
number of programs while you're here
i also want to remind you to be sure to
fill out your yellow evaluation form
which you will
see in every program that you attend
this helps us plan for the following
years we're now in our ninth year
of the festival of the book and every
year i think we get better in large part
because we spend a great deal of time
collating and counting what you all say
on these after the end of every session
every book festival
i'm trying to think of what i wanted to
say next
um
i think what i'll go ahead and say that
i'm very uh grateful also to uva
bookstore for allowing us to hold one of
our programs here actually many of our
programs here including this one
now talk a little bit about our guests
and about what i think we hopefully will
be able to do this morning in the time
that we have
our first guest is chris hedges
here uh one's a girl and one's a boy so
i guess it's not too hard to tell them
apart but at any rate this is chris
hedges and here's kate hudgins
chris hedges is a has been a foreign
correspondent for 15 years you may have
read his work in the new york times he's
worked with the new york times since
1990.
he has a b.a degree from colgate and a
master of divinity from harvard
university
in 2002 he won the amnesty international
global award for human rights journalism
and his book
war is a force that gives us meaning
is a very inspiring and very useful book
in en to help us understand some of the
consequences of war that we generally
don't think about it is now number 19 or
will be next week number 19 on the new
york times bestseller list
kate hudgins is a clinical psychologist
she received the 2001 innovators award
for the american society of group
psychotherapy and psychodrama for her
model the therapeutic spiral model the
therapeutic spiral is sort of an
interesting title but what kate does is
works with she works with trauma
survivors survivors of war sometimes
long after the event and works on some
of the issues that chris will be
bringing up in terms of helping people
recover from the consequences of war
she has a deep knowledge of violence and
trauma
and she also understands how people can
best recover from it she's also worked
internationally as has chris and i just
came back from a trip to taiwan which
she'll tell you about a little bit
what i hope we're going to so those are
who we have with us it's it's really
exciting to have two such high-powered
people with us and what we're going to
be doing this morning is trying to
understand a little bit more some of the
context of of war and mass violence and
of violence what do i mean by that
well it's quite easy when you're in in
times such as hours right now to know
why you're doing something but you don't
know and you maybe even have a vague
idea of what you're doing in the sense
that we know
what we are attempting to accomplish but
we don't always know all the details of
what are the consequences of what we do
what are we actually doing in the field
to human beings that i don't and i'm not
trying to be
dramatic in that what i mean is how do
we change our how do our souls change
when we take on violence as a tool
violence is an extremely
effective tool but it's also extremely
dangerous the job of the humanities is
to help us understand
and work with
the nature of human beings and in this
case to understand and make sure we
fully comprehend all the dimensions of
violence that we will be exposing
ourselves to that we'll be seeing that
we'll be feeling in our own
bodies and minds in the next several
weeks
so
while we planned this several months ago
it turns out that this is actually
a very timely topic
and i hope that what we'll have two
presentations by both of our speakers
and then we'll have a half hour to
really try to get into discussing these
issues for ourselves so the by the time
we leave here we have a lot more
information about war
maybe some of the feelings that we have
about it some of the hopes that we have
for it and some of the dangers and how
people will eventually be needing to
recover from the wounds of war
so with that i turn the podium over to
chris hedges
thank you very much
as i speak to you this morning
our nation is at war
americans and iraqis
have begun to die
and there appears to be nothing any of
us who oppose this war can now do the
french and the germans
remember these nations are our allies
reminded us that there is no link
between iraq and those who carried out
the crimes against humanity that took
place on 9 11.
they warned us
that unless we have credible evidence
that iraq
intended to use weapons of mass
destruction against us intended to
threaten our citizens or our nation we
had no right
to wage war
they warned us and they warn us now
that we have squandered the good will
the empathy the world felt for us after
9 11
folding in on ourselves building not a
broad coalition but a kind of troika
against terror with vladimir putin
and ariel sharon
two leaders who do not shrink in
palestine or chechnya from carrying out
acts of gratuitous
and senseless violence
and they warn us
that we will suffer the censure
and perhaps rage of much of the world
certainly one-fifth of the world's
population which is muslim
most of whom i remind you are not arab
if we do not maintain
rather than shatter
alliances
they warn us that real injustices
the israeli occupation of palestinian
land the brutal and corrupt
dictatorships we fund and arm in egypt
and saudi arabia mean that we will not
rid ourselves
of the extremists who hate us with bombs
indeed
we will swell their ranks
they warn us
and we do not listen
we listen now only to ourselves staring
into the pond to see our own
reflection and in that effort blinding
ourselves
the dogs of war
are unleashed
and i come to you this morning to warn
you that once the dogs of war are
unleashed
we do not control them
war has a force and a power of its own
it is a pandora's box
once this box is opened we become pawns
events we do not expect or anticipate
spiral out of control
the blunt and horrible instrument of war
is not like surgery
although with the talk of removing
saddam hussein it is often portrayed as
a simple surgical procedure
the massive industrial slaughter of
modern war
pushes us closer towards
our own destruction
and sadly when our friends warn us about
our folly we ridicule them
we make jokes on late night shows about
french culture
the things said to insult the french
are nothing short of racist
but racism is always the flip side of
nationalism it is why nationalism and
the blind patriotism that comes with it
is in my mind a disease
so listen to those jokes about the
french
and tremble for our own myopia
and desire for self-destruction
war
is a poison
it is a poison that at times we must
ingest
just as a cancer patient must ingest a
poison to survive
but if we do not understand the poison
of war
if we do not know how deadly that poison
is it can kill us
just as surely as the disease
and i want to speak of our security not
in ways you hear from the bush white
house
led by men who with the exception of
colin powell have not been to war
but from the perspective of someone who
has an intimate knowledge of war
i should have been immune to the siren
call of war
when my family visited museums my father
a veteran of world war ii
who was a presbyterian minister
steered us away from the ordered
displays of weapons
the vfw hall in skohari the small town
in upstate new york where i grew up was
a spot where men gathered to drink for
us who lived in a manse where there was
no alcohol
it might as well have been an opium den
when these panchi veterans sauntered
with their caps in the july 4th parade
my father watched them with disdain
he turned to me when i was about 10
during one of the parades and said
always remember most of those guys were
fixing the trucks
in the rear
during the vietnam war he told me that
if war was still being fought when i was
18
and i was drafted he would go to prison
with me
and to this day i have an image of
sitting in a jail cell with my dad
but war is where i ended up
i began covering insurgencies in el
salvador where i spent five years then
went to guatemala and nicaragua and
colombia through the first intifada in
the west bank and gaza the civil war in
the sudan and yemen
the uprisings in algeria and the punjab
the fall of the romanian dictator of
nikolai chaucheschu the gulf war the
kurdish rebellion in southeastern turkey
and northern iraq the war in bosnia and
finally to kosovo
i have been in ambushes on desolate
stretches of central american roads shot
at in the marshes of southern iraq
imprisoned in the sudan
beaten by saudi military police deported
from libya and iran
captured and held prisoner for a week by
the iraqi republican guard during the
shiite rebellion following the gulf war
strafed by mig-21s in bosnia fired upon
by serb snipers shelled for days in
sarajevo with deafening rounds of heavy
artillery that threw out thousands of
deadly bits of iron fragments
i have seen too much of violent death i
have tasted
too much of my own fear
i have painful memories that lie buried
and untouched
most of the time
it is never easy
when they surface
i went
as an idealist
as a young man who spent his teenage
years reading books on the holocaust and
the spanish civil war
as a young man who dreamed of an epic
battle against evil that could fill
his own life
and i thought i would find this battle
in latin america two decades ago when
military regimes in argentina chile and
el salvador
tortured and murdered dissidents and
ruthlessly crushed all popular descent
i left seminary to go to el salvador and
in that decision plunged myself
into the culture of war
we
have lost touch
with the essence of war
following our defeat in vietnam
we became a better nation we were
humbled
even humiliated
we asked questions about ourselves we
had not asked before
we were forced to see ourselves as
others saw us
and the sight was not always a pretty
one
we were forced to confront our own
capacity for evil
and in all this we understood not only
war
but more about ourselves
but that humility is gone
the good name of war has been
resurrected
it began under president reagan in
grenada and panama
and culminated with the persian gulf war
where we came to believe war was fun
another form of entertainment
we believe we can wage war and it can be
cost free
we believe in the same way the doomed
empires at the end of the 19th century
believed that our military technology
makes us invulnerable
or
we have come to believe as a spectator
sport the military and the press and
remember in wartime the press is always
part of the problem
have turned war into a vast video arcade
game its very essence death is hidden
from public view
there was no more candor in the persian
gulf war or the war in afghanistan and
there will be no more candor in this war
with iraq than there was in vietnam
but an age of live feeds and satellite
television the state and the military
has perfected the appearance of candor
and because we no longer understand war
no longer understand that it can all go
horribly wrong
we no longer realize that war begins by
calling for the annihilation of others
but ends if we do not know when to make
or maintain peace
with self-annihilation
we flirt
given the potency of modern industrial
weapons with our own destruction and we
do so not for the vaunted war on terror
but for america's right to control the
world's oil supply for what a senior
administration official told the new
york times were the spoils of war
if this was a war on terror
we would be attacking north korea a
nation that has at least two or three
nuclear weapons and 5 000 tons of poison
gas and germs plus the missiles and
artillery to deliver them to seoul the
37 you thousand u.s troops in south
korea all of japan and u.s bases in
okinawa and guam
but we do not attack north korea which
is also trying to build an icbm to
deliver a nuclear warhead to the
continental united states but we try to
buy them off with 4 billion in oil food
and nuclear reactors we plead we cajole
we turn our backs on a problem a problem
that like al qaeda i believe is a
serious and a real crisis for a war that
is about american empire
the seduction of war is insidious
because so much of what we are told
about war is true
it does create a feeling of comradeship
which obliterates our alienation and
makes us for perhaps the only time in
our life
feel that we belong
war allows us to rise above our small
stations in life we find nobility in a
cause and feelings of selflessness
and even bliss
and at a time of soaring deficits and
financial scandals of the very
deterioration of our domestic fabric
war
is a fine diversion
war for those who enter into combat
has a dark beauty
filled with the monstrous and the
grotesque
the bible calls it
the lust of the eye and warns believers
against it
war gives us a distorted sense of self
it gives us meaning
and once in war the conflict obliterates
the past and the future
all is one heady
intoxicating present
you feel every heartbeat in war
colors are brighter
your mind races ahead of itself you are
aware in ways you never were before
war
is zen
and they do tell you this
this is not a lie
moreover war allows you to engage in
lusts and passions you kept hidden in
the deepest most private interiors of
your fantasy life
it allows you to destroy
not
only things but human life and in that
moment of wholesale destruction you feel
the power of the divine the power to
revoke another person's charter to live
on this earth
the frenzy of this destruction and when
unit discipline breaks down or there was
no unit discipline to begin with frenzy
is the right word
sees armed bans consumed and crazed by
the poisonous elixir that our power to
bring about the obliteration of others
brings
all things including human beings become
objects
objects to either gratify or destroy or
both
and almost no one is immune the
contagion of the crowd sees to that
force
seymour writes
is as pitiless to the man who possesses
it or thinks he does
as it is to its victims
the second it crushes
the first it intoxicates
only when we are in the midst of
conflict does the shallowness of much of
our lives become apparent
does the emptiness of a society that
seeks fulfillment in the acquisition of
things and wealth and power
push us to peer into our own hollowness
trivia dominates our conversations and
increasingly our airwaves
and the purpose of war is enticing
it gives us a resolve
it allows us to be noble and those that
have the least meaning in their lives
the impoverished palestinian refugees in
gaza the disenfranchised north african
immigrants in france
even the legions of youth that live in
the splendid indolence and safety of the
industrialized world are all susceptible
to war's appeal
i do not miss war but i miss what it
brought
i can never say i was happy in the midst
of the fighting in el salvador or bosnia
or kosovo but i had a sense of purpose
and this is equality war shares with
love
for we are also able to choose fealty
and self-sacrifice over security
for those we love
this is why war at its inception
always looks and feels like love the
chief emotion war destroys
we are tempted indeed even
encouraged to reduce life to a simple
search for happiness
happiness however withers if there is no
meaning the other temptation is to
disavow the search for happiness in
order to be faithful to that which
provides meaning but to live only for
meaning indifferent to all happiness
makes us fanatic
self-righteous
cold
it leaves us cut off from our own
humanity
and the humanity of others
the ancient greeks understood the
perverse attraction between love
and death in wartime when achilles kills
penthecilia the queen of the amazons in
the trojan war he falls in love with her
as she expires
on the battlefield
he murders love
aphrodite the goddess of love had an
illicit affair with aries the god of war
who was hated by nearly all the other
gods
with the exception of the god of the
underworld to whom he steadily brought
new souls
i want to talk to you about an emotion
you may feel now
you will certainly feel as this war
progresses
comradeship
and i want to warn you not to confuse
this with friendship
with love
there are those who will insist that the
comradeship of war is love
that the ecstatic glow that makes us in
war feel as one people one entity is
real
but this is part of war's intoxication
in war
we no longer feel alone
we connect with strangers even with
people we do not like we feel we belong
that we are wrapped in the embrace of
the nation
the community
in short we no longer feel alienated and
as this feeling dissipated
in the weeks after 9 11 there was a kind
of nostalgia for its warm glow
wartime always brings with it
comradeship
it is what soldiers seek in reunions
after the war to recreate
and we think this is love this is
friendship but
it is the very opposite
as jay glenn gray points out in his book
warriors reflections on men in battle
friends are predetermined
friendship takes place between men and
women who possess an intellectual and
emotional affinity for each other
many of us will admit if we are honest
that we never really had a friend
and the most fortunate of us
have very few
but comradeship that ecstatic bliss that
comes with belonging to the crowd in
wartime is
within our reach we can all have
comrades
the danger the external threat that
comes when we have an enemy
does not create friendship
it creates
comradeship
and those in wartime
just as those who live through danger
and trial as a group are deceived about
what they are undergoing this is why
once the war ends once the period of
trial is over these comrades once again
become strangers to us
and this is why
after war
we sink
into such despair
in fact comradeship is the very opposite
of friendship in friendship there is a
deepening of our sense of self we become
through friends more aware of who we are
and what we are about we find ourselves
in the eyes
of the friend
friends probe and question and challenge
us to make us more complete
they draw the secrets out of us and know
finally that inner core of being
in comradeship
the kind that comes to us in patriotic
fervor there is a complete suppression
of self-awareness
self-knowledge
self-possession
comrades seek to lose their identities
in wartime
in the collective rush of a common cause
a common purpose
they are like erotic lovers
in comradeship life is ecstatic
corporate as opposed to friendship where
life is singular
individual
in comradeship there are no demands on
the self this is part of its appeal and
one of the reasons we miss it and seek
to recreate it
comradeship allows us to escape the
demands on the self that is part of
friendship
and this is why once the war is over
once the danger that has linked us
together is past the feelings we have
are extinguished
in wartime
we no longer face death
alone
but as a group
and this makes death easier to bear
we a noble
self-sacrifice for the other
in short
we worship death
and this is what the god of war demands
from us
think
of what it means
to die
for a friend
the act is deliberate
and painful
there is no ecstasy
for friends dying is hard and bitter
lose
the dialogues the the dialogue they have
and cherish
may never be recreated
friends do not the way comrades do love
death
and sacrifice
to friends the prospect of death is
frightening
and this is why friendship
or let me say love
is the most potent
enemy of war
you do not see war
in the images of war
films novels and the mythic narratives
the government and the press spins out
for you
war is carefully packaged the way
tobacco or liquor companies package
their own poisons but the titillation is
there although it is given a coherency
and logic it rarely has in battle
we taste a bit of wars exhilaration in
the images
but are safe
and in this safety we are fooled into
believing that we can control war
instead of the awful fact that war
always controls and ultimately if we do
not get out destroys us
we can thrill in the perversity of war
even as we watch films or read books
that are meant to denounce war
it is almost impossible to produce
anti-war films or books or documentaries
that also present images of battle it is
like trying to condemn pornography while
showing erotic love scenes
the puri and fascination with violent
death
overpowers the message
there is a film by renee clement the
french filmmaker called le joue interdee
or forbidden games it is about two
children who play war games
in world war ii in france
they bury things
they become obsessed with death but
there is only one scene right at the
beginning
when they are attacked by german planes
as they flee with a column of french
refugees the little girl's parents are
killed and she is told they have been
buried in the ground she thinks
repeatedly of her mother and father
under the earth
the boy and orphan girl are shown in a
village all they do is bury dolls dead
bugs animals until they have to kill to
create corpses to bury their lives their
focus their actions are concerned only
with death
this is one of the best insights into
the brutalizing effect of war what it
does to culture
to children
to civilization
death
is inherent
to war
and yet
we are sadly unaware of how war distorts
us how it brings out within us the
morbid the brutal the macabre we embrace
instead the abstract words of glory
honor courage patriotism to mask the
reality of war
war is part of the modern industrial
landscape indeed its tools are often the
cutting edges of technology
modern society created industrial
warfare in world war one it created ways
in which thousands of people who never
saw their attackers could die
in an instant
and weapons that carry out this
impersonal mass slaughter
are beautiful
they are well crafted sleek and harbor
within them awesome power
the machines of war
the planes
the tanks the heavy machine guns the
huge hulking howitzers the helicopters
are pieces of art
i have seen them at work
they are angels of death
streaking through the sky
i was once with a unit of guerrillas in
el salvador when some huey helicopters
raced in over a lake to hunt us down
we hid in the ruins of an abandoned
village darting from wall-to-wall
standing with our backs to the shattered
bricks so our hunters could not see us
as they passed low overhead
even then
as i looked up
at these machines that were trying to
kill me i found them seductive
and we are the biggest dealer of war on
the planet
we sell more arms abroad than all of the
other countries in the world combined we
sell these weapons to be used to empower
others to kill
we promise the user's victory or the
flip side the death and defeat of their
enemies
once these weapons are acquired once a
state or an ethnic group feels
emboldened with these weapons they must
then manufacture
war itself
manufacture the need for war
we make the tools and many times we make
the war too
the chief institutions that peddle war
are the state and the press this has
been true since the creation of the
modern war correspondent in the crimean
war nearly every war correspondent sees
his or her mission as sustaining
civilian and army morale
the advent of photography and film did
little to alter
the incentive to boost morale for the
lie and war is almost always the lie of
mission
the blunder is in senseless slaughter by
our generals
the ruthless murder of prisoners and
innocents and the horrors of wounds
are rarely disclosed at least during a
mythic war to the public
and when that myth is punctured as it
was in vietnam only then does the media
begin to report in a sensory rather than
a mythic manner but it simply reacts to
a public that has changed its perception
of war
newspapers and televisions have always
found that mythic war reporting sells
papers and boost ratings
look at cnn fox msnbc
real reporting does not
the coverage in the last persian gulf
war was typical the international press
willingly administered a restrictive
pool system on behalf of the military
one that saw a handful of reporters
escorted by officers among the troops
these pools filed reports to the bulk of
the press that sat rewriting the stories
or sharing the pool video in hotel rooms
and in the management of that war the
press parroted back to you lie
after lie
after lie
think back for those of you who remember
what images you were fed during the
persian gulf war
from the coverage you would believe that
we used precision guided weapons to hit
specific targets take out planes and
scud missiles
but these weapons were only a tiny
percentage
i was with the marines on the front line
i went into kuwait with them and night
after night i watched huge fireballs
shoot up from the iraqi lines where
vietnam war
era b-52 bombers were dropping hundreds
of thousands of pounds of iron
fragmentation bombs on southern iraq
and i was in southern iraq after the war
where perhaps as many as 85 000 iraqi
civilians were killed and i saw the
devastation the destroyed water
purification plants the wrecked roads
bridges electrical plants factories
buildings
but this was not the perception handed
to the press
and no one was there to report it
just as there were no reporters allowed
to cover the return of our own war dead
to dover air force base because those
who wage war today for american empire
do not want you to see what war is what
war is about because you might think
twice about waging it
not that any of this is new
in wartime
the first casualty senator hiram johnson
said in 1917 when war comes
is truth
when iraqi troops seized the saudi
border town of hafji sending
saudi soldiers fleeing out in a panic
the flight was covered up
two french photographers and i watched
as frantic saudi soldiers raced away
from the fighting dozens crowded on a
fire truck that tore down the road u.s
marines were called in to push the
iraqis back we stood on rooftops with
young radio marine operators who called
in airstrikes as units pushed through
the streets under heavy fire
yet
back in riyadh in dahran the world was
told of argallan saudi allies defending
their homeland the press bus stopped a
few miles down the road allowed
television reporters to do stand-ups
with a distant sound of artillery and
smoke as a backdrop for the lie the
pentagon wanted told
once in a conflict
once we live in the midst of fighting
we are moved from the abstract to the
real from the mythic to the sensory no
soldier after 30 seconds of combat
believes the myth anymore it is why
wounded marines threw their bedpans at
john wayne when he visited them in a
hospital in world war ii
when this move takes place we have
nothing to do with a world not at war
the world when we return to it is viewed
from the end of a very long tunnel
there they still believe
there they do not understand we feel
different wiser
greater and that experience is so
overpowering that if we can control our
fear we go back to seek it out again
war is addictive
indeed it is the most potent narcotic
invented
by humankind
the first time i was in an ambush was in
the salvadoran town of suchitoto it was
a dreary peasant outpost made up of
stucco and mud and waddle huts off the
main road the town was surrounded by the
farabundo marti national liberation
front rebels who when i arrived in el
salvador were winning the war
the government forces kept a small
garrison in the town although its relief
columns were regularly ambushed as they
ambled down the small strip of asphalt
surrounded by high grass
it was one of the most dangerous spots
in el salvador
the rebels launched an attack to take
the town and a convoy of reporters and
cars marked with tv and masking tape on
the windshields high-tailed it to the
small bridge that led to the lonely
stretch of road into suchitoto
we stopped for the familiar ritual of
getting high
something as a print reporter who could
scramble to safety i did not do but
something the photographers who would
stand and take pictures found a
necessary bomb to their nerves
then we moved slowly down the road the
odd round fired ahead or behind us
we made it to the edge of town where we
ran into rebel units now accustomed to
the follies of the press
on foot we moved through the deserted
streets the firing from the garrison
becoming louder as we weaved our way
with rebel units to the siege that had
been set up
and as i rounded a corner several full
bursts of automatic fire rent the air
bullets hit the mud wall behind me
we dove onto the dirt the rebels i was
with began to fire noisy rounds from
their m16 assault rifles the scent of
cordite fill the air dust was in my eyes
i did not move i began to pray
god i prayed if you get me out of here i
will never do this again
i felt powerless humiliated weak
i dared not move i could see the little
sprays of dirt the bullets threw up
rebels around me were wounded and crying
out in pain one died yelling out in a
sad cadence for his mother his desperate
and final plea cut through the absurd
posturing of soldiering
at first his cries haunted me soon
i only wished him to be quiet
mama
mama
mama
the fire fight seemed to go on for an
eternity i cannot say how long i lay
there it could have been a few minutes
it could have been an hour
here was war real war
sensory war not the war of the movies
and the novels i had consumed in my
youth it was horrifying
confusing
numbing
and nothing like the myth i had been
peddled there was nothing gallant or
heroic
nothing redeeming
i realized at once that it controlled me
i would never control it
in a lull i made a dash across an empty
square to find shelter behind a house my
heart was racing adrenaline cursed
through my bloodstream i was safe
i made it back to the capitol and like
most war correspondents i soon
considered the experience a great cosmic
joke most people
after such an incident would learn to
stay away
i was hooked
drawn into the world of war it becomes
hard to escape
it perverts and destroys you it pushes
you closer and closer to your own
annihilation spiritual emotional
and finally physical
i covered the war in el salvador from
1983 to 1988 by the end i had a nervous
twitch in my face i was evacuated three
times by the u s embassy because of tips
that the death squads planned to kill me
yet each time i came back
i accepted with a grim fatalism that i
would be killed in el salvador i cannot
articulate why i accepted my own
destruction and cannot now there came to
be a part of me maybe it is a part in
all of us that decided i would rather
die like this than go back to the dull
routine
the chance to exist for an intense and
overpowering moment even if it meant
certain death seemed worth it in the
midst of war and very stupid once the
war ended
when i finally did leave my last act was
in a frenzy of rage and anguish to leap
over the klm counter in the airport in
costa rica because of a perceived slight
by a hapless airline clerk
i beat him to the floor as his
bewildered colleagues locked themselves
in the back room behind the counter
blood streamed down my face from where
he had thrust his pen into my cheek
war's sickness
had become mine
during the war in el salvador i worked
with a photographer who covered the war
had a slew of close calls and then
called it quits he moved to miami and
took pictures of tepid domestic stories
for one of the news weeklies but life in
florida was flat
dull uninteresting
he could not adjust
and soon came back
from the moment he stepped off the plane
it was clear
he had returned to die
just as there are some soldiers or war
correspondents that seem to us immortal
and whose loss comes as a sobering
reminder that death has no favorites
there are also those in war who are
locked in a grim embrace with death from
which they cannot escape
he was frightening to behold
a walking corpse
he was shot through the back in a
firefight and died in less than a minute
sigmund freud divided the forces in
human nature between the arrows instinct
the impulse within us that propels us to
become close to others to preserve and
conserve
and the thanatos or death instinct the
impulse that works towards the
annihilation of all living things
including ourselves
for freud these forces were in eternal
conflict
he was thus pessimistic about ever
eradicating war
all human history he argued in
civilization and its discontents is a
tug of war between these two instincts
taste enough of war and you come to
believe the stoics were right
we will in the end all consume ourselves
in a vast
conflagration there is a constant search
in war to find new perversities new
forms of death when the initial flush
fades a rear guard and finally futile
effort to ward off the boredom of
routine death this is why we would drive
into towns in bosnia and find bodies
crucified on the sides of barns are
decapitated and mutilated it is why
those slain in combat are treated as
trophies belonging to the killers turned
into grotesque pieces of performance art
i know soldiers who to this day carry in
their wallets the identity cards of men
they know they have killed they take
them everywhere they show them to you
with the imploring look of a lost child
they will never understand
the job of killing allows our senses to
command our bodies the killing whips
fighters into greater orgies of
destruction hedonism and perversion
spirals out of control those who work
hard all their lives are reviled as
dupes and fools they hunt the soup
kitchens the loyalty they express to the
state or to the institutions they worked
for
has left them as beggars
they collect pensions when they are paid
that amount to a few dollars the normal
order is turned upside down
decency sobriety honesty and moderation
no longer pay
better to give yourself up to the lust
of war
in war
we deform ourselves
our essence
we give up individual conscience maybe
even consciousness for the contagion of
the crowd the rush of patriotism the
belief that we must all stand together
as a nation
in moments of extremity to make a moral
choice to defy war's enticement
to defend love
can be self-destructive
shakespeare shows this in anthony and
cleopatra
as he does in the final defeat
of corey elena's
in the rise to power we always become
smaller
power absorbs us
and once power is obtained we are its
pawn
as in richard iii the all-powerful
prince who molded the world we fall prey
to the forces we thought we had
harnessed
when the mask of war slips away and the
rot and corruption is uncovered when it
turns sour and rank when the myth is
exposed as fraud we feel soiled and
spent
it is then that we sink into despair
in the arab-israeli 1973 war almost a
third of all israeli casualties were due
to psychiatric causes and the war lasted
only a few days
a world war ii study determined that
after 60 days of continuous combat 98 of
all surviving soldiers will have become
psychiatric casualties they found that a
common trait among the 2 percent who
were able to endure sustained combat was
a predisposition towards aggressive
psychopathic personalities
during the war in el salvador soldiers
could serve in the army for three or
four years or longer virtually until
they psychologically are physically
collapsed in garrison towns commanders
ban the sale of sedatives because of
abuse by troops
in the war
in this war the emotionally maimed were
common i interviewed a 19 year old
salvadoran army sergeant who had spent
five years fighting and suddenly lost
his vision after his unit walked into a
rebel ambush the rebels killed 11
soldiers in the fire fight including his
closest friend
a couple dozen soldiers were wounded he
was unable to see again
until he was placed in the army hospital
i have these horrible headaches he told
me sitting on the edge of his hospital
bed there is shrapnel in my head i keep
telling the doctors to take it out
but the doctors told me that he had no
head wounds
i have seen other soldiers go deaf or
stop speaking
or simply shake
without being able to stop
war is necrophilia
and this necrophilia is central to
soldiering just as as it is central to
the makeup of suicide bombers and
terrorists the necrophilia is hidden
under platitudes about duty or
comradeship it waits especially in
moments when we seem to have little to
live for and no hope or in moments when
the intoxication of war is at its pitch
to be unleashed
and when we spend long enough in war it
comes to us as a kind of release a fatal
and seductive embrace that can
consummate the long flirtation with our
own destruction
war ascendant wipes out eros
it wipes out all delicacy and tenderness
and this is why those in war swing from
rank sentimentality to perversion with
little in between
when we see this
when we see our addiction for what it is
when we understand ourselves and how war
has perverted us
life becomes hard to bear
john steele a cameraman who spent years
in war zones had a nervous breakdown
in a crowded heathrow airport in 1994
after returning from sarajevo
he understood the reality of his work a
reality that stripped away the
self-righteous high octane gloss
i came back from sarajevo he said we
were in a place called sniper's alley
and i filmed a girl there who had been
hit in the neck by a sniper's bullet i
filmed her in the ambulance
and only after she was dead i suddenly
understood that the last thing she had
seen
was the reflection of the lens of the
camera i was holding in front of her
face
a year after the war in sarajevo i sat
with bosnian friends who had suffered
horribly
a young woman
liliana had lost her father a serb who
refused to join the besieging serb
forces around the city
she had been forced a few days earlier
to identify his corpse
his body was lifted the water running
out of the sides of a rotting coffin
from a small park
for reburial in a central cemetery
she was emigrating for australia soon
where she told me i will marry a man who
has never heard of this war and raise
children that will be told nothing about
it nothing about the country i am from
liliana was young but the war had
exacted a toll her cheeks were hollow
her air hair dry and brittle her teeth
were decayed and some had broken into
jagged bits she had no money for a
dentist she hoped to fix them in
australia
yet all she and her friends did that
afternoon was lament the days when they
lived in fear and hunger emaciated
targeted by serbian gunners on the
heights above
they did not wish back the suffering and
yet they admitted these may have been
the fullest days of their lives
they looked at me in despair
i knew them when they were being pounded
by hundreds of shells a day
when they had no water to bathe in or
wash their clothes when they huddled in
unheated darkened flats his sniper
bullets hit the walls around them but
what they expressed was real it was the
disillusionment with a sterile feudal
and empty present peace had again peeled
back the void that the rush of war of
battle had filled
once again they were as perhaps we all
are alone
no longer bound by that common sense of
struggle no longer given the opportunity
to be noble heroic no longer sure what
life was about or what had meant
the old comradeship however false that
allowed them to love men and women they
hardly knew indeed whom they may not
have liked before the war had vanished
with the last shot
moreover they had seen that all the
sacrifice had been for naught
they had been as we all are in war
betrayed
the corrupt old communist party bosses
who became nationalists overnight and
got them into the mess in the first
place had grown rich off their suffering
and were still in power
they depended on handouts from the
international community they knew the
lie of war the mockery of their idealism
and struggled with their shattered
illusions they understood that their
cause once as fashionable in certain
intellectual circles as they were
themselves lay forgotten
no longer did actors politicians and
artists scramble to come and visit
during the ceasefires acts that were
often ones of gross self-promotion
and yet
they wished it all back
and i did too
a year later i received a christmas card
it was signed liliana from australia it
had no return address
i never heard from her again
but many of those i worked with as a war
correspondent during the past 20 years
did not escape
they could not break free from the dance
with death they wandered from conflict
to conflict seeking always one more hit
by then i was back in gaza and found
myself pinned down in another ambush a
young palestinian 15 feet away was shot
through the chest
and killed
it was time to break free to let go to
accept that none of this would or could
come back
and i knew then it was over
i was lucky to get out alive
kurt shork brilliant courageous driven
could not let go
he died in an ambush in may of 2000 in
sierra leone along with another friend
miguel gil moreno his entrapment his
embrace of thanatos of the death
instinct was never mentioned at the
sterile and antiseptic memorial service
staged for him in washington
everyone tiptoed around it but those of
us who knew him understood
that he had been consumed
i had worked with kurt for 10 years
starting in northern iraq
literate
funny it seems the brave are often funny
he and i passed books back and forth in
our struggle to make sense of the
madness around us
his loss is a hole that will never be
filled
his ashes were placed in a lion's
cemetery in sarajevo for the victims of
the war
i flew to sarajevo and met the british
documentary filmmaker dan reed was an
overcast november day we stood over the
grave and downed a pint of whiskey
dan lit a candle i recited a poem the
roman lyric poet catullus had written to
honor his dead brother
by strangers coasts and waters many days
at sea
i come here for the rights of your
unworlding
bringing for you the dead these last
gifts of the living and my words
vain sounds for the man of dust
alas my brother you have been taken from
me
you have been taken from me and by cold
chance turn to shadow
and my pain
here are the foods of the old ceremony
appointed long ago for the starvings
under the earth
your brother's tears have made them wet
take into eternity
my hail
and my farewell
it was there
among a few thousand war dead
that kurt belonged he died because he
could not free himself from war
he was trying to replicate what he had
found in sarajevo but he could not
war could never be new again
kurt had been in east timor in chechnya
sierra leone
i was sure meant nothing to him
curtin miguel could not let go
they would be the first to admit it
spend long enough in war and you cannot
fit in anywhere else
it finally kills you
it is not a new story
it starts out like love
but it is death
war is the beautiful young nymph in the
fairy tale that when kissed
exhales the vapors of the underworld
the ancient greeks had a word for such a
fate
ekpyrosis
it means to be consumed by a ball of
fire
they used it
to describe heroes
thank you
we say
thank you very much to chris uh i have
made a terrible blunder in my way and i
realized that we need to end before too
long in order to allow time for book
signing however i think it's very
important that we follow up this
discussion with uh remembering what
chris said about love is the most potent
enemy of war and what happens to those
who as chris hedges has talked about
survive war and attempt to come back to
something like love and life and so i
want to give
some time to kate to talk to you about
that and her work
and reduce it with you all's permission
will reduce the book signing a little
bit is that okay
okay
thank you
i watched your faces
um as you talked as you listened to
chris
and i watched um the the feelings that
people were showing
as a clinical psychologist
that's what i do with my life
is i
am with people
and i look to see the effects of words
the effects of violence the effects of
war of trauma on people
and the message that i want to give and
bring to you today is one of hope
that the effects of violence are the
same no matter what the cause of
violence
whether i my career started out working
with
men and women who had been sexually
abused who had experienced domestic
violence
in the 20 years of my career i've been
to
countries where i've worked with people
who have had refugee experiences from
vietnam from cambodia from afghanistan
from iran from iraq from bosnia serbia
northern ireland
south africa turkey israel and what i've
seen across
across all the cultures
is that the healing components of what
can be given to humans are the same
i work in places like i was in taiwan
yesterday and i don't even understand
the language but i can see how people
can come together how they can reclaim
their souls
that the effects of violence does hurt
your mind hurts your heart hurts your
body hurt your connections with others
and as a traditionally trained
psychologist i was trained to talk to
people to help them make sense of their
experiences
but i found that that wasn't enough
that it wasn't enough to help people
just understand some of the lust for war
that chris talked about some of the
effects of violence the nightmares the
shattering of relationships the
inability to take the risk to trust
again
and i became trained in a method of
experiential psychotherapy
where i
witness with people
in groups
these
experiences of horror that are replayed
that are not just kept inside the psyche
inside the mind but using teams trained
teams of other psychologists social
workers
um humanities people that are joining
together with our work now
we recreate the scenes of horror face
them together as a community
and find new ways to come together put
new endings to the haunting images that
people carry around from
experiences from internal experiences of
something like incest between one one
person in the family and another person
in the family to the horrors of war
my own experience
includes that of family addiction and
childhood sexual abuse so i come from a
place of speaking from knowing that
healing can happen
and again seeing it time and time again
the the
experiences of people taking in a group
the ability to try to trust again to
speak of their horrors to put it out and
share it until we can face the violence
that happens till we can really name it
and look at it
and speak it without shame speak it
without blame there
it just stays stuck it stays inside the
humans
and so
the the model that i work with the
therapeutic spiral model is a way of
sharing that in community
sharing the horrors so that you see not
just the horrors but you see the moments
of healing
and what i've seen is that in all the
places i've worked around the world the
moments of healing
are the same
people let down the defenses
they look in each other's eyes again and
they're willing to take the risk to love
willing to take the risk to reconnect
to find their souls to connect with a
sense of spirituality
and to reach beyond the horrors that are
are now being repeated again as i was
flying home yesterday on the plane i was
hoping to get home before war broke out
i was in australia on 9 11
and so i was away from my country on
that day and i didn't want that to
happen again i wanted to be able to be
home with the people that i care about
with the people that care about me to
feel that safety of connection
and the the we have we've started a
non-profit organization therapeutic
spiral international three years ago and
the goal of our organization is to
create teams and create communities of
healing
so that people can come together in this
way of experiential therapy in a way
where you don't just talk and analyze
what happened but you actually use drama
use art use sound and music use
expression to be able to bring back the
life into people
as chris said you lose your feelings you
lose your your humanness
when you experience violence no matter
what kind of violence it is
and if you can go back to that moment
and in and change it by now
re-experiencing
the coming together of humans
the being able to go beyond it it it
becomes an experience that is more
ecstatic than the addiction of war
the ability to really be with other
beings as they're able to risk again
after unspeakable horrors one of the
reasons that talk therapy you know
doesn't work for trauma survivors
is that the horrors that have happened
are beyond words
the latest research shows that trauma no
matter violence no matter how it's
experienced no matter what the cause of
it is it damages the structures of the
brain
that the the unprocessed traumas the
stories that that chris shared the
things that you all know for yourself
that we'll see on television in the next
few days damages the structure of the
brain and the the experiences get held
in the emotional centers of your brain
stuck back here in the
limbic system it's not accessible to
words
there's not a way into the brain
through just talking about things you
have to involve your body you have to
involve your emotions you have to
involve the contact one-on-one to
another human being
to have the experience that caused the
brain damage the the neurotransmitters
to be off to not work right to be able
to shift around to the frontal cortex so
words could become important again
words of meaning that you have
that the sense that you make so that the
myths do get broken
so that you can speak new truth and can
speak about the horrors of what happens
i've seen this the shattered psyches the
the heart the shattered bodies and minds
and spirits of the humans that have gone
through the worst experiences imaginable
for many years i i listened and i
watched and i heard stories of sexual
trauma
and then i started working with refugees
and i found there
that the the acts that humans can do to
each other the tortures the religious
and
political persecutions are so far beyond
anything that you can truly hold in your
mind to believe happened
and then what i saw is that you can also
find the healing for those experiences i
have now written witnessed you know
thousands and thousands of times of
people coming together in community to
be able to risk again to try to find the
way past the horror past the terrors
the experience of violence for everybody
is one of terror
the core experience being terrorized and
being helpless that causes mental health
psychiatric problems such as
post-traumatic stress disorder that
wasn't even a diagnosis until 1984.
even long before many many centuries and
centuries of war and then finally the
effects of violence got a name
post-traumatic stress disorder it's and
it's a mental health response a
psychiatric response to real trauma it's
not people making up things that
happened they actually experience a
trauma the nightmares the flashbacks the
body memories the ways that the trauma
continues to haunt are real
they're not be people being crazy
they're people trying to work through
their brain is trying to work through
the old
experiences
and i chose the the title the
therapeutic spiral because
violence is like a tornado that's out of
control
you have a sense of not having any
control and so the spiral begins to give
an image that people can bridge that you
can choose to spiral and most
importantly you can choose to spiral
slowly and deeply into the experiences
of horror that you want to have healed
and you can spiral back up with new
words it's it's it's not enough to just
you know hold the images they need to be
shared with other people
and to to slowly step by step find the
ways to hold them in consciousness
so instead of walking
across an enemy line alone
in
the replay of it in the re-experience of
it you would walk now with somebody
playing a role of a guardian angel of a
good enough mother of your best friend
who didn't die
and it doesn't it doesn't change the
reality but what it does is change the
images
change the feelings you get a chance to
cry and to grieve and to and to rage
with other people not to just have to
hold it all in
the way roberta and i have connected is
to to bring the principles of clinical
psychology that i use in the therapeutic
spiral model with the humanities to
bring it even more into the community
you know i've worked with therapy groups
i've worked with large groups of 200
people in south africa we had um you
know
men and women mostly women who had
walked seven and eight miles to get to
the workshop because they heard that
maybe there was just something new to
learn about how to help bring healing to
their
to their
people to their families
and the hunger for that is so huge and
so as i worked with these larger and
larger groups my question became how do
you take it beyond therapy how can you
take it out into the streets the healing
that i've witnessed in small therapy
groups in in groups of people of 25 you
know how can we take it out and reach
into the community and i think the
humanities is the answer for that
the
the literature that can come out of
people's sharing their stories
the dramatic performances the creative
expressions
that can help people
not only share the horror stories but
find the celebration of the reconnection
of being able to come back together
again
that the anthropology is in itself a
reason a support for experiential
treatment as being a treatment of choice
for trauma you know the the traditional
methods of healing from shamans all all
over the world native american ones
korean shamans aboriginals they all have
experience at the core of the healing
they do rituals they do ceremonies the
the priests the shamans they take on the
energy of the evil that's being faced
and now
clinical psychology research is showing
why that's true why experiential therapy
is the treatment of choice it's because
of what trauma does to the brain
and talk therapy cannot access
that in the same way i mean if you want
to stay and talk therapy for seven years
and do you know psychoanalysis for five
days a week you'll probably have that
experience because you'll learn to trust
again
you'll learn to be able to connect
one-on-one to a human you'll be able to
share your stories
but we're trying to find through through
a new program action against trauma how
to bring it into the community so it
doesn't have to be an elite way for
people to heal how many people in the
world can do one-on-one therapy i mean
it's it's not even a conceivable idea
for that but how you can bring people
together in larger larger groups to have
new experiences together where they will
take the risk
to trust to find faith to connect with
others that that's that's what i've
witnessed and that is the message that i
want to want to share today you know as
i did here the stories of horror and as
i looked out at your faces i saw the
despair i saw the fear of us coming into
war again
of that becoming now prevalent in our
faces
but if we can look at and look at it and
stare it in the face with and really
look at the evil and name it
we can i believe find hope to stop the
generational trans transmission of
trauma that's what happens you know you
have a trauma that you don't deal with
and you don't mean to pass it on
you mean to do whatever you can to try
to make it better for the next
generation but as long as it stays
locked inside it gets passed on it's
passed on to our children onto our
societies onto our culture that's why
war keeps repeating you know it's not
just the lust for the violence and the
power but it's that we don't know how to
do it any differently
and so to to help find new experiences
and i've been able to find that you know
people do that all over the world
they're happy to come together in new
ways to really find the way to to become
human again to connect with their own
spirits and with the spirits of the
other people
and i'm not sure how my time is so i
think i'm just about at an end here um
no that's good it's um
i mean it is because the essence of what
i wanted to say is about the hope
i mean you know my book takes you
through step by step of you know how you
can practice experiential therapy in a
in a safe way
but that's not really the message i
wanted to bring here today most of you
probably aren't clinicians some of you
may be and the book is helpful just in
in being able to understand about trauma
but
but the to leave you with the message
that we don't have to end in despair
that as we watch the images of the
violence that will occur on the
television and we'll be impacted by that
you can get secondary ptsd just from
watching it on the television
you know in many ways we as americans
are a very privileged
society and a privileged group of people
and i've seen that as i've gone around
the world and seen the
lack of of privilege
and i believe we have a responsibility
as a culture
to reach out with messages of hope i
mean if we could only spend the money
that we're spending on the bombs
in humanitarian aid and truly
make a difference but we can only do
that one person at a time so each person
can take their own responsibility for
finding those new experiences whether
it's through a therapy model or through
a community practice or through
however you connect
is the message that i hope to leave you
with
all right now we have the uh
terrible quandary
of uh signing or questions
and um
what do you guys want to do
are you going to tell me what you want
to do you're going to ask a question
okay i think what we'll do we have 15
minutes
right
okay and
i know this is against the rules but i
come from the foundation so i can
take the heat later if this is okay with
you i'd like to have 10 minutes of
questions
and then we'll we'll stay a little bit
later to to do book signing is that all
right
okay
okay
they have to get set up
okay
okay let's
go on for a few minutes
okay i'm really sorry but um
we just had all have so much to say okay
and no you guys have questions all right
questions yes sir yes thank you
uh chris let me just say i
thought your words were perspicacious
and brilliant true
here we are a small group of people
you know get the word out get the word
out but with the immensity of the media
just drowning us
how do you get that word out how do you
demonstrate to more americans of what
that
triumvirate is doing in the white house
the problem in wartime is that
it always begins with the destruction of
culture of our own culture
and
the most effective the way the state has
to accomplish that is by taking away our
language
and
it gives us the words and the cliches
by which we speak about the experience
we're undergoing
so
that it becomes very hard to think
outside the box
and
these i don't own a television
because
i don't want
those
phrases pounded into my brain on 24-hour
news cycles
the war on terror
countdown with saddam
showdown with iraq
once you rob
language once they
give us the words by which we have to
speak about what we're undergoing it
becomes almost impossible to express the
disquiet that we feel and i think that
many of us feel
we saw this in bosnia
and in a place like mostar where you had
young men who had grown up together who
had gone to school together attended
each other's weddings slept in each
other's houses
sitting in trenches often a few yards
apart where at night they could still
speak to each other killing each other
yet they didn't have the words by which
they could express what it was they're
doing when you ask them why they were
fighting they spat back at you
those kind of
cliches that had been that were pounded
into them day after day after day after
day
and i'm not picking on the bosnians
because now we're the same
and what it does is turn the other into
an object it denigrates the other it
turns the other into a caricature
and
when we go to war of course the other
side is doing the same
so that until you can recreate an
authentic language
and that has a lot to do with
allowing authentic culture which is
always about self-examination and
self-critical to again become ascendant
or at least have its proper place in a
society you are rendered mute i think
we've all become in wartime like othello
who's so consumed by jealousy that
at
the final one of the final moments
before he turns to kill desdemona
he says goats and monkeys goats and
monkeys
the most
poetic man in venice
a man who wooed not only
his love but the state with words
and that's why in bosnia or in cyprus
you do not have peace
you have the absence of war
in bosnia or
with the turks and greeks in cyprus
people learn students
learn different histories
both of which are a lie
and this
is of course touches upon the brilliance
of the truth and reconciliation
commission in south africa
where
although the torturers and the killers
of the apartheid regime were given an
amnesty
to do so they had to confess their
crimes and what they were doing is
returning to south africans language a
narrative a common narrative by which
you can build and maintain peace
and it's always the same disease
i woke up a few weeks after 9 11 and i
looked around new york with people
driving down the street waving big
obnoxious flags and i thought we've all
become the serbs
and that's what's so terrifying about
war it doesn't matter whether i'm in
argentina or israel or bosnia or el
salvador it's the same
disease and we have it
yes
but i want to ask you one of my concerns
is that we not only
export war but we import it
after the war is over you bring back a
culture of 300 000 soldiers who come
back
and caught of that patriotism
is a
new cycle that begins again
which means that we just continue in
this you touch upon for me a very
important point and you know when we
look at the destruction of war we always
look at the physical destruction you
take bosnia which i covered the bridges
the buildings the infrastructure
but probably more dangerous is that
unseen psychological destruction
and
one of the
benefits that we as a country have from
the legacy of our debacle in vietnam
is that because it was a defeat
we have not permitted vietnam veterans
to mythologize the war the way we have
with world war ii veterans
they
they suffer more trauma because it
because of it but they also speak a lot
more truth about war
and
i they have a lot to tell us and we're
not listening
um it has been done since the iliad when
nestor got up and talked about the age
of heroes we look back on past conflicts
we elevate
and we and exult those that carry out
carried it out the greatest generation
and what we're doing in essence is
creating and perpetuating that myth of
war
i grew up in a family my father and all
my uncles fought in the war one of whom
uh fought in the south pacific he was in
the regular army in 1939 eventually was
wounded
and never recovered he never was able to
hold down a job he was a burden on our
family was particularly difficult
because as an alcoholic and and we my
father mother did not drink
and he he drank himself to death in a
trailer
and i don't think that's an uncommon
story that's a silent story
that's what war does
so
yes we bring back people who are
maimed and brutalized and then
we
we discard them and we don't listen to
them war is always about betrayal it is
about betrayal of the young by the old
and it is about betrayal of soldiers by
politicians
what would you recommend for people who
are
what
talking to the mic okay oh
yeah people who uh live alone are
isolated and who are so traumatized uh
that they can't watch television they
can't read the newspapers they don't
have the benefit of groups like yours
what would you recommend for people like
that right i mean that that's where i
see that you know each individual human
being
can start trying to reach out
that if you find your courage if you can
build up your courage you know to reach
out to the people that are isolated to
reach out to the people that because of
their own traumas
can't even leave their homes
um to take that responsibility to be
able to to for yourself to say oh yes i
see that person that's drinking
themselves to death in the trailer yes i
see the person who
is you know that looks crazy all the
time and to ask them about themselves
you know to to and and just begin the
process of being human with another
person
little small things like that are what
can make a
let's have one difference question for
either
okay
the traditional ways of of trying to
heal people after trauma and and
uh and and i um
i'm thinking of situations like rwanda
and mozambique uh south africa is not
the only model to what extent have you
drawn from traditional from traditional
ways of healing in in your work
our society and psychotherapy that right
right
that very much the therapeutic spiral
model um we we worked with a native
american shaman um for three years in
the development of the model
so that we've incorporated some of the
principles of spirituality of ceremony
of ritual
of the the natural ways of people coming
together non-verbal
movements dance
so that you know it is in many ways a
returning
um to some of the aboriginal the
indigenous cultures
um that i've seen with the people and
where i see that the people embrace the
experiential methodology the quickest
are the cultures where they're still
practicing traditional healing methods
and that it is about you know finding
the the public forum to be able to to
confess to own to
um to say what the perpetrations that
have happened have been
you know only then and that's what the
traditional um practices are about they
were all communal
you know they were all communal and they
all in involved body mind spirit and
connections with both a spiritual belief
beyond something human and the
connections among the different humans
thank you
thank you all i'm sorry that we don't
have more time i think we could probably
have this be a seminar yes
we'll move the book signing back there
please stay and ask any questions and we
need to vacate this area however at this
time
[Applause]
you're watching book tv's coverage of
the virginia festival of the book
in an hour and a half we'll take you
live to charlottesville virginia for a
panel on the limits of free speech
during the war you'll hear from henry
abraham author of freedom and the court
barbara perry author of the priestly
tribe robert o'neill who wrote the first
amendment in civil liability and
catherine mcnamara publisher of the
online quarterly archipelago
first a panel we taped yesterday it's
moderated by samantha power it'll start
in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
god
okay
[Music]
[Music]
well
hello
it's about war let's make war for
uh it's just great to be here uh i'm
samantha power i'm moderating uh this
panel uh i wish i were participating uh
in a more formal way but uh but i will
revel in the task of uh
being charlie rose to uh these
gentlemen's uh experiences um
and i wanna just begin by saying turn
off your cell phones uh we are actually
being broadcast on c-span
as we speak not to increase the pressure
on the panelists
we are going to have book signings
immediately following this session
and we will be in the north signing area
in line d
and this will be marked on your map so
if any of you want to meet with the
authors and and follow up with questions
and so on that we don't get to in the uh
hour allotted to us go to the north
signing area and uh and we'll be happy
all of us uh to take your questions and
to discuss so if you could don't
actually come up to the podium uh or to
the table afterwards and just let us get
to the signing area and that will make
it easier
to continue the conversation
um
we are here to talk about something i
think that is both
a puzzle
and a peril
which is the seduction of war
at a time when this country is formally
and explicitly uh embarked upon
a war of indefinite duration
uh against a global and not a confined
or national enemy
um i think the time the timing couldn't
be better to ask the question
why on earth is war so damn appealing
um and that i think was behind
steve wasserman's creation of this panel
and the decision to include
such wonderful uh and uh respected and
experienced voices from very different
worlds uh to discuss the seduction of
war
war uh
changes uh as time
passes technology changes resources
change again enemies definitions of
combatants and non-combatants change
but there are certain constants uh from
thucydides and even the bible forward
and one of the things we'll try to get
at today is what are those constants
what is george bush
and his cowboy boots and landing on an
aircraft carrier and and his
association of manliness and war
and what are the precedents for that
what is specific to today and what is
more uh timeless
uh we're also going to get at uh
changing conceptions of honor
and um
definitions of exclusion and inclusion
who's in the group who's on your side
and who who is the enemy and how do you
otherwise people in order to rationalize
in your own mind
killing
either participating in killing or
ordering it
we'll try to get at uh
the question of of
whether war is a manifestation of
individual desire for aggressiveness or
whether there's something that gets
distorted at the collective level
is it an aggregation of individual will
or does the collective take individuals
and do something very strange uh to them
and who are the individuals who define
what the collective does because leaders
of course uh shape
um collective spirit
and i think a number of the authors here
have written about uh the extent to
which
our proximity
with death that occurs in war and maybe
even in in terrorism
um whether that increases our
appreciation for life
and whether that is some part of of the
seduction uh at work and we won't close
uh without asking
what is to be done how do we
if there is a seduction here and if
there is a time timelessness to that
seduction
what can individuals do
um we are a part of the war that is
being waged now uh indefinitely and
again
across the planet it is being waged in
our names and so we want to get again
the experts and the veterans uh to tell
us uh what they think can be done um
to impede the seduction of warfare
joining me
today i'm very very excited again to be
a part of this discussion uh we have leo
browdy
who is a university professor of english
at the university of southern california
he's the author of five books including
uh jean uh jean renoir
the world of his films uh the frenzy of
renown fame and its history and his
latest and the reason he's on this panel
uh is from chivalry to terrorism war and
the changing nature of masculinity
uh next again from right to left we have
chris hedges of the new york times i'm
especially pleased to be on a panel with
chris who uh
sort of set the standard for war
reporting uh for people like me who were
just breaking into the business a decade
ago
chris has spent 15 years covering war in
el salvador nicaragua algeria the west
bank iraq sarajevo kosovo
he also uh uh has a masters in divinity
from harvard and so uh he's not merely
he's not your average war reporter uh he
was famous for toting uh copies of of
the iliad and odyssey around with him in
in
under shell fire in in bosnia and uh it
shows uh in his writing the depth of his
writing he won a 2002 overseas press
club award for international reporting
and was part of the new york times
pulitzer prize-winning uh coverage
of the war on terrorism in uh that prize
awarded in 2002.
next we have james hillman
an author of more than 20 books
including the force of character and
revisioning psychology uh his latest
book again placing him on this panel uh
is a terrible love of war um and so he's
gonna give us uh the individual and and
psychological perspective on war and
greatly looking forward to that and then
of course anthony swafford here who is a
2003 los angeles times book finalist in
current interest congratulations
um and he is the author of jarhead a
marines chronicle of the gulf war and
other battles
he served
in the marine corps surveillance and
target
acquisition platoon during the first
gulf war
he's now teaching at st mary's college
north of here and uh working on a novel
uh so we're looking forward to hearing
from him today and to uh reading the
literary version of um
uh his reflections which will come out
uh in the next couple of years okay let
me just begin
we're not going to have kind of set
pieces here um but just begin by asking
the panelists to respond to the
overarching question i think that unites
all of the work here which is
why is war so appealing what what makes
us tick and and gravitate toward it
again and again uh through human history
and today we begin with you uh professor
browdy
uh i i'm beginning perhaps because i'm
i taking a longer historical view but
also because my name's earlier in the
alphabet i suppose
uh and in in my book let's just start
out i was intrigued with in chris's book
and tony's book but the iliad they both
took the iliad along with them and the
iliad said as for war talking about
hector
uh and andromedas for war that's for men
and there's some essence of male self
definition that's involved in war and
this is one of the things i wanted to
trace in my book not about the
essentialist side of it not about the
the continuity that that doesn't change
but about all the changes that do occur
i mean if you look at the relationship
between men and war changes remarkably
over the ages it's not a fixed quantity
then and so male self definition has a
lot to do with war but when that just
moves the whole question back another
layer and say what what does male self
definition mean in a variety of
societies it means something different
historically it means something
different culturally depending on the
place in which it occurs too but war is
always a part of it in one way or
another because in part war is a testing
place and one of the aspects of
masculinity uh that is intriguing to
look at is the way in which masculinity
is always seen as
deficient
in one way or another that is it always
has to be tested you are never truly
masculine you're always trying to be
masculine in one way or another and war
is the great testing place of it now
william james in the beginning of the
20th century in a little essay called
the moral equivalent of war took this
whole idea and said well if war releases
if war is this kind of testing place if
war releases these kinds of energies
then can't we do something else to
release those energies that is it's not
something innate in war that allows this
testing to occur it's just the place
historically where this has happened so
what are the alternatives to war then
and i think this
brings up a crucial question that is so
many arguments about the need to make
war or the seduction of war uh seem to
rest to me on kind of a sensualist basis
that is it's something instinctual it's
something that men have to do there will
always be war because men want to fight
but if you look at the statistics say in
world war ii
there was a great inhibition only 25 i
think was one of the statistics only 25
percent of american soldiers in world
war ii actually fired their guns
and a smaller percentage of those men
fired actually at the enemy even so i
mean i think you know there are there
and in vietnam they
were firing at their own officers often
too
uh
i think you know this what are the
let's kind of battle of the instincts
here what is instinctual is the desire
to do violence instinctual or is the
prohibition against violence instinctual
samantha was mentioning you know how do
we demonize
the enemy in order to feel that the
enemy is not really human and therefore
is should be killed
and i think the whole idea a whole idea
of propaganda in that way the demonizing
of the enemy
really does argue the opposite and in
fact that there aren't that there are
other kinds of instincts that fight
against this supposed war instinct and
finally i think
if you're talking about essences and
instincts and seductions and the you
know the kind of overpowering fatalistic
need to go to war you have to think okay
even if that might be true for the
individual what does it have to do with
public policy there are many instincts
that we have there are many kinds of
violence that occur
that in fact laws control uh that in
fact
morality controls religion all sorts of
all sorts of self-consciousness about
the human need not to behave that way so
the i think there's a great gap between
any argument saying that something is
necessary something is instinctual
something is basic in male nature or
female nature or human nature that
requires us to do that and the jump that
says therefore we must go to war against
this particular country well let me
address the point in the study that you
uh mentioned because you're correct
there was a 20 firing rate and this
disturbed
military officials after world war ii
and they decided what techniques can
they use to increase the firing rate and
what they did was change targets from
round targets to human shape targets
that would pop up and down they began to
simulate battlefield conditions as much
as possible for recruits and they did
repetitive training they used they
brought in psychologists and
used the technique of operant
conditioning that basically the same way
you trade train a dog to
through
repet constant repetition show soldiers
how to respond in a firefight so that
firing rates by the vietnam war were up
to 90 percent
the problem was that
along with that rise came uh from
further studies a correlating increase
in post-traumatic stress disorder
the military is very very good about
studying itself
and one of the frustrations that i and
many combat veterans
had friends of mine during this current
debacle in iraq is
the way war was presented and we got
together and did a small little book
called what every person should know
about war the last third of which are
footnotes
and we let the army explain itself
you know they we know how long human
beings can stand through studies
sustained combat which is 60 days and we
know what happens to
soldiers and marines who spend 60 days
in sustained combat they have a cycle 98
of the unit has a psychological collapse
and the 2 percent that doesn't according
to the military study um showed a
predisposition to psychopathic
aggressive personalities
so um either you uh you know war made
you crazy or you were crazy to begin
with um
i want to talk a little bit about yes i
mean as you point out leo the the
technology has changed in war
dramatically um but the fundamental
essence and attraction of war has not
which is as samantha said why
i you know read and reread um the iliad
and the odyssey which is the book of the
great struggle to recover from war and
uh it's
no uh secret or it's no accident that
you know
odysseus is the only one who recovers no
one else is able to curb his warriors
hard as he says um and that attract the
attraction is
predominantly but not necessarily male
it
revolves around comradeship
and comradeship which i think many
people who go through the experience of
war friends of mine in sarajevo is in
sarajevo during the siege you mistake
that for friendship it's not it's the
very opposite of friendship
friendship is about self-awareness
friends probe and question each other to
expose these sort of inner depths i mean
through friends we become more complete
comradeship is something very very
different we can all have comrades and
the attraction of war
is that when we have an external enemy
and i think we may have felt this after
9 11
we no longer face death alone but we
face death as a group
and death becomes much easier to bear
because of that first of all
second of all in comradeship if you're
willing it allows you
in war time to suspend individual
conscience maybe even consciousness for
the contagion of the crowd
you no longer have to make moral
choice moral decision and it obliterates
that deep alienation that i think is
very much part of modern society hannah
aaron writes about this calling it
atomization and origins of
totalitarianism
and that has a tremendous appeal
and while many people who go into combat
show great physical courage
they also very rarely show moral courage
there's and there's a tremendous
difference
because moral courage requires you to
stand up to authority
which is very very very hard to do when
you become part of the crowd part of the
unit because you become one entity and i
think as anthony
speaks of in his book and many others
have soldiers don't you know all those
abstract notions of glory honor heroism
become hollow and probably obscene the
moment combat starts soldiers and
marines fight for each other they fight
for their comrades for the people next
to them
and the the greatest uh uh you know the
the the most amazing sort of feats will
be carried out often to protect your
comrades
um but at the same time there's a
complete suspension of the ability to
make moral choice and i think that when
when you see veterans come back and even
war correspondents mean we're not immune
from this and we you know these were my
comrades for almost two decades and when
you see them come back you know nobody
who you know i often say that nobody
hates a war more than a soldier that's
been through it and but when they come
back that nostalgia is not for the
suffering and the horror of war um but
it's that comradeship that sense of
belonging
to the nation to the unit
in a way that we never have been able to
experience we never experienced before
and have never been able to experience
since and lastly i just want to talk
about the myth the myth of war the lie
of war
that is an extremely
powerful myth because it is about
ultimately through nationalism which i
think is a disease self-exaltation
self-aggrandizement i mean what did the
coverage of the war in iraq i'm talking
about electronic media consist of it
consisted of the
exaltation of our weapon systems
and the power of our weapon systems and
the precision of our weapon systems and
by extension our own power
and that is extremely hard to fight i
mean i i like tony's book a lot jarhead
and i think it's very honest and i think
that there are other uh people who have
come back from the experience of war and
have written honestly um farley mauit um
you know uh robert graves they're there
but we don't want to hear it
we don't want to hear it because the
myth is too intoxicating and too
enticing and has too strong a pull and
unfortunately the only way we wake up if
human history is any guide is through
rivers of blood we woke up after the
vietnam war
but the myth has again become ascendant
gradually and you know i think we go
back to this freud freudian distinction
between what he talks about all all
individual and social life is a battle
between two forces the eros instinct the
instinct to preserve conserve protect
and the thanatos or the death instinct
the instinct to annihilate all living
things including ourselves and one thing
i've learned as a war correspondent is
that for because of that intoxication
people are quite willing to accept their
own annihilation we don't always behave
rationally we don't always behave in
ways that ensure our self-preservation
but often doom us this was certainly
true in the war in yugoslavia thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'd like to go back to the
the
testing sense that you you go there and
you are tested
and the need or desire for initiation
and the initiation involves
meeting death in one way or another
but what sets up the possibility of that
is the fantasy or the idea to begin with
that there's an enemy
and once we have established as we do by
declaring an empire of evil or
axis of evil we even
the war or the possibility of death is
already
at the fringe because there is an enemy
now an enemy also produces
paranoia
uh and fear of enormous sizes anxiety so
on and so forth
if
the war begins with the fantasy not of
the other but the other as an enemy
and in
any enclosed society or any enclosed
family or any enclosed group
what is outside that
can be imagined as an enemy
so the testing that goes on is the
whether it's done valorously and
courageously
and
as an equal or whether it is done as
impersonal in anybody
the enemy
sets up the possibility of the test
meeting the test whether it's a masai
warrior with a lion the lion is in a
sense
an enemy but also in some peculiar way
a special relationship
and we have this special relationship at
the moment
with islam this giant fantasy of islam
as of
an enemy of of star wars size
with billions
and reaching back in history so it takes
on such an enormity
that making it an individual personal
initiation
i think is not
it's not a true
personal initiation now that's different
from i mean i'm talking now from the
point of view of we who are not engaged
immediately in that war
but are watching it hearing about it
reflecting upon it
but it has become
it has become
the test almost for the society now it
has almost become
uh will we be able to go on can we
a war without end an endless test of our
courage and our resources and our
beliefs and so on so that
so long as the
the imagination of an enemy
continues in our minds we will be drawn
seductively into meeting the test
standing up to the test
and this is how we as a as a population
continue to be seduced
and so the enemy is also becomes a
blanket idea there's no differentiation
in the enemy
there were no good germans and in the
first world war there were no good
uh germans especially because there are
statements from the archbishop bishop of
london who said kill them all kill the
ones who've been good to us kill every
single one that you can find the huns
have to be killed they became a blanket
enemy
so long as we continue with the fantasy
of the enemy we are in a kind of
paranoia
which is blanket
which is um
undifferentiated about who is actually
the enemy
and makes it impossible for the enemy to
be separated among themselves
so that we have
we have not been able to think our way
properly through the discrimination
between
the
jihad terrorists whatever we want to
call them
and
the vast majority of muslims in many
different countries with many different
kinds of people and many different
societies and relig religious
aspects
as long as we remain a
in the imagination of being a young
country when in fact we are an old
country and an old nation
filled with old people like myself
we are unable
we
we are unable to imagine other modes of
initiation
and
particularly interesting today is the
decline of the of the intensity and in
passion
of the arts
and what the current administration does
in regard to the arts in education
where
instead of a moral equivalent of war
there could also be an aesthetic
equivalent of war meaning
if each individual person were
passionately intensely engaged with the
same battle rage towards one's own
individual work
not a moral
reprehension but a passionate engagement
every kid
the desire to bully and to oppress and
to win and so on would be directly in
one's own engagement
there would be there's there would be i
believe an aesthetic equivalent to
initiation and to war
[Applause]
i was
first seduced by warfare at probably an
earlier age than i'm
aware of but uh the the bombing of the
marine barracks in lebanon uh was was my
first sort of absurd movement into
uh into the myth uh internalizing the
myth i stood at that time they would
allow film of the corpses coming back at
dover and um i recall i was 14 and i
stood in my parents living room and
a skinny lonely nerdy kid and i saluted
the television as these corpses were
returning
and uh you know my father had been in
vietnam my grandfather in world war ii
so there was some family history that
that was preparing me to to move into
that place but uh you know at the
individual level it it it occurs
uh
to i i think often to keep loneliness at
bay to join a group and and indeed uh
yeah i was a
lonely kid in the suburbs of sacramento
but when i spoke to that marine
recruiter uh he let me know that i i
would could by joining the marine corps
i could not be that lonely kid in the
suburbs of sacramento i could be a young
savage who was ready to go kill the
enemies of the state uh as they say uh
travel the world uh meet interesting
people and learn how to kill them and
um
which is what it's about especially for
the marine corps uh the
yeah i it's i was on the marine corps
recruit depot in san diego on thursday
and uh
friday there were a company of a
battalion of young
new marines and they were milling about
uh the base that day it was our first
time uh being able to uh buy a hamburger
or uh drink a pepsi and and they had
family on on base and uh you know 15
16 years ago that was me that young 18
year old and um
i think that uh you know some of those
young men were seduced by warfare at the
same age that i was or maybe a few years
ago at the age of 16 or 17 when this war
on terrorism began and so um you know it
takes those individuals to to fill to
fill up the national myth and
and continue it um i i think it's also a
process um i i refer to it as a
psychosis that's induced uh and often
when i'm reading around the country or
lecturing i'll call it a temporary
psychosis and afterward uh someone who's
been in the military maybe from korea or
vietnam or the gulf war will come up to
me and say it's not temporary man i'm
still screwed up and um
you know which makes me consider my own
mental state but uh
and that you know those young men that i
saw on thursday i don't think they're
psychotic yet but as they spend more
time in the marine corps and as they
prepare to go fight you know those men
in in six or seven months may be
fighting in iraq and dying there and um
they as as chris said it will be about
camaraderie um they'll they'll assume
that it's about friendship
just as i did but when i left the marine
corps
i didn't keep in contact with anyone
except one
one guy who came down to visit me in
sacramento once he was still still a
psychotic and
that was about a crowd
and uh continuing the mentality of the
crowd when you're in this crowd this
closed crowd that has a mission uh it
makes you
better than others who aren't a part of
the crowd it makes you more important
and and as uh you know part of the
marine corps training is it's essential
to make you know that you're a marine uh
you're willing to do dangerous things
for your country you're going to make
great sacrifices uh maybe die watch your
fellows die and and be injured and those
things are all true and they also make
you better than those other people and
i'm a civilian now so when i was on uh
the recruit depot the other day i i felt
this um the kind of the the energy that
comes from uh
that that potential for violence you
know they wouldn't have me i'm 40 pounds
overweight and slow and my eyes are
going but um
they don't even recognize me as someone
who used to be one of them anymore which
is which is good for me but um
so uh essentially i mean it takes a long
time for people to remove themselves
from that crowd and chris was speaking
earlier you know as a journalist he he
was around the same kind of psychotics i
think there they
the difference was they weren't asked to
pull the triggers but they were watching
the people who were dying at either end
of it um and in the end i would just say
uh
you know as i say in jarhead um those
young men on either side who are asked
to fight it i i think this is changing
now or the the kind of warfare that
we're engaged now this may not be as
true but
i used to think and i used to hope that
if um
lance corporal swafford and um his enemy
a thousand yards away were given the
choice to either meet somewhere and kill
one another or to put their rifles down
and walk the other way that they both
would have put their weapons down and
walked the other way and and and the way
that warfare is changing or the way that
we're using our power
i'm not sure that that's true anymore
and um but but regardless i think that
this this seduction
uh will will remain
okay
i'm just gonna
read uh briefly just two snippets um
from uh the two uh participants here who
uh have seen war up close and then ask a
question the first is from uh chris's
book and he talks about coming back to
the real world and but asks a question
about whether which is the real world is
that the real world or is this the real
world
um and he writes i would rather die like
this he on his reflection about being
kind of near combat in combat then go
back to the routine of life
the chance to exist for an intense and
overpowering moment even if it meant
oblivion seemed worth it in the midst of
war and very stupid once the war had
ended
uh tony has something similar he comes
across uh a group of of iraqis who've
been killed uh and dismembered and
partly incinerated in iraq in the first
gulf war
and he writes i could bend at the waist
close my eyes and try to join these men
in their tight dead circle but i'm not
yet one of them i must not close my eyes
the presence of so much death reminds me
that i am alive whatever awaits me to
the north i realize i may never again be
so alive i can see everything and
nothing
this moment with the dead men has made
my past worth living and my future
always uncertain now has value
i'd just like to ask the two of you
is war is one of the one of the things
that has us so troubled by it apart from
the the carnage and the extinction of
life
um
that we learn
who we really are or does war distort us
i mean does it give us a mirror to the
self that that we don't want to know
yeah this passage which we haven't
mentioned is from the first book war is
a force that gives us meaning
um
what is the essence of war the essence
of war is death
um
and that
very essence of war um those who
propagate war work overtime to hide from
everyone it's why you don't see the
coffins at dover it's why you don't see
the wounded it's why no one who hasn't
been to war ever sees war in the
televised images and in the photographs
of war war is always sanitized
the poison of war is hidden covered up
commercialized made attractive
aesthetically
and sold to you in the same way that
liquor companies or tobacco companies
sell you poison you are sold war
and
and that's important to remember if you
haven't been there you haven't seen it
as samantha will tell you
uh human bodies uh you know clustered in
a group that have been hit by a 155
howitzer shell uh it's a it's a pretty
brutal sight i could not eat a piece of
meat for three years after i left
sarajevo
but you'll never see those pictures
you're given enough sort of titillation
and excitement in the images as we saw
with this shameful reporting with the
embedded journalists
always of course remembering that you're
safe you do not feel the fear and you're
never shown war as it actually is
because it would so disgust and horrify
you you would never want to go anywhere
near it
um and
i think that that is
an important way in which the myth is
kept alive and war
is sold sold to you um the attraction uh
when you're in a war zone i mean it's
not incompatible to hate war
and yet at the same time not be able to
exist outside of that war zone
i certainly had it i loathed war um yet
at the same time i became so deformed by
war that i couldn't function i i spent
like many war correspondents leaping
from war to war to war all around the
globe and when one were finished all we
did was sit around and talk about how to
get to the next one
and we fell into a kind of despair a
kind of depression that i think you
always do after a war ends uh and i
think finally it's important to talk a
little bit about the intoxication the
sad fact is human beings like to destroy
and they like to destroy not only things
but other human beings and there is you
know i i i talk about wars the most
powerful narcotic invented by humankind
and it has everything in a war zone i
mean war is zen when you talk about you
know your colors are brighter you are
aware in ways that you never were before
you are thrust into the present
in a way that you never were before
um you become an adrenaline junkie you
know you can you can in the course of a
24-hour period reach every conceivable
drug high whether it's hallucinogenic in
terms of the grotesque landscape in
front of you whether it's pumped up on
speed because of the adrenaline and the
fear whether it's that zombie-like hashy
state from exhaustion and lack of sleep
and a mental breakdown it's all there
and you tend to swing from these
extremes one from the other
and it becomes i mean a combat high
which within the military is a very real
phenomena and certainly war
correspondents have it and the more you
seek it out the more dangerous it
becomes until it eventually and you know
in the last 20 years how many of my
friends are dead
um because of it you you and it's like a
moth to the flame i mean i quit
and then i got went back and i quit and
i went back until i ended up in netsirim
and in israel in a junction and there
was a 19 year old palestinian kid who
was shot through the chest and killed
about 15 feet away from me and i said i
got to stop and i was talking to tony
before but it took me three years my
cachet
might that comradeship that sense of
identity the deep alienation that i felt
coming back into a peacetime society the
the terrible irony of war is that
morally and in some ways
perhaps even psychologically it's much
harder to live in peace than it is to
live in war it's it's it's the work is
much harder
yeah i mean living at warfare is quite
simple
the mission is to find other people and
kill them and um
that's the main mission uh we hear about
hearts and minds campaigns etc and um
you will be your best friend
once we've
torn apart your village
but but um it is about that warfare and
it's it's uh you know i've i've been out
of the marine corps for many years and
and um you know uh the passage that
samantha quoted from my book
um
is
that that that
react that reaction the direction that i
had there is something that's common
among soldiers you you talk to men who
despise war because they've fought wars
and and they might still say that when
they were at warfare they were living at
their best that they were young they
were athletic they were strong they were
masters of whatever small universe they
were a part of and um
that's that's the effect of that drug
that is combat and uh you know marines
are over in uh baghdad right now
fighting and dying and i'm 33 years old
and there are times when i read these
accounts of these of these men and i
have a friend who's a marine captain
who's over there and i'll for a moment
think about well maybe i should join the
marine corps again maybe i should go
fight again
and and that's because at 18 i was in
the marine corps and it was very
important to me and you know now i'm a
writer i sit alone in a room for most of
my life
um
pacing
and i just
started smoking cigarettes recently but
i quit after one pack but um
bad
nasty habit as bad as war um
but and that scares me that that really
scares me but but that's why uh
you know we'll always have men who are
willing to do that fight and and report
about the fighting as well because uh
when when they're living in warfare uh
they they might possibly be living at
their best can i just i mention a
wonderful passage in his book where he
talks about how
you know
it is it doesn't matter what kind of
movies you make about war you're sitting
in a barracks watching platoon i think
and everybody has cases of beer for us
it's all war porn and i think that
attraction of violence uh even when you
create a movie that's meant to denounce
violence it always fails because the
sort of period fascination with violence
overpowers the message it's like trying
to make a film condemning pornography
and showing erotic love scenes it never
works
yeah it will never work the the as i say
you're the men no matter what
you all might think uh when you see
platoon or a full metal jacket or the
deer hunter or any other war film
the young men who have the capability
and the desire who are sitting on the
bases with the loaded rifles nearby
are excited by by that despicable beauty
um
leo uh
just you
link um warfare to masculinity and um
i'm wondering as we move toward the sort
of constructive uh
part and perhaps less despairing part of
the discussion
uh whether
women in the military in in western
militaries uh i suppose it's especially
whether uh gays in the military and and
moving toward a day hopefully when you
will both be able to be gay and be able
to say you're gay and and serve in the
military
whether these
uh
change the association between
masculinity i mean tony in his book
again not to keep um using your book in
vain but writes when he sees these uh
soldiers
um in who've been killed in the marine
barracks in lebanon he writes the
marines were all
sizes in all colors all dirty and
exhausted and hurt and they were men and
i was a boy falling in love with manhood
i understood that manhood had to had to
do with war and war with manhood
and to no longer just be a son i needed
someday to fight
is this is this changing uh at all and
that's the first question the second is
is humanitarian intervention knowing
it's a misnomer and so on but going to
somalia and feeding people or or
going into kosovo and doing
nation-building leave aside iraq um is
is that kind of war for sissies
or for william james maybe
uh i wonder i you know if you look at it
historically in fact uh it doesn't seem
to change that much i mean the you know
the elite fighting group uh in greece
the theban band was made up of gay
lovers and the reason was as plato talks
about it that in fact you always want to
do your best in front of the person that
you love the most uh so in fact that was
an inspiration
that they were there uh i can't see that
particularly that that women in the
military has changed the israeli
military very much uh i think it's you
know that they're absorbed into the same
kind of ethos that that chris and and
tony have been talking about and i think
you know to come at the question in a in
another way though uh you know one of
the things that intrigues me is say how
much
with the with the advance in technology
uh that is our our capacity for power in
awe for shock and awe there how much
would that advance in technology with
the advance and you know the use of
computers all the technology that we
have the technology to destroy and the
technology to control destruction
which in fact one implication of which
is that the individual soldier is a very
is less and less important in in the
whole equation of warfare yet at the
same time the publicity the propaganda
of luring men and women to war is about
individualism we were talking about
camaraderie but so much of the ever i
was thinking of the army's cam army of
one campaign which i'm sure many of you
seen on television uh you know there
there are little ads there and it's all
about this this one guy who is covered
with all sorts of electronic equipment
and guns and things like that who will
who is
entirely sufficient unto himself you
sort of see the other people in his
group behind him in a very shadowy way
but he he is really there so that you
know as as in fact technology
uh the technology of warfare has gotten
so extensive that in fact maybe in
future wars there won't need human
beings there that's certainly the air
force view of things
the army still thinks about people on
the ground being necessary
as as that kind of warfare increases
where in fact the individual will be
totally irrelevant yet the need to draw
individuals into war stresses things
about individualism individual
sufficiency plays on those dreams of
personal immortality that that teenagers
and you know that young men and young
women have that you will you will be the
one who survives
uh james um
you urged us to take this forward and to
be constructive we've heard a lot about
the appeal
um
i mean what what how can we think about
neutralizing this appeal we're feeding
our denial by by
as has been said by not allowing uh
photos of coffins to be shown
we are probably reducing the impact of
journalists
by embedding them and making them part
of the camarade camarade ship
among soldiers
what what are we as citizens how are we
to to respond to this discussion knowing
once you're in how appealing it is and
also the kind of vortex that tends to
envelop
uh these actors
the hardest part you know all along is
to wake up
uh they did studies uh
on hypnosis
eric erickson pointed it out a long time
ago that when a paradox is too extreme
when there's a
complexity that you can't handle
such as that war goes on and on and on
and its essence always wants to go on
war's desire is to perpetuate itself
and at the same time there's a desire
to save your life
not go to war
stay you know safe
the
you go to sleep one of the sleep
inducing
events is a paradox that's too much to
handle
and so we're living it seems to me in a
in a situation where we declare all the
shibboleths of our society democracy
freedom and so on and so forth and at
the same time we're murdering uh the
actual civilian deaths are just
phenomenal compared even to the military
deaths which were which are beginning to
increase enough they're already a
hundred uh wounded women soldiers
and those wounds have to be imagined
not
the word wound doesn't take care of it
it's disfigurement it's blinding it's
losing half your face half your limbs i
mean wound is not the right word we
think of a wound you know from our
little lives
so we are fundamentally asleep
and
the more perplexing it becomes the more
sleep inducing and the more the society
encourages the sleep so we constantly
hear about the wake-up call we've heard
about the wake-up call since 9 11
and we're not awake
we're continuing to support and our
complicities in paying paying for and
the moral burden of that on me
personally is enormous i i have shifted
because i start off as a psychologist
you know
empty of judgments
we're supposed to listen and be neutral
all of that
and i have become recently at pr
probably owing to old age and the
narrowing of the the drying of the brain
to
the that i'm becoming a moralist
and that there is that the wake-up call
is in a sense a
a moral call to realize the extent of
everyone's complicitousness in
in this horror in which
uh the casualties
are now moved from military casualties
to
something like 90
or more of the casualties in current
warfare are civilian casualties
[Applause]
i'm sorry you don't know go ahead well
it's also very it's very easy to stay
asleep when um you know until very
recently i knew no one who was serving i
have the the marine captain i know he's
over there now he happened to meet him
uh in in the fall in australia
at a book fair and and i wasn't being
touched by this war uh and and how many
of us know an iraqi family who's lost a
child or who has a son who lost a leg we
don't know those people so so we're able
to uh culturally stay asleep and and uh
you know the names of the dead when they
appear in the new york times they're on
page 810 or a12 or a14 and those names
should be on the front page i mean we we
should we should read those names and
know how many of them are dying and how
many are injured
how many are injured and how many are
injured yeah the wound they're injured i
heard today 100 dead this year this
month but over 600 wounded and those are
those are serious wounds almost 4 000
yeah they're almost 4 000 uh wounded so
far
okay we're going to open it up now uh in
the time we have remaining to questions
uh you've got to get up to the to the
hold on sir just one sec um
if people could move move to the
microphones make your questions as brief
as possible and we really have to be
brief with the answers so we can get a
good few in those of you who want to
leave will give you a few seconds now to
get out
just one section
you need to unfortunately get up and go
to the mic
okay why don't you go ahead sir
uh you guys thanks for getting my ptsd
all warmed up i spent a year in vietnam
so i'm really well and uh warren right
now i'm kind of pissed but the question
goes to another obvious question to me
is the selection of war who how do you
think this applies to our current
leadership who have not themselves been
men in war
cheney bush wolfowitz etc
can they be seen through your eyes as
people who are trying to
in a secondhand sort of way prove their
manhood get themselves initiated into
the society are they getting off on the
dead over there in some ways
chris before you answer we're actually
going to take a few questions at once so
just if you could write down your
answers then we can we can get responses
uh yes sir thank you good morning a
famous historian once said that the
study of war by those who haven't seen
it is like the study of sex by virgins
who only have pornography as a guide and
the question is what effect on the war
narrative do you see from the
diminishment of service in the american
population that is we the audience have
less and less of a reservoir of service
with the end of conscription and i'd
like to know how that affects the
narrative thank you we're going to take
two more and then yep
my question is for uh chris hedges you
talked about the shameful reporting of
the embedded press and i'm just
wondering what's happened to our
independent press that we're not getting
an accurate picture of war thank you
last one yes i'd like to touch on an
issue here that the gentleman before
just touched on these neoconservative
chicken hawks that are quite happy to
take us to war i think general anthony
talk touched on this and why aren't we
discussing this and the the zionist
extremist entities that wanted this war
in iraq for israel i mean the 911
commissioner philip zeliko the executive
director has said the war in iraq was
for israel so why don't we talk about
these zionist extremist think tanks like
the jewish institute for national
security affairs agenza of which douglas
fife and richard pearl and dick cheney
are associated with we don't ever hear
about this and also the project for the
new american century i mean we have it
sir sir yeah but one last thing was we
never touch on this it's a document
called a clean a clean break please call
for war in iraq for in syria and also to
dissolve the palestinian peace process
and that's exactly what these people are
doing okay please thank you okay let's
very quick answers if we could to the
four questions as you as you see fit or
do anyone just one just one quick
comment about the the first question
there just remind me i was thinking of
robert graves and goodbye to all that
and robert graves comes back from his
first leave from the uh from the front
in world war one and he and his and his
friends are all amazed at how
bloodthirsty the politicians and the
public at home are compared to the
people actually on the line so i think
this this idea of the politicians
sending people out and this is certainly
an old idea in war and certainly
something that that we've seen before
well you know every war is about
ultimately betrayal it's betrayal of
idealists by cynics by the young
of the young by the old and ultimately
of soldiers by politicians
um you know we have
the the the reason that we don't want to
hear i mean there's no
shortage of vietnam veterans who came
back
as prophets
in many ways
to tell us not only about war but about
ourselves
and that's what we can accept the most
disturbing
thing one learns in warfare is the
capacity we all have for evil and
atrocity
how thin that line is between the
victims and the victimizers how easy it
is to be seduced by the crowd to commit
horrific acts and how thrilling and
exciting
that orgistic
use of violence is
you pay for it the rest of your life
but in that moment you feel the power of
the divine
the power to revoke another person's
charter to live on the face of this
earth
and in wartime everyone becomes objects
objects either to gratify or destroy
or both and almost no one is immune and
the the when when people come back from
war
and tell us this
it obliterates this civic religion that
we've created where we are a good nation
we are a good people um god will lead us
to victory in and righteous we will we
will create a righteous world it exposes
that darkness within us and i think that
fundamentally is
what we don't want to hear and it's not
just the people who lead us to war this
whole country most of it was
complicitous
everybody got into it and i know because
i was standing up against it and it was
very lonely chris just
again let's be more brief but say a
quick word about the embedded
journalists quick quick word well the
pro you know there's the problem is that
when you are embedded you become part of
that comradeship you become part of the
cause you want to do your bit for the
cause and there's no problem with
embedding i don't personally do it and i
didn't do it in the gulf war um but if
you do independent reporting
is very it's very very very dangerous
and it's very hard and as we saw in
afghanistan and we saw in iraq the one
thing these people don't want are
independent journalists doing
independent reporting um what they got
with the embedded was a giant commercial
for the us military operation okay let's
let chickenhawks and national service
real quick
[Music]
i'll take the national service um well i
think i think that uh you know there are
not many books have come out of the gulf
war that i fought in and and part of
that may be that it's uh an
all-volunteer service and that uh you
know fewer people are doing the fighting
uh the the men who came out of world war
one and and fought were uh you know from
all over the the culture as well world
war two and vietnam it also takes a it
takes some years for for the work to
come out of it there's i i read
something the other day that the nea is
going to run some workshops
with tom clancy i think at
um
military installations around the world
to get these narratives and that's
important to get the narratives that are
coming out of iraq right now but but the
art that's coming out of the war the
writers who are who are being formed
because of their service uh you know
we'll we'll hear those books we'll read
those books in in five eight ten years
and further on
okay uh let's take four more
quickly i guess i guess i'll go back to
this question about the narrative it
seems like in um history you mentioned
you uh you kept the iliad with you
and the narrative in the elite homer's
um
uh description of war um certainly was
uh not merely a matter of honor i'm just
thinking of achilles dragging uh hector
around troy 11 times and uh how priyam
had to
uh go back to him slip back to him to
beg him to return the body of his son
the other uh part of this is of course
this william james thing about uh what
could substitute or take help us get out
of this war
mania and sports uh immediately came to
mind because i just uh recall this uh
football player the national uh football
he was uh it seemed like a direct link
somehow between values of football
no it's it's
okay you know it's an important comment
and maybe we actually could comment on
pat tillman and how um
i mean the the sacrifice that he made
and the heroism associated with choosing
to leave professional football and going
into the service
dr hillman has touched on this but
approaching this problem from another
point of view
is the gullibility of populations
because actually the number of soldiers
for example is just really a small part
of the population and there i don't
think that there could be really the
seduction of war
if it wasn't uh
connected with the gullibility of
population i'm thinking that the
iliad and the odyssey may be a wrong
thing like what we need is grimm's fairy
tales or what we have with the pied
piper of hamline really
thank you sir
yes
i i think you know the plight of saturn
is just really to to to
betrayed his own principles
and and abs and
uh sacrifices on uh john
and uh
but
that desire for destruction and
empowered to preserve itself
also you know betrayed
uh uh uh uh the moral you know uh
court of society and i think the the
society is more religion
of a culprit than power because i said
that the morality that is presented to
them and is done to a process of
education that actually absorbs
everybody to to a status quo of
acceptance and make them more complicity
i don't think you know we're gonna do
you have a question yes i i think the
main thing is that the principle don't
exist and the population is absorbed by
the democracy system please ask a
question for other people can i can i
say something james has something to say
oh do you know i want to well all right
yeah we'll take one more and then
because we are running out of time i
would just like to ask the extent to
which those of you on the panel believe
that americans sense of entitlement
entitlement to education health
money
uh colors our tolerance of war which is
more and more becoming against in
unentitled persons great thank you james
please
the question that came up indirectly
is about the religion
the religion connection to to the
military and uh
anthony says in his book that there is
no connection between religion and the
military and what the chicken hawks
which was the question the chicken hawks
are not militarists they're religionists
and it's the it's the the disaster the
disaster
of the unconsciousness of the religion
it's not religion as such although i
have my doubts there too but
but the unconsciousness and the denial
within the religion of its own violence
that makes this the chicken hawks so
hawkish they're unaware of the militancy
in their own
piousness
on this gullibility
is leo
i would i would just amend that to come
back to chris's point it's about civic
religion uh in that way the religion of
american exceptionalism and and also i
think the the our separateness i mean
this you know this is like a key factor
in our history we're not there in europe
we've we've become insulated you know
pearl harbor and september 11th were
great blows because somehow we were
seeing we saw ourselves as vulnerable in
a way that we never saw ourselves before
and i think the more we see ourselves as
vulnerable and the less we see ourselves
as different from the rest of the world
i think the better off we'll be
i i just want to quickly i mean as a
former seminarian
and jesus was a pacifist i mean you just
can't read honestly the greek bible any
other way so
again
it's
he's clearly does not accept the use of
violence which is
part of his own crucifixion everything
else so i think that that again it's
this civic religion which is part of
when people come back from vietnam and
other places i think that was part of
the the sense of disillusionment and
anger because they had bought into that
civic myth which is not religion it's
that fusion of national and religious
symbols which is very different and it's
called idolatry
okay
okay we're going to just take four more
and then and then we're going to give
the panelists closing comments so very
quickly and make sure you ask a question
addressing
are you all aware that there's a
statistic into the
microphone that a hund 55 000 men were
killed in vietnam and 150 to 200 000 who
have been there committed suicide since
and i'd like you to comment on that
please thank you yes
uh it seems that war is usually um
you know over its power you know it's
it's contests for land or resources and
it's usually done you know poor people
uh are sent in the war by the rich right
and my question and this comes from a
peace activist i organized against
vietnam war
i organized the coalition against the
first gulf war i'd been against this war
but my question is
okay is there ever a justification you
know for fighting uh
resistance uh defending yourself
in any situation thank you and we might
also add humanitarian intervention such
as it is to that question yeah yeah just
to follow two quick comments um
of following up what this gentleman said
first of all there's been a lot of talk
about we've done this we've done that
and i realized the panel's on the
seduction of war but i don't feel like
i'm part of the we who decided to go to
war i feel that
that this is a decision uh made against
our interests second point is i do think
that there's a different a different uh
between a just war and unjust war isn't
it different for the vietnamese to
resist an invasion or the iraqis to
resist an occupation thank you thank you
sir and last question yeah okay uh first
of all
uh
what are if any any viable substitutes
to war to war
and secondly if uh jesus was such a
pacifist why are christians so violent
[Applause]
okay this will give the panelists an
opportunity to make their closing
comments and try to respond to the
questions made it also give james and
chris an opportunity to break into war
uh on the question of christianity
well i mean the
religion after the third century or
christianity certainly was perverted
distorted and used to support the
institutional church and the goals of
the institutional church and you're
right the history of christianity is the
history of one huge bloody battlefield
but when you read bonhoeffer or in my
mind other great religious thinkers
bonhoeffer despairs completely of the
church
and talks about how real uh
christian love if you want to call it
that will not come out of the
institution at all so i think you you do
have to keep in mind that what is
presented to us as religion is not it is
civic religion every state does it every
state tries to fuse their religious
traditions uh with that uh to sanctify
the national cause um but you know
certainly from the prophets onward um we
have been warned against it as a former
theology student thank you yeah leo
i think we're at a very strange and
interesting phase in history now too
that is to a certain extent the the
whole uh radical islamic attack against
the west and the united states is the
downside or the underbelly of globalism
in fact the reaching out this the trying
to separate ourselves from a kind of
knee-jerk nationalism at least on the
economic level
has created this these other kinds of
problems for us as well and i think
moving away there is a moving away from
nationalism but then in the present
administration there is an effort to
kind of go back to an older nationalism
an older sense of of needing to be
shielded of needing to be armored uh of
needing to be invulnerable on a whole
variety of levels
and in fact the kind of
psychological and political
vulnerability or even pacifism that is
the openness to other experiences to
other people's perspectives is really
let's say the ideal version of the
globalism that's happening but in fact
this phase i think this historical phase
that we're going through is going to be
a lot more tumult before it gets settled
down
james please i'm going to read
something
i have read the book of revelation and
yes i believe the world is going to end
and by an act of god i hope but every
day i think that time is running out
this from former secretary of defense
weinberger the man in charge of in 1982
of the national arsenal of mass
destruction i do not know how many
future generations we can count on
before the lord returns said president
reagan secretary of the interior and
reagan himself said i sometimes believe
we're heading very fast for armageddon
now that's the part of the bible we
should pay attention to the last chapter
the end of the world the and the intense
belief by vast amounts of american
believing
committed christians to the
concrete literalism of the end of the
world
by violent war
so there's a belief in this war that is
religious
and we are in a religious
mindset and that's the hard thing to
deal with it's not religious it's as my
great ethics professor james luther
adams said he called them the christian
fascists and he is good
let's not confuse the two there is a
place for deep religiosity it's real and
um that does they don't speak for me and
i think ultimately they don't speak for
for for the faith but do they speak for
the nation well that's because it's a
civic religion it's it's the it's the
religion of the state
tony you get the last word
i'll partially respond to the woman's
question about the the vietnam veterans
uh i i'm not familiar with that
statistic of 150 000 having committed
suicide but i know that up to a third of
the men who are homeless on the streets
today are
vietnam veterans and um
we it is a civic religion uh and and
we send people out to do this fighting
and it's a very small portion of of the
population that does this and i think we
need to we all need to take
responsibility the gentleman earlier
said it was not his choice to go to war
but he is a citizen and this time i'm a
citizen and we all have responsibility
responsibility for the people who are
over there fighting and dying and will
shortly be returning and attempting to
to re-enter
uh this somewhat civil life and we need
to uh
remember that they're over there
regardless of where we land
okay
that concludes our panel all five of us
will be in the signing area north in
line d and we'd love to continue the
conversation thank you
[Applause]
well the first panel of the 2004 la
times festival of books goes over 15
minutes as it gets very interesting here
and the discussion kind of continues we
are going to open up our phones and
invite you right away to this
202-585-3890 if you oppose the war and
202-585-3891
if you support the war and we're going
to have chalmers johnson with picture
internet zero live monday at 6 30 p.m
eastern on c-span
over 6 million child combatants were
killed or injured in the past decade
next author p.w singer explores the
global phenomenon
also at the talk chris hedges author of
war is a force that gives us meaning and
roger rosenblatt author of children of
war
it's just over one hour
good evening everyone
welcome to the housing works bookstore
cafe i have the great pleasure of
introducing this evening um this event
this evening my name is molly michael i
am the director of marketing here and
i'm happy to welcome c-span and book tv
back to the space to cover this really
fabulous event before i tell you about
our
participants this evening i just want to
give you a very brief
overview about housing works and the
bookstore for those of you who don't
know much about the space or about
housing works we are a non-profit
bookstore all of our stock is donated
we're run almost entirely by volunteers
and
all of our proceeds go toward housing
works inc which is the largest minority
controlled aid service organization in
the entire country and uh we we serve
tens of thousands of of clients um
annually we provide housing and advocacy
at the state and city and federal levels
and uh it's it's even more important to
provide these kinds of services in new
york city in particular in this country
because while in new york city uh we
make up three percent of the the united
states population we are home to 16
percent of this country's aids cases so
um here here in new york we really are
ground zero for the for the epidemic
nationwide so thank you so much for
coming out this evening and supporting
such a such a great cause and um
also
uh we if you are ever interested in
visiting our website all of our events
are posted you can make a donation to
housing works inc it's housingworks.org
and i encourage you all to
to go there
and now i have the the great pleasure of
kicking off this author to author event
with dr p w singer roger rosenblatt and
moderated by chris hedges and so forgive
me for for this canned introduction but
i want to make sure that that i
introduce these guys properly and give
them the credit that they deserve
dr singer is the national security
fellow in the foreign policy studies
program at the brookings institution and
director of the brookings project on u.s
policy toward the islamic world he's
written for the boston globe the la
times new york times washington post
foreign affairs current history survival
international security and world policy
journal he's provided commentary on
military affairs for media outlets
including abc al jazeera bbc cbs cnn fox
and nbc and this event this evening is
to discuss his new book published by
pantheon this month children at war
and also participating this evening is
roger rosenblatt he's a journalist and
author playwright and teacher his essays
for the newshour have won a peabody and
an emmy award his essays for time
magazine have won two george poke awards
his journalism career began in 1975 as a
literary editor of the new republic he's
been a columnist and an editor at large
for life magazine editor of u.s news and
world report a columnist and editorial
board member of the washington post and
editor at large of time inc his work has
appeared in the new york times magazine
vanity fair the new republic esquire and
i'm sure many many many more places his
book children of war an account of young
people growing up on modern
battlegrounds from northern ireland the
middle east and cambodia won the 1983
robert f kennedy book prize and was a
national book critic circle finalist
and finally our moderator this evening
christopher hedges is a reporter for the
new york times was a war correspondent
for nearly two decades in central
america africa the middle east and the
balkans he is the author of war is a
force that gives us meaning which was
the national national book critic circle
awards finalist and his new book losing
moses on the freeway america's broken
covenant with the ten commandments will
be published in june so please check
that out when it comes out and now i
have the great pleasure again of
welcoming these three to the table thank
you
well i wanted to begin by thanking all
of you for coming out this evening and i
thought it best to
start off
what's a chilly evening outside with a
chilling quote
this is from a
young boy in west africa
i was attending primary school the
rebels came and attacked us
they killed my mother and father in
front of my eyes
they took me with them
they trained us to fight
the first time i killed someone i got so
sick i thought i was going to die
but i got better
my fighting name was blood never dry
as our moderator mentioned my research
is on changes in warfare in particular
the rise of new forces in warfare and
how it affects national security and
children at war looks at one of the
darker sides of this the rise of child
soldier groups
as nobel peace prize winner archbishop
desmond tutu said quote it is immoral
that adults should want children to
fight their wars for them there is
simply no excuse
no acceptable argument for arming
children
the problem is while there's no moral
excuse this practice
is out there and it's growing every
single day
and so what the book seeks to do is take
the first comprehensive look at it why
is it happening how is it happening what
are the implications of it and with that
what can we do about it and in the book
i tried to um tap into expertise
everything from
military history to neuropsychology the
interviews i did for it ranged from
child soldiers to mercenaries who'd been
hired to fight them
and my hope in writing it was really
three things the first is
once you learn of this issue and the
fact that it's out there but so few
people are aware of it you feel
compelled to tell these stories and get
the message out that these children are
not only victims they're also heroes at
the same time
the second thing is that i wanted to
tell it in a way that was not only
interesting and brought the tragedy to
the front but also
added to understanding with the idea
that our response responses so far have
not been effective and part of that's
because we haven't dealt with the real
underlying causes of what's going on
and hopefully this will help answer that
and then finally
i wanted to offer a new lens to look at
this issue not just the pure moral
tragedy of it but point out that there
are some real world implications for it
and real world implications even for us
in the west who don't know about this
for example the fact that our soldiers
are out there dealing with it every
single day and with that
we see that there's not just a moral
obligation to act but a strategic
mandate to act as well and today
security is the new coin of the realm
and hopefully that'll force our hands a
little bit
so um
what i'd like to do in sort of the brief
remarks today is
talk about where this has come from
what's happening out there what are the
causes of it and then later on we can
talk about
what can we do but i think it's
important first to start off with the
history of this
the rule once held in warfare that
children had no place in it
neither as victims nor as participants
now the rule is that war is not complete
without them
to put it another way when you look at
the last four thousand years of warfare
when children appear in it it's mainly
as footnotes and small isolated
instances for example
the um navy ships of admiral nelson you
had the powder monkeys which were young
boys who ran ammunition back and forth
in our civil war there was one battle
the battle of newmarket in 1864 where
the confederacy used a unit of 247 vmi
cadets but these were exceptions to what
the rule used to be and we typically
didn't see children
present at all we didn't see them as
targets we didn't see them serving in
combatant roles and no one rushed out to
copy the examples
today it's a far different thing
on the victim's side in the last decade
more than two million children have been
killed in warfare
on the participant side there's more
than three hundred thousand child
soldiers out there there's another half
million children who are serving in
armed forces that are not at war right
now another way to look at these numbers
is if you take the entire collection of
the world's armed forces everything from
militaries
to
insurgent groups to terrorist groups 40
percent of them use children
20 of them use children under the age of
12.
another way to look at the numbers is
that children fight in almost 75 percent
of the world's wars
they fought on every single continent
but antarctica
so they're out there in their present
and it's important to note that
sometimes people try and quibble with
the age point of 18 as being the
childhood point and there's a couple
things to say about that the first is
18 is not just some western construct
it's actually international law the most
widely signed international law 190
countries have signed that law but it's
also the age point at which countries
all around the world award different
rights and privileges
everything from health care to education
to voting
but even when you look at history when
you look at military history this age
point was something different for
example of when someone joined warfare
the zulu tribe in africa wasn't until
you were between the ages of 18 to 20
that you were allowed to serve as a
warrior and the ancient greek armies in
the spartan army there were young boys
between the ages of 14 and up but they
only served as herders of the cattle
that followed them they didn't serve as
combatants
in northern uganda where there's a
particular child soldier problem right
now during the tribal period you weren't
allowed to become a warrior until you
were married because it was such an
honor and a privilege today that's been
flipped on its head and this is the
final thing to note is that we're not
talking about 17 and a half year olds
we're talking about those at the age of
childhood that any sane person would
describe it
the average age
is 12 and a half
that's from two separate surveys the
youngest ever child soldier was a
five-year-old in uganda
the youngest ever child terrorist was a
nine-year-old in colombia
and so what this means is that now
as a consequence of our military
deployment after 9 11
our forces have come into contact with
child soldiers everywhere they've
deployed and while it's not been
discussed in the media that much we've
also fought child soldiers every single
place that we've deployed the very first
u.s combat casualty in the war on
terrorism was the green beret sergeant
who was killed by a 14 year old sniper
just a couple months ago
our forces in afghanistan picked up a 12
year old who'd taken part of an ambush
of u.s forces there
in iraq the practice has grown
before the war saddam hussein set up
this force called the ashbal saddam it
was a paramilitary unit of boys between
the ages of 10 to 15 and it served as a
feeder organization into the saddam
federen which was this paramilitary unit
that was run by his son uday and a lot
of people remember the fedine because
these were the guys that actually fought
back during the invasion as opposed to
the iraqi army that mostly ran
child soldiers fought u.s forces in at
least three different cities
during the invasion but it's after the
invasion during the insurgency that it's
taken off a good indicator of this a
dark indicator of this was the fact that
the very same week that president bush
made his mission accomplished speech on
the aircraft carrier
an iraqi twelve-year-old in the city of
mosul fired on u.s forces with an ak-47
and since then it's taken off all three
broad insurgent groups used child
soldiers
the posted on bathus
the radical shia groups and some of the
pictures that we're seeing here are from
much of our sauder's mafi army that
fought in a pitch battle in najaf and
actually the spokesperson of that army
didn't deny they had child soldiers and
they were as young as 12. actually
extolled it and said this was an
evidence of the fact that we are a
popular army that both the old men and
the young boys are coming out to fight
for us and then finally the sunni
triangle and the fighting there we've
seen it in november
the u.s marines went back into fallujah
and they talked about the challenges of
having to fight
children armed with assault rifles
so this is an issue that's very real and
it's one that we're having to deal with
and where i'll end in the discussion is
why has this come about why has this
happened right now
and really there's three things that
have come together here there's three
causal factors
the first is
we're living through the most prosperous
period in human history but we're also
leaving people behind and in particular
we're leaving a cohort of children
behind
and you could put this in terms of
there's now a lost generation and so all
the ills of the world are falling
hardest on children there's more than
250 million children who are homeless
out there there's another 25 million
children who are refugees are internally
displaced a special at-risk group that
these warlord groups target are orphans
and that cohort is larger both because
of warfare but also because of disease
by the year 2010
43 million children will have lost
either both or one of their parents to
aids
so what that means is it's a larger pool
of potential combatants but it's the
second force that what has activated
this this wouldn't have mattered a
couple generations ago but there's been
changes in warfare and particular
changes in the technology of warfare
the military looks at what are described
as light weapons the assault rifles the
rpgs they describe them as man portable
weapons and these are the main things
that are really used in warfare today
not the big ticket budget items that we
talk about in congress but actually
these are the ones that most people use
and cause over ninety percent of the
casualties what's happened now is that
they're not just man portable they're
child portable
they're lighter because of the
incorporation of plastics they're
simpler and easier to learn how to use
the ak-47 has nine moving parts
and ten-year-olds will tell you how they
learned how to use it in under 30
minutes
they're proliferating there's more than
550 million small arms out there in the
globe enough for one for every 12
persons which means that they're cheap
you can buy an ak-47 for the price of a
goat in kenya
and then finally they're far more lethal
that 10 year old has the same firepower
as a civil war regiment
and so that means that children can be
effective combatants they may not be as
good
as professional soldiers at the start
but they certainly can be enough to
cause disruption in civil society
particularly when targeting unarmed
civilians and over time they can become
quite good one of the interviews i did
was with a former um us green beret who
was now working in africa in a private
capacity and he had been training a unit
of child soldiers and he described the
child soldiers he was working with as
the best soldiers he'd worked with in
his 18 years of experience in africa not
the best child soldiers but the best
overall
and then finally it's the context of war
that matters warfare itself is changing
we have this image of war as men in
uniform fighting for the political cause
of their nation state
and it's not like that
it's men it's women and it's children
the groups that they fight in are
everything from state armies and that's
increasingly rare
to warlord groups to insurgent groups to
terrorist groups and the causes are
rarely political now they're religious
socioeconomic
personal profit sometimes the reasons
don't even make sense and children in
these groups are even beaten if they ask
what is the cause you saw that for
example among kids in sri lanka
and it's this context of failed states
and conflict entrepreneurs who profit
from the existence of warfare that's
driving this and the post-modern
morphing of warrior and civilian
and the best-case example of this is the
story of charles taylor
charles taylor was an escaped convict
from plymouth prison in massachusetts
he escaped from that jail went back home
to liberia where he was from and on
christmas eve he invaded the country
but he only had about 150 adult
followers people in the capital didn't
even know they'd been invaded
but over the next couple years he builds
out his force through child soldiers
both through abduction raids
targeting orphanages
and through convincing children to join
some of the kids talked about how they
were promised they would get a
mercedes-benz
when charles taylor won the war other
kids talked about how they were told
they would get a home computer obviously
there's not a reason why you join a war
and taylor didn't deliver on it when he
won the war
within a couple years
taylor is running what's called taylor
land
this enclave in the jungle where they're
illegally selling timber to western
corporations and he's pulling in
300 million dollars a year
a couple years later taylor wins the
civil war and he becomes president of
liberia so through child soldiers this
petty criminal became a king
and then other people looked at that
model and it spread like a virus and we
saw child soldier groups then go from
liberia to sierra leone to guinea to
cote d'ivoire to you could find former
child soldiers from liberia fighting as
far away as congo it's more than a
thousand miles away
and
where hopefully we can talk about what
can we do about this and what are some
of the implications on this but where
where i like to end on it is this is
obviously
a dark issue but we have to face up to
it this is war as it is not how we wish
it would be but there is a takeaway when
we look back at history there's all
sorts of practices that have fallen by
the wayside that we now can't even
believe happened
just a few centuries ago it was
considered completely proper
to take your pows the prisoners that you
captured they were your personal
property and to use them as slaves
a little more than a century ago
it was your obligation it was the white
man's burden to go out and invade
countries to lift them up into
civilization hopefully we'll look back
at this period when
the
rules of warfare broke down
as another one of these anomalies
but it's only going to happen
if we match the will of those who've
chosen to do evil to children with our
own will to do good thank you
thank you
[Applause]
there's there's a couple issues that
hopefully
roger and peter can address
you know for those of us that have
covered conflicts where you have
militias in places like the congo
child warriors armed children
are
perhaps
some of the most frightening elements
and i i think
as i remember you addressed this in your
book peter
and perhaps you can speak to it too as
well
they oftentimes
are
especially when they're as young as 12
or 13
they don't have
i think a concept of what it is they're
doing in terms of the actual killing
that they're carrying out
and
when you're stopped at a roadblock
and you run into child warriors you
sense
that there is no line of demarcation and
perhaps you could talk a little bit
about that i mean for those of us that
have covered these conflicts running
into a roadblock filled with child
warriors is far more frightening
than running into a roadblock of
adults one of the things that i was
surprised by during the course of this
was actually
the younger the child is
often the more frightening they are
to their fellow child soldiers and you
would talk to
kids in the range of 14 to 15
in liberia and sierra leone who were
scared of the younger boy units and they
called them sbus small boy units and
those were kids in the ranges of eight
to twelve
and they were frightened of them because
they didn't know what they would do and
one of the um young boys in that younger
unit talked about if they got mad at the
older kids they'd just start shooting at
them
um
and
there's two things that i think are
important here the first is
we have to remember that
these are not just little adults there's
actually physical and psychological
differences between an adult and a child
and when this 18-year point is really
important
one of the things is the part of your
brain that controls both your death
concept but also
your
vision of risk
is the prefrontal part of your brain and
it doesn't reach its full development
until somewhere between the age of 18 to
20. and that's why for example
little kids will climb a tree that we
would not even look at or when you go to
a ski slope it's you know you'll see
them going down ski slopes that we would
be scared to do
that's how this plays out in warfare and
these kids don't have a death concept
and they don't see the consequences not
only to them of the gunfire but also
what it means when they've killed and
then there's an added thing that these
groups often do
they hop the kids up on drugs and
for example in west africa it was a mix
of
heroin and gunpowder which they thought
would make it stronger and these groups
don't just do it because they're evil i
mean they are evil but they do it they
have a thought out process here and it's
two things the first is it's a further
disconnection and um the kids will say
you know it was someone else it was like
i was on a different plane when the
bullets weren't coming at me and what i
was doing that was someone else and then
the second thing is it's meant as a way
to bind them into that organization to
make them dependent on it and that's
another thing that we have to be able to
figure out how to fight
well my experience chris with
children in warfare was limited because
my inquiry in
children of war was to look at the
effects of warfare on civilian children
populations however
and in most cases there
in contrast and maybe as a kind of
layer a different layer of thought but
one that cooperates with what peter was
saying
i was mostly aware of the
the rational child the sweet child the
child who had to become the adult in a
situation where adults were very
dangerous and were knocking one another
off
there were however even when i was
pursuing the story of children of war
which was a story before became a book
um
two situations one in lebanon where the
palestinian children
were being trained as soldiers
and i'd also be interested to ask peter
when this sort of began more recently
because
i was in situations that may have
changed over these last 20 years or so
but even then the palestinian leaders
the plo leaders were there was an
admixture of both pride and secrecy
about that they were not
it was not something that they were
going to boast about
and then the other context which was the
most horrific that i encountered was
the consequences rather than the thing
itself of paul potts work camps in
cambodia
and these were situations where children
were in effect i suppose soldiers in the
maddened
uh
idea of war that came out of paul pott
and the khmer rouge
but
the
what they did to one another
at the
to be sure at the behest of the adults
um was the kind of torment that
you could not possibly nor ought you to
imagine
that people could come up with of ways
of inflicting pain both
psychological
and physical one of the things in
peter's fine book is what do you do
afterwards and how are these effects
uh what what effects do they have
however i do remember
and also i found the same sweetness in
sudan where i went for uh vanity fair
because i came across so
we came across a group of 400 or so lost
boys and they were setting up camp and i
must tell you instead of finding
anything bellicose or
even approaching it
i found
what one could honestly say would be the
height of civilization the first thing
these boys i went with sebastian salgado
the great photographer of human
suffering and
the first thing they were interested in
with salgado and me was did we have beds
and were we comfortable you know do we
have food this from kids who had been
gone on a biblical track uh trek all the
way through from the north to the south
of sudan barely surviving animals
disease famine and so forth
but i did also go for the new york times
magazine with with salgado again to
rwanda
and there i did we did come across
young certainly in their uh early teens
young uh soldiers
who i'm i have no doubt would have
knocked us off in a in a second
um and
i don't know quite how to convey it
because it's the first time i've thought
about it as a result of your question
but
it was an interesting experience if you
can think of the normal predisposition
of adults towards children is kindness
and welcome
and you want to take advantage of the
situation where they're to be embraced
and then you see that same child and you
can remember those tendencies in oneself
you know how it can how it can easily
uh flop when you're a child
to the
coldest look as if i were not a person
but a target and somebody to take out of
the way
and these are
it is on that capacity that ruinous
capacity of children that the adults in
these situations in the military
situations play they make them feel that
um that's a that's a good way of life
that a war is a
reasonable pursuit there's you know
there's an emotional numbing that comes
with killing whether you're an adult or
a child
um but sort of having watched it from
the outside it seems that sort of
numbing effect is more pronounced in
children
one also gets a sense and perhaps this
is something you can address that in
war zones
um
these child soldiers do not have
a high survival rate over the long term
you know one i remember in the uh
iran-iraq war for instance the iranians
would not only use young iranian
children but they would recruit yemeni
children and send them running into the
mine fields but there was they were not
only uh expendable in the eyes of the
commanders but i think because of their
emotional and physical frailty um it
seemed
that there was a very high attrition
rate among child soldiers and i don't
know whether that's something you run
into it's definitely something actually
connects back to what you were talking
about
then the iranian iraqi war
they told these young boys
they would wear
keys around their necks because the key
would unlock your way into heaven when
you died
and it during the lebanese civil war it
wasn't until the iranians started
sending in revolutionary guards to train
that then you saw the rise of children
there and what what this leads to and
why it's spread
is
actually teaching pathways where groups
learn from each other and they've seen
the advantages of this
another example is lol senna is a rebel
group in nepal
that didn't start using child soldiers
till it started jointly training with
groups from latin america and south asia
and it's a particular group that uses
girl child soldiers and it
claims that it does it to aid women's
liberation again these groups are taking
advantage of kids um and this goes to
what you're talking about of the the an
indoctrination techniques
when you talk to the kids um
there's often very brutal techniques
that are used to turn them into soldiers
some groups have
ones that are modeled after armies um
the tamil tigers in sri lanka have a
four-month training program where the
kids get up at 5 a.m and they train
until 10 at night
and at the end of it they're
quite indoctrinated and trained other
groups particularly those that abduct
force the child to
kill someone in their home village it's
a killer be killed situation and when
you talk to them they say that's the
breaking point that's when i became
someone else that's when my old life
ended in some ways they put it and they
develop coping mechanisms
they call themselves by different names
um the jungle names is what they
sometimes call it and the names range
from um sort of laughable ones
lieutenant dirty water which was a kid
who everyone joked he didn't bathe ever
and he kind of smelled to blood never
drive which that first quote was from
which has meant he was always out there
fighting
and it's another way of coping it's a
disconnection it was this other person
that was doing the killing it wasn't me
it wasn't this
my old identity and this goes to what
can we do
if
these children get the support they need
it they can be turned back into children
and we have to realize that they're not
just child soldiers they're victims of
the most political form of child abuse
but just like any other victim of abuse
it's going to shape their identity for
the future it might scar them but it
doesn't mean that they're lost goods
forever and and some of the child
soldiers i met were one was a student at
a very prestigious university in new
england another was a major in the us
marines who'd actually fought in the
lebanese civil war as a child soldier
but they were um two they're their
exceptions to the rule most of these
kids don't get the support they need and
it's a question of resourcing
well i think that one of the issues that
has to be looked at as well is the
breakdown of nation states in continents
like africa
and i think that
you know
especially with
the end of the cold war
you know i who had been covering
insurgencies in central america that
were disciplined uh both
uh militarily i'm thinking of the san
anistos of the fmln but also
ideologically all of that evaporated
and
i'm wondering whether we can really
address the issue of child soldiers
when essentially we have dysfunctional
states
with no central authority with competing
warlords who
essentially
mount
um
military operations for
personal profit and personal gain i mean
certainly covering the war in yugoslavia
one very quickly realizes that ethnic
warfare is a business
i mean all the mercedes in belgrade
pointed to that so i think that the that
if
we don't have centralized authority if
nation states are dysfunctional i'm
wondering how we can address that issue
of
child warfare do you want to well
i don't know this that this will be
helpful but i'd like to
use you in fact to broaden it
even beyond the nation states to give to
remind us of the context in which we're
dealing
the whole idea of warfare of war
throws you into a
mad set of other consequences other
forms of reasoning so that the kind of
torment or suasion that is used for
children becomes quite reasonable and
various
minor tactics or great strategies all
seem within a a scheme of the
of the uh
intelligent
and uh
and useful person but in fact this isn't
so and let me just read you a a
paragraph from wars of force that gives
us meaning chris hedges book
which gets to this in a in a different
way
but does remind us of the context
many of those who defy the collective
psychosis of the nation are solitary
figures once the wars end
yet these acts of compassion were
usually the best antidotes to the myths
peddled by the nationalists going to
your nation state in question
those who teach those who reached across
lines to assist the enemy in quotes
freed themselves from nationalist
abstractions that dehumanized others
they were vaccinated against the cult of
death that dominates societies in
wartime
they reduced their moral universe to
caring for another human being and in
this they were able to reject the
messianic pretensions that come with a
nationalist agenda
by accepting that they could only affect
a few lives they also accepted their
small place in the universe
this daily lesson in humility protected
them they were saved not by what they
could accomplish but by faith such
people are however
very rare
and once you've established as this
elegant paragraph
uh gives us
a context in which nothing makes sense
but the death of another
then anything goes
children women
anything you can use uh for
uh for victory because victory is the
only thing that is of interest
i think there's two really important
things here the first is that the
model of warfare has changed and that
when you look at insurgencies it used to
be the maoist model that you would you
were a fish in the sea you would build
up your local support and that was the
way to success
now it's the predatory model it sees
what you can and the local populace is
just assets to target it's about seizing
diamond mines controlling the drug trade
you name it and we see this repeated all
over and so that alters warfare it makes
it harder to end because you can't
negotiate with groups like this you also
because a child soldiers see groups that
have no viable ideology um the lord's
resistance army in uganda is a group
that's led by a fellow who um thinks
he's the christian holy spirit and under
his interpretation of the ten
commandments owning sex slaves is
allowed and riding bicycles is a sin
this guy is a nut job and he has about
200 adult followers but over the last
decade he's abducted and built out a
force of 14 000 child soldiers and he's
fought a civil war so what this is this
is a david koresh-like figure who's now
operating in warfare and how do you
negotiate with a david koresh-like
figure you can't
and yet he's carried out this warfare
and um to go to the question of what do
we do
on the prevention and deterrent side
so far the model has been
one of trying to shame the shameless
reaching out to these leaders and saying
didn't you know that it's wrong to use
children
they already know that and you can see
very subtle examples of it for example
in um sri lanka
the tamil tigers there the headstones
for fallen child soldiers don't have the
date of their birth on it because they
know history is going to judge them that
way
so it's not a question of trying to
shame the shameless it's actually trying
to alter the dynamic
create costs for them not advantages and
so that has to include
prosecuting them for war crimes because
this is the most easy to prove war crime
out there there's no question of well i
didn't know about this massacre i didn't
allow it if i'd known i would have
stopped it you cannot plead ignorance by
the fact that sixty percent of your
force is made up of twelve-year-olds you
can't claim you didn't know but we also
have to realize that there are certain
situations in particular with these
warlord groups
where we're not gonna be able to reach
them they're gonna be out there in the
jungle we will not be able to seize them
and so then we have to find what is it
that they want what is it that they need
and go after that is it shutting down
their weapon supply
shutting down the illegal trade and
light weapons which has been something
that the u.s has been on the wrong side
of that where we've been actually we've
made it harder to shut down the illegal
trade of light weapons
or is it going after the enablers
the countries and corporations that are
trading with these guys and pushing the
profits into the practice and you know a
model maybe to look at is the way we
dealt with apartheid where
we knew we couldn't just go after that
government we also went after the
corporations those are some of the
things that we need to think about but
at the end of the day we've got to start
making them march to our tune rather
than the other way around to what extent
are child soldiers and the militias they
serve
the natural consequence
of the
neglect on the part of industrialized
nations
towards the developing world
i think the question implies the answer
it uh
um if
particularly for our country the biggest
country on the hill
if we choose to use this immense power
for
what
are to my mind you mad utopian dreams of
spreading liberty um
uh
in the name of warfare
or warfare in the name of liberty
whatever
the cockeyed idea is
um
it not only seems wrong in itself but
it's an absolute avoidance of the
question that you asked the use of that
power for the powerless
for the people who need the help um
children being the weakest i mean the
remember
uh which these two uh fellas know uh
particularly well the thing about
childhood is that it's helpless the
thing about child is that children do
what they're told
that's how we in the most benign
circumstances teach them
the interesting and moral life that we
hope they will have but
give the
wrong impetus the wrong way to teach
it's still the same helpless child who
has to go where he's told to go
be pushed into things
the uh
um i'm gonna stray a little from the
question
forgive me but
um but before i do are there children
present here
good because i'm gonna tell you
something that
we'll
lock this in
i haven't told the story in a while
one of the i was talking about what
adults will do to children in order to
create
a kind of a state of mind that you are
so horrific so nightmarish that you
cannot imagine the child scrambling out
of ev forever
one child who came to the kowidong camp
in
in thailand
the largest of the refugee camps to
which the cambodian children
um
escaped when they could escape
was named poe p-e-o-v
and she didn't say anything for a year
after she had come to this camp
um wonderful psychologist named neil
boothby i must tell you that if
sometimes we are doubtful of the uses of
western psychology this was a context in
which it was heartening to see that the
idea of getting someone to talk about
even the most uh
painful uh problem can work
anyway poet
drew the only thing she did do was to
draw a circle that looked like a kind of
wagon wheel with a little circle in
between and then a little girl standing
off to the side and
a rope that seemed to extend from the
outer rim of the circle but it was a
confusing cipher to anybody looking at
this
then finally after a year through the
gentle and
useful prodding of neil boothby she told
what this all meant
the circle
was used on a
a child who escaped
from the paul pot
work camp
um aren't children who escaped it wasn't
a circle at all it wasn't a wheel it was
a portable guillotine
that was in that had been invented by
you can imagine this context of
invention um
by the kim rouge
this was placed over a child's head and
the lines of demarcation that looked
like spokes of a wheel were in fact the
demarcations of blades so that it worked
like a um camera lens with clothes and
open and then the strings that you saw
leading from this were to close the lens
and therefore decapitate
uh the child
but it wasn't the adults
who worked this terrible device the
adults made the children
do it
and so when poe was not speaking she was
not speaking of an event
so horrific to her
that it's amazing that she ever spoke
again
and i tell that story not to shock you
or to depress you but to give an idea of
the depths to which
uh
the the
the purposeful adults in these contexts
will sink
if they think it serves their purpose
chris i think it's important to
reframe the question and reframe these
issues of aid you know whether we are a
stingy or a generous nation or not
and realize that it's not just a test of
our generosity but it's about investing
in the future heading off future
occurrences of u.s soldiers fighting
children or future occurrences of
terrorism and the like and i'll give you
two examples of this
one is
sierra leone there was more than uh is
between estimates of 15 to 20 000 child
soldiers there
and the first un peacekeeping operation
that went there they sent one
child psychologist
one
sierra leone was a fundraising hub for
al qaeda where they converted
their cash into diamonds prior to 9 11.
another example is afghanistan there was
more than 8 000 child soldiers in
afghanistan that were used by the
northern alliance and the taliban
after we toppled the taliban
it was two years
two years before we spent one penny
on rehabilitation and reintegration and
demobilization of those children so we
gave the warlords two more years to tap
into that 8 000 children and the only
reason we spent that money was it was
really about providing aid to the three
kids who we'd held at guantanamo
and then returned back to afghanistan
and there's you know an interesting
story of at guantanamo we have camp
x-ray which is for the adults and little
disgust is camp iguana which is the one
where the juveniles are held and we've
in effect painted ourselves into a
corner where on one hand we treat these
kids really well
in camp iguana
it's a converted house on the beach they
play volleyball they play they learn how
to play bocce they've learned
mathematics english they watch dvds
their favorite film um is actually
castaway the tom hanks movie because
they kind of connect to one there's not
a lot of dialogue and the other part is
they also see themselves as someone who
is plucked away and dropped on a desert
island but at the end of the day the
military is frustrated by this because
they don't want to be in the business of
holding kids there forever and they
can't figure out how to get out of this
cycle and so it's not just a
humanitarian question but it also has a
military question to it
i think we can take some questions uh if
anyone has any please come to the
microphone
and please keep the questions
concise
i'm curious about the um the idea of
accountability for these these leaders
the international criminal court just
issued warrants against a bunch of the
leaders of the lra in uganda and i'm
wondering
what if if there's a if you think
there's a worry that that might prolong
the conflict you know you say children
are going to do what they're told these
leaders most likely are going to tell
them
they're going to prosecute you if you if
you
uh you know surrender so what do you
think is going to happen is that an
effective strategy to try and hold these
guys accountable while the wars are
still going on
thank you you want to do that peter
i think it is with a caveat the the
first is we have to make clear that
these indictments are not for the
children therefore the leaders who put
them into that and you have to have a
public affairs strategy around of it to
make sure that that message is getting
out there
the other part is um the ice the
international criminal court is a great
start unfortunately the us has sort of
done our utmost to
undermine it and that's a longer term
question i think ultimately we will
become a part but it's not going to
happen in the near term and so then we
go to the question well what are the
other things that we can do now
and we've actually started this process
of creating ad hoc tribunals the
tribunal for the balkans tribunal for
rwanda but they've always been
geographically set
there's no reason there's nothing under
the law that says that they can't be
issue based that you could not have an
ad hoc tribunal for those that
that targets those who use child
soldiers and one of the interesting
things is this would actually be a very
easy
issue to get to the euro un security
council level because the first is what
nation is going to try and defend that
practice no one on the security council
is because it's already a crime the
second part is
the security council actually has
already issued a number of resolutions
that specifically identify leaders who
are using child soldiers so it's already
there at the international community
level who's doing it and the evidence is
there so it's something we can be novel
about it the other thing is you know
going after the enablers it's someone
who's aiding child abuse and so when
there are corporations or other states
that are profiting after this we got to
go after them as well and um you know
this is one of the burdens of the
humanitarian community is that it's
focused all its efforts on outreach and
meeting with these leaders repeatedly
and nothing on enforcement and and i
guess the last example that shows it
which is um pertinent today
is the tamil tigers in sri lanka they
signed a ceasefire more than a couple
years ago
they've
since that violated the ceasefire by
recruiting
mainly through abduction more than 1700
children including now they're
recruiting among the refugee camps after
the tsunami
and yet the international community
continues to meet with these guys they
promise oh we've stopped
we catch them again they promise oh
we've stopped this time we promise this
time you can't keep meeting with them
you've got to start exacting some costs
can you please come to the microphone
how many young people are at the camp
iguana and also are our troops prepared
in any fashion for coming up against um
child soldiers when they do do they do
anything differently
uh the numbers at camp guan have ranged
from three to six now there's an
interesting backstory to that which is
camp iguana is for
under the age of 16.
we made up that age is our determination
it doesn't have either backing in u.s
domestic law nor in international law
and so what we've done is taken
those that are between that 16 to 18
point and put them in the general
populace which pretty much ensures that
they're going to be
pulled back into it when someone's in
prison they get pulled in by the leaders
so it's a small set that are there and
the decision to take that was one that
it was ad hocked and this goes to the
military response is because
this issue hasn't gotten the coverage
the responses have been ad hoc we
haven't given the intelligence support
to our troops the training the equipment
all the kind of backing that they need
and um there's two really good examples
of that the first um is when i was
writing the book a couple years ago
we were about to go into liberia we had
a u.s marine force right off off the
shore and i got an email from one of the
officers on board one of the ships and
he said we've seen on the tv that
there's some child soldiers there but
we've gotten nothing from washington
about it neither how many there are or
what to do about it
and i wrote back and said
actually 60 of the force there an
estimated 20 000
are children and it would be important
if 20 000 had blue skin let alone
children with all the dilemmas that it
presents for soldiers
and so i sent him a draft of the book
but you know that's not the way the
system is supposed to work
and then we saw that also repeat itself
now in iraq
where um one of the things that soldiers
want to have
are non-lethal weapons not to replace
their rifles but to give them another
option on the battlefield something that
can incapacitate a foe but without
causing permanent harm
the armchair generals back in dc because
they're not big ticket budget items
haven't spent on that and a particular
incident during the invasion was one
where u.s army forces that were moving
through karbala were being fired on by
two iraqi boys that were
between 10 and 12 and they were shooting
rpgs at them and the unit which had not
even been told that they might be fired
on by children stopped
pulled back
talked amongst themselves what to do so
not the military optimal solution
first called out to the kids said stop
that didn't work then they fired a
warning shot that didn't work
and then they had to shoot to kill
and then that unit
had severe problems in its morale and
psychological trauma after the fact
to go back to one of the things they
wish they had had was a non-lethal
weapon that could have incapacitated
those kids and allowed them to advance
would have saved lives on our side and
the opposite side in the entire u.s
military
there are 60 non-lethal weapon sets
we sent
six
to iraq
we're not supporting the troops the way
they need it
i have two questions uh one is what is
the success rate of rehabilitating the
child soldiers
and two what is the real story on um
flying all these lost boys out of sudan
on um
klm flights to minnesota and places like
that is that a successful way to
rehabilitate people who've been living
in the skillet of uh the the earth you
know
so
do you want to well i could um i can
only speak to
the rehabilitation uh question and that
in an anecdotal way but
journalism which i really don't do much
of anymore has very few rewards
but
occasionally a story that you do has a
a nice ending
and
when i did children of war was a story
cover story for time and so time gets
around the world and um and here and
there were several people
in this country who reading about the
kids who were written about became
foster parents but one of them
particularly the the um
there's no way you can see it but a very
cute little boy a cambodian boy named t
kim sang
i myself am much younger in this picture
and the uh
he
has he was reared in massachusetts by a
very careful couple and he now is in his
30s and he's married and he's stayed in
touch and he's come to see my wife and
me
just written a little book about
what he's been doing
now here's a boy who had to bury his own
parents and saw one of them executed in
front of his eyes and walked 60 miles on
his own when he was eight years old from
um
cambodia uh to thailand to escape
and um i must tell you the um
as uh
saddening as the original story was with
this
uh boy it's just as heartening to see
the resilience of children too
i don't know whether these uh i'm not
i'm not skilled enough in
psychology to know
how
these buried
torments may affect them but
i imagine they're not different in kind
they may be different in scope from the
from the sadnesses of all children
everywhere who's including ourselves who
managed to
put things in proportion
um
so
i don't know peter would speak to it uh
much more authoritatively i don't know
how
the
the being a soldier would affect but i
know being a victim as a child uh seems
to have a uh create a situation where
you can rebound
i think it's important to remember that
they're both soldiers and victims at the
same time
and
the heroes of the book
are
the children who are now out there
trying to prevent other children from
falling into this
and
for example
in sierra leone there's a radio station
that
targets children but it's actually
operated by children
and so there are
kids can recover but again it's the big
if are they getting the support that
they need are we investing in the
rehabilitation programs demobilization
et cetera to break the cycle and when we
don't
we shouldn't be surprised that these
wars start up over and over and over
again and
so again we should look at these as
opportunities to
head off warfare not just as nice things
that we're doing
the question you asked of the lost boys
there's actually an interesting back
story to
where the lost boys came from and um
the lost boys were
during the sudanese civil war
the
rebel force there was numbers a refugee
and they set up a deal with the
humanitarian groups that they would have
a camp for boys
next to the military camp
and the aid groups went along with that
and the reason was that the rebel groups
wanted that pool of reserves right
nearby that they could tap into and when
the war went badly for them things fell
apart and that group of boys then moved
off into the desert collectively
together and spent i think it was a good
three years moving back and forth
and
ultimately they were as you said airlift
a good number were airlifted around the
globe here many came back to the us and
it's the same stories many of them are
now leading happy healthy lives
they're enrolled in high schools etc but
that's that's a band-aid on top of the
practice it's it's not the way you deal
with it in a hole
you know if i if i could answer if i
could the question was um what pete the
question is the question was why did we
do this in sudan why did we focus on
sudan and not elsewhere and you know if
i could answer why the press chooses to
cover one war more than the other um you
know i would have a career in media
studies um and one of the things chris
has written about and also in the book
is this question of you know
focusing on tragedy and the balkans at
the same time you know there was so much
tragedy in the congo and
it's important in terms of coverage
because that is then
the aid follows and when you look at the
per capita aid that was given towards
the balkans it was about 100 times
higher 100 times higher per person than
it was in the congo and it doesn't mean
that it wasn't needed in the balkans it
just means that you know we focus on
different issues why did we decide
darfur was the important one but um you
know the other ones ongoing weren't i
just want to speak to the issue of
trauma which you raised
as somebody who spent
almost two decades of their life around
this kind of
organized institutional violence around
a lot of violent death
you can never walk away from that
without suffering from
various degrees of post-traumatic stress
disorder
and you carry that with you for the rest
of your life
it's
i think
to somehow think that people can walk
away from a situation like the sudan or
the congo as a child warrior and not
cope with very dark demons for the rest
of their lives is naive
the tragedy is that
you know the lost boys are a fraction of
one percent here we're talking about
people who never escape
these kinds of situations and after
they're traumatized are re-traumatized
the other problem which you run into
places like gaza or liberia is that
in a way because they have been robbed
of their childhood
they have
no other way
to live no other way to function
and when they try and step outside of
that
role as a as a warrior or as an armed
combatant in a conflict uh many times
they fall back into exactly the same
kind of poverty and marginalization that
drew them into the arm movement to begin
with and so there's a terrible kind of
recidivism where people keep being
thrown back into these movements that
that there there can be a lull
in this kind of
militia warfare that then rises up again
and i do think that poverty
and
the breakdown of central authority
and
the fact that those of us on the outside
intervene in such poultry ways
makes this a problem uh that
is as peter pointed out is growing
and um
and one that i think and i think you do
get to this point in your book as well
is going to come back and haunt us uh
because we all live in one community we
all live in one planet um and what the
figures you had uh the are are
staggering in terms of uh what is how
many people are living on less than two
dollars a day that's
about a
couple hundred million a couple hundred
million it's more than that even i think
i mean there are are terrible terrible
um
situations that i think propel people
into this kind of hobbesian universe and
we have to address the conditions that
create the hobsone universe one thing to
add in terms of how it's going to haunt
us is the flip side of this
which is
one of the interviews i did was
a british soldier who'd fought child
soldiers
in sierra leone when he went back home
he had to be hospitalized for severe
depression had to go to a hospital to
deal with it
and
as our forces
engage with these kids
we'll see this come to pass in a couple
years as well
and um we're not prepared for it right
now because we're in denial that it's
even happening let alone that this is
something that soldiers have to deal
with
it is a difficult issue to extricate
from the
from the context i keep coming back to
this because one would naturally ask the
question well if we could remove
children from wars then wars would be
great
the if if if we dealt with this
particular problem
then
the situation itself would be where it
should be
and um i just
uh
find the whole
uh notion of addressing that um what is
the uh the larger problem in terms of
the specific useful kind humane
and
maybe even
practical at some point
but you're still dealing in a larger
situation that will always recur as you
were saying
because the enticements are the same and
the species is the same
i will i will ask the three gentlemen on
the panel if they have any further
closing comments and then we will wrap
up and they are available to answer
questions and sign books as soon as
we're done here thank you
i think the only comment i'd like to add
is that um
in situations like iraq in situations
like the congo in situations like sierra
leone
uh
murder which is always part of war
and and i i distinguish between murder
and killing as killing being
the uh
shooting
to death of an armed opponent
and murder being the killing of an
innocent that in in in insurgencies in
uh warfare where there are no uh lines
of demarcation murder usually becomes
predominant
and that the consequence of that kind of
murder uh
of innocence we have a hundred thousand
dead iraqis is one that
distorts inflames enrages a society and
essentially creates a culture of death
you certainly see it in gaza with the
constant almost deification of the
shaheeds of the martyrs
and you have
this uh
yearning on the part of
children
to essentially
not carry out a kind of vengeance
and empower themselves because they live
in in a universe so distorted where they
where they it's not just that they have
the diminished power of childhood but
they and everyone around them are
powerless it creates it has a kind of
spiral effect it has a kind of snowball
effect
that i think we're seeing in iraq and uh
somehow in those kinds of a conflict in
those kinds of conflicts um
all of the components work to
essentially
foster and create the growth of these
kinds of militia this kind of killing
and these can entice these kinds of
children into it and it and it becomes a
matter of addressing the nature of the
conflicts themselves before you can
begin to address the problem of
children warriors as well
i have nothing further to say but i'm
happy to give peter the last word
childhood's the point
in human life where
identities are formed and where the
notions of right and wrong are formed
and
what's happening with this is really the
destruction of childhood itself where
you're taking children and plunging them
into an environment where killing is not
only
sanctioned it's rewarded and it's
punished if it doesn't happen
and the consequence of this is not just
wars are more tragic it means that wars
are easier to start
they have a higher cost to them
in terms of casualties level atrocities
means they're harder to end
and they often start up again
and so it's something that affects us
it's not just an issue that takes place
somewhere else
and it's for these reasons that children
have no place in warfare
except for the fact that
now they do and so it's up to us to end
that
thank you very much
[Applause]
pw singer served as an advisor to the
u.s military on child soldiers his book
children at war is published by pantheon
books visit
pantheonbooks.com for more information
[Music]
non-fiction authors all weekages
jonathan shell and francis fitzgerald
compare and contrast american
involvement in vietnam world war ii
and the current war in iraq
this talk from the nation institute in
new york city is an hour 20 minutes
so good evening my name is hamilton fish
and on behalf of the nation institute
it's my pleasure
to welcome you tonight to the new school
university
here in new york city
for a conversation entitled the
deepening shadow the us at war in the
nuclear age
we're privileged to have with us tonight
three of the leading journalists of our
day
whom i'll introduce and i'd like to
start
with francis fitzgerald
in the red
frankie fitzgerald has worked as a
journalist in the united states vietnam
the middle east europe central america
and the south pacific
her books include fire in the lake the
vietnamese and the americans in vietnam
america revised history school books in
the 20th century
cities on a hill
a journey through contemporary american
cultures
way out there in the blue
reagan star wars and the end of the cold
war and vietnam spirits of the earth
with photographs by
mary cross
the winner of the pulitzer prize the
national book award the bancroft prize
for history among many others frankie's
been a frequent contributor to the new
yorker has written for numerous other
publications including the new york
review of books
the new york times sunday magazine
architectural digest islands
and
most prominently the nation
where she is also a member of the
editorial board
[Music]
gentlemen in the middle
chris hedges
a senior fellow at the nation institute
chris joined the staff of the new york
times in 1990 having previously worked
for the dallas morning news christian
science monitor in the national and
national public radio
he held a ba in english literature from
colgate
and a master of divinity from harvard
he's a lecturer in the council of
humanities and ferris professor of
journalism at princeton
he was a member of the new york times
team that won the 2002 pulitzer prize
for explanatory reporting for the
paper's coverage of global terrorism
and he received the 2002 amnesty
international global award for human
rights journalism
he's the author of war is a force that
gives us meaning
which was a finalist for the national
book critics circle award and what every
person should know about war
and
my process of elimination
jonathan shell is
the harold williams piece fellow at the
nation institute
he's the author of 12 books which have
earned him nominations for the pulitzer
prize the national book award
and the national critics award
his reporting on vietnam for the new
yorker included his path-breaking essay
the village of bensouk which helped turn
u.s public opinion against the war
michelle's later books include the 1982
bestseller the fate of the earth hailed
by the new york times as an event of
profound historical moment
in 2003 his the unconquerable world was
described again in the new york times as
perhaps the most impressive argument
ever made that there exists a viable and
desirable alternative to a continued
reliance on war
jonathan has published two more
recent titles with nation books the
whole in the world
a collection of his letters from ground
zero columns from the nation
and his latest title the jonathan shell
reader
as i mentioned all three members of
tonight's panel will be available to
sign copies of their books which will be
for sale following the program outside
the lobby
chris
thank you
[Applause]
jonathan and frankie and i were speaking
before we came in about
what we wanted the heart of this
discussion to be
um
and i think it's really
how
after the war in vietnam we've almost
come full circle
and found ourselves caught of course in
another
debacle uh
another sort of
again in this
overseas
adventurism
facing the prospects of another imperial
presidency
and we'd like to look back over the last
few years and find out what went wrong
and why we ended up here
but i think i'd like to begin on perhaps
a more
mundane or prosaic level and just ask
and beginning with you frankie
how it is you ended up in war how it is
that you ended up in vietnam what it is
that drew you and how that experience
um changed you and and what it taught
you
well um i went to vietnam almost by
accident um i
thought i'd like to go see southeast
asia and i was just starting as a
journalist and so i thought well i'll go
and do a piece for a magazine in vietnam
and then i'll come home
so
uh i went there and um i couldn't leave
and uh i was still there you know uh 10
months later
when i finally had this had to leave um
uh
but then um
i really never left the subject until
the until the war ended and and that was
that was in 1966
jonathan came a year later
um he was just out of harvard at the
time he had no credentials i didn't have
any either
we've decided that we've lived our lives
in parallel in many ways um
uh we both
went to the dalton school in new york in
fact our parents were friends though we
never met until we were adults
and uh uh we went to harvard and then um
we went to vietnam so but
which was in a way our real
matriculation then we wrote about
nuclear war that's right and then on
it's gone um but but jonathan you you
went to vietnam and you immediately uh
uh
did two extraordinary um series for the
new yorker which became books uh one on
the village of ben sook and the other on
the air war in central vietnam
and i wondered how you managed to do
that first of all how you dared to do it
how did you get there and how you
imagined it
i mean how did you imagine doing those
pieces which no one else was was doing
at the time
well i didn't imagine it because i was
an even more accidental journalist than
you were uh
i actually arrived in vietnam as a
tourist uh i'd i'd spent a year and a
half in japan
sort of pretending to be a graduate
student
and i had a ticket on the way back that
with the now defunct pan american
airlines
that permitted me to stop anywhere i
wanted in the world and in as many
places as i wanted in the world so i
chose saigon
calcutta
kathmandu and oxford england
first stop
well hong kong first actually
then then vietnam
i had no credential
i had a very vague idea that i might
like to try to write something but i did
have one phone number in my pocket
because at college i had met
one francois souly
french journalist who was later killed
in the war
i called up my one
number
he invited me over to the newsweek
offices where i was where he was working
and i had under my arm a book that
people were reading at that time by the
great bernard fall a writer french
writer on vietnam and
there was another gentleman there at
newsweek and he said what are you
reading and i said well it's two
vietnamese by bernard fall and he said
i see it
so i handed it to him
and he opened it up and he signed it
that was
so and then sometimes i've actually been
asked by journalists how do you get
going in in journalism and i say well
just try to stumble into something you
know just accidents the best way uh
anyway uh
they took to cut make a long story short
these two marvelous high-spirited
bullied uh frenchmen
out of the
sheerest generosity of their hearts
decided to take on this definition of a
nuisance in a pest a sort of false
graduate student who thought he might
like to write something about a country
he knew nothing about and they got me a
press credential
and one day they called me up and said
if you will come to a certain gathering
place at 3am in the morning we'll get on
the military bus and something big is
going to happen it turned out to be the
largest
military operation of the war which was
cedar falls it was also the largest one
ever mounted because it was such a flop
they didn't care to repeat the
experience
so
and
part of that war was that operation was
to attack and destroy the village of
benson which had been occupied
or occupied had been governed by the
vietcong for some
decades i think really before so i
then went on that uh expedition and and
just simply gave a first hand account of
what i had seen that was it i was truly
a tabula rasa when i i was less
knowledgeable even than the normal
uh fake graduate student because
i'd been in japan
they speak japanese in japan
i did learn to speak it but i could not
read it and therefore i was cut off from
the news and so it was pure shock i was
entirely naive and
it was really just a a first hand
account without reflection
much really on what i saw what unfolded
in that village
well it's extraordinary it really really
was a great piece of work and it's so
beautifully written um
if you get the jonathan shell reader
you'll find a part of it in a good
advertisement right but um
i i mean it i i was i've just always
been um stunned by that piece and and
the following one which you did at the
same time that saying no then i went
back again later yeah
how about you chris how did
i um i was in seminary and um
living in a housing project in roxbury i
was going to be an inner city minister
and sort of began to sour on the
institutional church and
um
harvard divinity school
and this was the time of the early 80s
when
you had military dictatorships in chile
and
argent the dirty war in argentina the
war in el salvador was heating up samosa
had just fallen
uh and i i was drawn to latin america in
in many ways through orwell um and i
felt that by going to latin america at
that time it was as close as my
generation was going to come to fighting
fascism uh and and i i had very close
ties of course to the church um although
as a protestant to the catholic church i
lived with the maryknoll fathers in
south america for a year
uh but that was really the you know what
propelled me so it was a little more
ideologically driven
um although unlike my colleagues i was
very
critical of liberation theology of any
uh theological movement that endorsed
the use of violence to create utopia
having had reinhold niebuhr sort of
pounded into me
but that's how i and i spent six years
in latin america five of them in el
salvador i want to ask about the vietnam
war because um i think
unlike
um i mean i know you went you've been in
the middle east and other places um
i i after leaving el salvador i leapt
into several more conflicts and i always
found uh
until i was in kosovo 20 years later
with people that i had actually covered
the war with in el salvador and one of
the things i found was that you know
going to your first conflict was
somewhat akin to losing your virginity
and there was a constant kind of search
i saw in foreign correspondence in other
conflicts to try and recreate the
passion and um in some ways recreate the
experience
of understanding of course the the
hatred for war itself but um and in some
ways they could never do it and i know
that um you know vietnam was not
something either of you gave up easily
and i wondered if you could address a
little bit about the impact that it had
upon you
um
intellectually emotionally what it did
to you what did the experience do to you
maybe that's the answer i don't know
um
is that is it on now
oh
sorry
um
to me uh uh
apart from the the obvious uh drama of
what was going on that was
what what really got to me was the
mystery of what was happening
i mean when i arrived there i just
expected that all these grown-ups i mean
you know military officers civilian
officials
um other journalists who know ben knew
better than myself
would would have uh answers to simple
questions such as
uh why was the army of south yet now i'm
defeated in the you know
um in 1965 essentially
and um
uh
they didn't have them now maybe you find
out of course much later
pentagon papers
other documents much later on that that
uh people in washington d knew a good
deal more than they were saying at the
time about
about why the other side was winning um
in in
1965
um
and they had projected early on i mean
in 1961 that that
a lot of people thought it would take
several hundred thousand american troops
but i just didn't say that
so to some extent the it was a kind of a
willed ignorance that that um
um
uh
uh arrived in saigon and saigon was was
full of people who
were there for one tour one year um
and uh
i began to think that i mean i
actually my my
my literary
cue was conrad um
was
as it was for jonathan later on
but it's um
it's firing that shell out into the
middle of the jungle you know
and uh as indeed they were doing um the
night i arrived when uh
some television correspondent was giving
a birthday party for his girlfriend and
so we were on top of this caravel roof
of this wonderful hotel and there were
flowers and wine and everything and
there were border shells going off being
fired into the jungle on the other side
of the river so and um so i thought this
is
this is it
and
um
i decided to not to to do military
reporting not to cover
uh troop battles and so on because i not
my comparative advantage as a woman at
that time um
but also
what intrigued me was the vietnamese i
mean what was going on in this country
that
that
the americans there didn't seem to be
able to tell me about
well you did that better than anyone has
done it since uh i may return the
compliment uh
yeah i
um
i of course did go out and cover the
troops and the battles and uh
and really met amazingly few
vietnamese to tell the truth i was in
the military bubble really
as i say i arrived there without many
preconceptions because of my ignorance
of course any war i think can uh
just
follow up what you were saying chris is
is a fantastic shock for anybody who
goes into it
and certainly it's a lifelong shock it's
something that you never even begin to
get over exactly
um
and uh but i think that when the war is
uh seems to make no sense or when you
can't understand it when you can't
fathom those mysteries that frankie
talks about
then the shock is more profound because
it's unpalliated
uh by the noble vision of what it's
supposed to be all about
and and i think in fact just to comment
on on
some of the reporting that was going on
uh was i think the people who were more
knowledgeable than i uh if i may say so
were perhaps a little bit disadvantaged
by it i don't mean to be
anti-intellectual or against knowledge i
believe in it
but certainly there was an understanding
of what was going on in the war a
mainstream understanding that was uh not
confirmed by what was happening uh on
the ground so there was the shock of the
war and then there was the shock of the
senselessness of it because the thing
even in terms of what i could see with
my own eyes happening from minute to
minute just didn't hang together it
didn't make sense these questions you
know one if if we were supposed to be
saving the south vietnamese people why
were we killing them and destroying them
just simple things like that
it was it was very clearly and in detail
a self-defeating operation
uh just to respond to to what you said i
did understand when i got back from that
war
uh that i was uh obsessed with it
um
and i could easily and i saw others who
were obsessed with it
and i actually made a deliberate
decision not to go back
uh or to go to another war at that time
and part of the reason was that i feared
that obsession which remains with me to
this day and certainly it was a seminal
experience in my life uh and certainly
that was the sort of
artillery true that i was shot out of so
to speak and the long arc of my writing
you know begins right there and it's
followed from it something that makes me
uneasy by the way because i think your
formative influence can often be uh
uh too formative um but i dare say that
for the country as a whole this war that
war the vietnam war has had an amazing
staying power
uh precisely because we never succeeded
in coming to terms
truly some did but most did not i think
with the truth of that war sort of
condemned to repeat it because we can't
face it or something like that
is that because there's
a willful kind of forgetfulness is there
an attack against memory is that what
has happened you know i i think memory
becomes very selective and um uh you
know if you read textbooks you know
modern um high school history textbooks
uh
or or you you sort of look look at
what appears now and then in the press
in terms of you know
usually with reference to iraq
um
what you see is that well i'm afraid
just pretty much what you saw then too
which is incredible solipsism i mean
it's all about
the vietnam war was bad for america
right and it was there's no question
about that uh it was certainly bad for
the american army um and er you know
every professional soldier there knew it
although they weren't saying at the time
but i mean if you read colin powell's
memoirs you know he he
tells us that it took
him and and other officers
virtually 10 years to put that army back
together again so there's um
uh and goodness knows the casualties uh
you know the first first of all things
but i i think that you know what's
selective is that is that
we don't
remember
what was important in the war i.e
um
vietnamese politics period i mean you
know the american troops as hard as they
fought in as much as they died there
um were almost irrelevant
to the conflict
uh it was always going to be won or lost
inside vietnam
and um you know selective memory to
about about the sheer amount of damage
that we we did to that country
i was to go back to your first question
angry for 10 years and um when i when
the war finally ended i i said to myself
i'm never ever going to be that angry
again and tried to think of something
more
what do you think i mean do you
i mean
you know here we we find ourselves in a
situation as the nation that has so many
parallels to where we were
and
is the root from that is it caused by
our
our final inability to to look at what
happened is it
well i mean you said will forgetting and
i think that's absolutely right and
and i it's it's even the word forgetting
seems to me to be a little bit wrong
because i think there was a a sustained
and
and highly deliberate as well as
unconscious attempt actually to purge
the lessons so-called of vietnam after
all they were called a syndrome a
sickness something that you had to get
over
and
i think we saw that in the reagan years
but reagan
in other words vietnam was a defeat a
defeat is a very hard thing to embrace
there's a wonderful title of a book
about the occupation of japan about the
japanese by
uh
mr
i'm sorry
embracing defeat
uh
name will come to me
uh but
the united states
i don't think ever
accepted
the defeat and there was an effort
thereafter and especially in the reagan
administration perhaps you witnessed
this and uh
in latin america to actually purge the
lessons of vietnam by reenacting some
kind of a victory somewhere so that we
would no longer be
a defeated nation actually
reagan
did
uh did less than you than he might if it
was covert it was under the table there
were no 500 000 troops
sent anywhere he sort of drew back many
times from the edge although
sponsoring these dreadful and horrific
sort of
covert efforts
in latin america i don't know what do
you have experience in
i find that amnesia
which strikes
a defeated country almost immediately
fascinating i saw it in for the first
time in buenos aires when i covered the
falkland war
but i saw it again in belgrade
after the serbs
after the nitto bombing broke the serbs
in bosnia and um people just there was a
midsummer night's dream quality
where
everything that had happened before
sometimes in the case of bosnia for
three or four years
didn't exist
and there's a there's a wonderful story
i i think it's maybe in churchill one of
churchill's
memoirs about uh
after the end of world war ii the french
inviting the french military inviting
their british counterparts to come for
lessons of the war and the british show
up and it's all about world war one
or if you i remember visiting the
imperial war museum in vienna and going
through all the rooms and finishing
world war one and asking
where the exhibit on world war ii was
and of course there isn't one anywhere
in vienna anywhere in austria
and i think that that
that
need for amnesia is something that
strikes a populace after a defeat
and it it it has for those of us who
uh
who live through the conflict
it it has
opposite it turns it as a it creates a
bizarre reality
in the case of the united states um of
course it was not a defeat on our soil
so so that's different from from some
exciting santa
but uh
i think for
a period of
five years
actually it was only five years um
there there was a a real sense right in
the middle of washington and not only
among the democrats but not entirely
that
we never never
do anything like that again that and
that the power of the imperial
presidency had to be curbed and there
were a lot of laws passed at that at
that time
um
then
there was uh the oil shock
um
the fall of the shah
uh a sense that um brezhnev was on the
move
both diplomatically and otherwise
and that
um we were becoming this um what nixon
called as do know what is that pitiful
helpless giant yes
and
when reagan ran in in 1980 um his
rhetoric was a most extraordinary
reversion to the past
um it that rhetoric could have come
straight out of the 1950s
um and it had all of the sort of
elements of
of um
sort of the the american sort of civil
uh religion in it
which reagan spoke so very well
but it was it was saying that
we are renewing
here we are we are renewing this country
so that it will be the way it was in the
past it was very past oriented and
curious absolutely yeah and um
and i think people longed to hear that
at that particular time they really
wanted this uh notion that we would be
safe back in the 50s again um i get
turmoil in the united states having gone
on as well um
and um
and so he was essentially preaching this
this uh this this revival of our
national religion um
and uh
at the same time what's what was
interesting about it is that is that
while while on one hand it was saying
he was saying uh vietnam didn't happen
in this fashion
um
uh
the military
and uh indeed the defense secretary
casper weinberger were laying down a set
of rules
um and they literally uh you know it's
on paper um we will never do this again
we won't ever go in without the support
of the american people without it
uh with that without um
uh overwhelming force uh without an exit
strategy et cetera et cetera et cetera
and um you can find that uh in many
places on but including in powell's
tells me more
yeah well then weinberg
there's a great saying about
nationalism uh that it's often based on
forgetting a lot of things the
foundation of nationalism is to forget
all kinds of things and i think that
that's that sort of restoration that
reagan uh
offered was uh was very similar to that
at the same time you know and you've
written on this uh you know there was a
within the reagan administration this
disconnect with reality
um and um
you write a lot about sdi and how there
was this need to feel that were
protected even though of course it was
an impossibility
and to what extent was that the
beginning of a widening disconnect with
our own reality and the reality of the
world that we live in
well i don't think the disconnect was
really in the reagan administration i
think it's in ourselves and reagan
understood that
beautifully he he understood he didn't
even have to look at the polls but if
you look at the polls going back
to 1947 up to that point if if
the american public was asked
can we have a defense against
a nuclear missiles
everybody would say of course but a half
of them would be shocked that we didn't
have it already i mean what is the
defense department doing if it's not
defending us or itself so
um you know
people really could could not swallow
the notion of of deterrence the notion
of of uh you know
mutual assured destruction
and and so reagan simply used that um
when
uh
jonathan shell
jonathan shell wrote an extraordinary
book
at that time
when did it come
83 94
right
reagan's next election
um
which uh
uh was part of the
and
helped create the anti-nuclear movement
at that time because well that faded the
earth was 82 yeah
that's what i was thinking fate of the
era so it's early on in the anti-nuclear
movement that's right
and um
this movement became so large at the
time because i mean one of the things
that reagan was doing was simply
building up
uh
our whole nuclear arsenal
at a great rate and um and not talking
to russians at all and that made a lot
of people extremely nervous
um
uh
so the antinuclear movement came from
nowhere where very middle class became
enormous um spurred on by by jonathan's
uh book just describing what what a
nuclear explosion would do
um
and
then what happened uh reagan changed his
whole message
in 84. it suddenly it became much more
positive opening
world and
he he uh he simply made everyone forget
um that in fact this nuclear buildup was
going going on steadily by saying all
right we're going to have the star wars
we're going to have this wonderful
shield over the united states and he did
it all by himself he wrote that speech
all by himself and uh
um the the few people who actually saw
it it was just that actually was a few
paragraphs at the end of a sort of a
normal
defense speech
the physical assault said you can't say
that you can't say that
and he knew exactly how to say that
so that so that
people would see him as a man of peace
yeah you know i think
what you say goes you know right to the
heart of a kind of a paradox of american
power
really throughout the
nuclear age and never more acute than at
this moment which is that on the one
hand
and now more so than ever we consider
ourselves to be the great superpower the
sole superpower the hyper power and so
forth
and certainly nuclear weapons are
supposed to be
a supreme expression of that
and yet when you really look at it it
turns out that there's almost nothing
that you can actually do with them
and at the same time that we're the
hyper power and the superpower we are
hyper vulnerable and super vulnerable
and our biggest buildings can be knocked
down by a couple of airliners now that
paradox was present in vietnam too
uh you mentioned the nixon's phrase
pitiful helpless giant and so here we
are all bulked up with military force
straddling the world and we're supposed
to be able to get a terrific payoff out
of that
and yet then we go to a tiny little
country vietnam then now iraq
and it turns out to be exceedingly
difficult to work our will for the
reasons that frankie was alluding to
namely that what really counts in these
countries is the local politics and
the u.s forces can troop back and forth
and kill all kinds of people and destroy
cities to save them and all the rest of
it and then at the end of the day the
people there
unless the us stays there forever just
going to do what they like
so i think that part of this forgetting
this aggressive forgetting that we're
talking about
is
is a cure for a fundamental paradox and
problem of american power or indeed of
any great military power in our time
uh which is that it it it tries to find
a way to restore
the idea
that we are immensely powerful in a
world in which military strength
actually doesn't give you
uh that kind of power and i think we
we've been struggling with that problem
psychologically you know uh secretary of
state
dean rusk
once
said we're the greatest power in the
world if only we act like it
so there it is we're the greatest but
somehow there's a doubt about it somehow
we're falling through a trap door we're
not acting like why aren't we acting
like it because if we act like it will
blow up the whole world ourselves
included
so it's not so easy to act like it and
then if you go and try that a little bit
as in vietnam or now in iraq
it turns out you get burned
and you don't even achieve the minor exa
objectives that you set out to to
take
go back to salvador for a moment because
we're talking about the reagan
administration um
there are some who have made parallels
between iraq and el salvador uh with the
notion being that um
uh free elections
finally triumphed there and um
uh that
uh
this is this is sort of good news for
well the of course the
the great
outcome of the salvadoran elections is
that they elected roberto dalbyson
the head of the death squads
of arena and who ran death squads as
president and then of course the u.s
embassy worked behind the scenes to make
sure he never assumed office
i think i think there were a lot of
lessons
in
central america
that
are useful for understanding iraq
first and foremost being of course that
the united states while it pays lip
service to democracy that's sort of the
last thing that they want what they want
is a malleable government that they can
control
um that has the appearance of legitimacy
which of course this interim government
does not
um
but you know a democratic iraq as
somebody who spent seven years in the
middle east and a lot of that time in
iraq would probably a clerically
controlled shiite iraq with very close
close ties to iran
and that's just something that's never
going to happen
in terms of the fighting itself
i think there's a difference
i think it it has probably a little more
to do with the israeli
occupation of gaza
in some ways uh than the war in central
america because of course we had
surrogate forces we had the contras in
nicaragua we had the salvadoran army
fighting against the fmln but we didn't
actually have american occupation forces
on the ground
but having spent a lot of time in gaza
one sees
or very quickly becomes aware
of how dangerous that and what a
unifying factor that hostility is number
one and number two what happens when you
have an occupying force that has
disproportionate firepower that is able
to go to an urban
environment or refugee camp in gaza and
call in apache helicopters
and the the you know if you haven't been
in a war zone that the fact that you're
using apaches to attack houses in
hanunes doesn't mean anything but for
those of us who've watched apaches these
are flying tanks is what they are i was
in the last tank battle of the gulf war
and the an entire iraqi uh tank division
was wiped out essentially by apaches
um and or the fact that you use f-16
fighter jets to bomb jebalia um
and that's what's happening in iraq
that it's that escalation of massive
firepower
um you know the fact that you're walking
into a slum
in fallujah and unleashing with 50
caliber machine guns
um and of course
they worked very hard so that we don't
know
the numbers of the dead but i think it
touches on the frustration you're
talking about um and and of course that
only galvanizes i mean what we have done
is taken a very fractured country
and created a very unified rebellion
against that occupation and i think that
in in some ways it bears a lot of
similarity to what the french went
through in algeria you know you go
through the airport in algiers and it
says welcome to algeria the land of a
million martyrs
and um when you live under that kind of
degradation and i think that's something
that you
got so well in your book you know that
the the problem with the people running
this enterprise is then there's that
wonderful essay by danilo quiche about
how all nationalists are inherently
ignoramuses because they only see the
world as a reflection of their own
national everybody's a nationalism just
like them a nationalist just like them
and i think that um you know without an
understanding of
uh the communal ties the family ties the
truth you know the undercurrent of the
society their perspective of reality um
we can only speak in the language of
force and an escalating language of
force um
and one that dooms us because the le the
big lesson you learn in el salvador when
you walk away from that conflict after
five years that the best recruiting
weapon the rebels had were martyrs
um were the death squads the the the the
best recruiting weapon the fmln had were
the salvadoran desk quotes
um and
i'd like to talk a little bit about
iraq and specifically and
um
and what parallels you see with vietnam
if any and what differences you see
um
in in the way the conflict is proceeding
well you just brought up some some um
similarities uh so i'll go for
differences um
uh
this election that's just been passed
we've just had in iraq
um there was never anything like it in
vietnam and for for a simple reason that
we were we were trying in in vietnam
to uh suppress a an indigenous
revolution
and so therefore those people were by
definition not allowed to vote and um
nor was anyone else who was even on the
margins
uh so we never had a free election in in
in vietnam and uh it would have um
because our entire purpose was to was to
to
save this uh
non-communist regime
um
in iraq it seems to be a little
different uh because um
while uh
we
clearly
when i say we i the administration does
not want uh sodom hussein to come back
again again but
uh
there's it's there's not a parallel
situation in that in that um
they don't want to suppress the sunnis
or the shia or goodness knows the kurds
um and you know at this point uh
you know people talk brave i mean the
president will keep on talking bravely
about democracy but what they would
really like is is for the iraqis to make
some kind of a deal um those iraqis who
who think that
that uh there should be um a stable
government and an end to the insurgency
so the issue is
my view whether whether um
those who were elected uh were mostly
shia of course um can actually make that
deal themselves because we're not going
to be able to do it for them uh make it
with with the sunni who who um
uh
and make them feel that they will be
part of a a new uh
a new uh iraq um can that happen i would
hate to try and predict that one but i
it seems to me that the u.s role
in terms of and in terms of iraqi
politics is rather different than
yeah that that sounds right to me i
think that the what what
the comparison that is that is there and
that holds true is that the local
politics whatever they are
are going to dominate at the end of the
day but those local politics are
fundamentally different because in
vietnam
you had a sustained united historically
deeply based
revolutionary independence movement that
had already defeated one foreign power
the french and you had and and now is
targeting the next one the united states
and also there was half of the country
uh that was um
uh under the control
of the
of that movement namely north vietnam
and then behind them several superpowers
china and russia layer upon layer so
that was far different from uh iraq
and and quite honestly i i don't feel
able like like frankie to make a
prediction i don't feel so expert in
that
area of the world but what's
apparent
is that iraq right now is not does not
have that kind of incredible national
unity
that the vietnamese had what it has is a
fractured
society
and the fractures seem to be deepening
and on the one hand clearly the election
did evoke an emotion from the iraqis
that was unlike anything we saw in in
vietnam i happened to witness one of
these so-called elections in vietnam i
went to a
a province uh
ben tray i think it was
and there was this election that was
going on in 1967
uh and i went out there in the sort of
muddy streets and uh nobody was there
nobody was there and then it turned out
the candidates had got stuck somewhere
else in some other city and there was
this rally ground no people had come no
candidates what did come
but there was one little old man who had
a strange contraption of bullhorn
an old fashioned not electronic just
like a guns cap
that was strapped to his shoulders by a
strange metal apparatus and he was going
up and down the street saying come to
the election rally come to the election
route and i was with the with the boys
on the bus at that time
and there were like 40 or 50 reporters
there they had nothing to show except
this one little old man
now that was the election in south
vietnam just no candidates
no voters just this little old man of
all the western news
people trying to pretend that something
was happening well that's far different
in iraq uh so so it's a different
politics i was thinking takashi okay who
is a wonderful japanese correspondent in
vietnam uh
recorded a remark he heard from one of
the villagers after that election in 67
the villagers said you know
every
every um
uh
vote is sort of is like a feather and
when we put all the feathers on these
candidates they fly away and we never
see them again
that's great that's beautiful
that's true
before i open it up to questions which
we will do i just want to ask
both of you to back up a little bit and
talk about
this coming proliferation of nuclear
weapons
not just in north korea
but having spent a year of my life
covering al qaeda certainly it's the
feeling among many intelligence officers
that it there it is
probably inevitable that
some of these groups who are arrayed
against us will get their hands on at
least crude version of these weapons
dirty bombs etc and
um are we entering
perhaps an apocalyptic age are we
entering an age unlike one that we have
seen before
and how are we preparing for it
go ahead jonathan
well
i do think that the uh
with the theme that the nuclear danger
it's sort of like a steel spine a hidden
steel spine around which events
have have revolved really going back
since to
1945 and i think we're in a new chapter
in that evolution
uh i think at the heart of it
is our we're talking about willful
ignorance our resolute determination not
to see and grasp the meaning of the fact
that we ourselves have a great mountain
of nuclear weapons still in this world
and that so do the russians and the
french and the chinese and so on and so
forth
and now the north koreans and the
indians and the pakistanis
the way i see it as long as we're unable
to see
the nuclear weapons that are in
existence
we're not going to be able to persuade
other people not to bring new ones
uh into existence so
i think we've now entered a period of
stepped-up proliferation very clearly
north korea being the latest to announce
anyway that it's across the finish line
iran is seems to be on its way as far as
we can tell
and it it appears once again
that this is moving like a to the center
of things it's like an axle on which the
events are turning
because after all what was the iraq war
all about putatively it was about
weapons of mass that's how it was sold
to the country and to the world after
all the resolutions at the u.n and that
congress mentioned this they didn't talk
about democracy in lebanon
they talked about weapons of mass
destruction and so also that's the theme
for several other prospective wars which
i like to call disarmament wars
uh which which may lie in our future
starting with iran although
it's not so clear that they simply have
the wherewithal to do with that but
certainly the doctrinal foundation
has been laid so uh as long as you
uh
don't have
a handle on that
control of that it's going to control
you and now it's doing so in a new way
just as it did in the cold war in
another way where really that
we the
united states and the soviet union
weren't unable to stop the
arms race uh between us
until the cold war ended and really
until gorbachev appeared and the gold
were and then they began to
tail it down although let's remember uh
that we still have some you know 32 000
nuclear weapons in the world today
people forget that they just forget that
entirely it passes out of their mind but
there they are
so
so if
that that's where i think we are now i
think that nuclear weapons and the other
weapons of mass destruction but still
above all the nuclear are in the saddle
again in a whole new way in this whole
proliferation
uh
nexus
um
i'm going to put terrorism aside for a
moment just and talk about state control
them
but because it seems to me that
end of the cold war comes
and
um
suddenly we uh have a very much simpler
view about what power is than we used to
have yes you touched on this before
military power is power
period um
uh who was it calls calls the
the bush
the bush people the whack-a-moles right
no just go and take it out and it comes
back up again and you know you just
whack it
so
um
it's not uh you know but i think that
that uh that they've they've they've
come to the end of of
of this uh logic
because uh
uh not only are we bogged down in iraq
but
clearly we have um been going backwards
in terms of north korea um simply
because they they uh refuse to to uh
enter into negotiations of any sort of
kind and the north koreans are
are
you know all kinds of cheating and all
kinds of things
go on i mean not making them into saints
but the point is um
the the the uh
that um the clinton administration was
able to use threat and carrot and so on
um and we've always this the bush
administration just refuses the carrots
and
it's now
um i think finally coming around
uh
to the europe more of the european
position on on iran because there's
simply nothing else to do and they're
taking the only choice they have the
other one is simply to do nothing
there's no there's no military solution
there any more than there is in korea so
you know if that gets through
you know that there is actually um
more to power than simply uh trying to
counter proliferation is the word um
then um
then we're i think we're we may be
getting somewhere finally and there was
not
the way there was in the cold war a sort
of unalterable sense that
that most of the world
i mean the the
the nuclear superpowers are
unalterably ideologically opposed and so
therefore there is you know at least
some political
basis that didn't didn't exist before
now the terrorism thing is is another
matter and and um and uh
and a scary one because we have so done
so little with non-proliferation um thus
far including uh you know trying to try
to to uh uh
mop up the loose nukes in in in uh in
russia that um we're way behind on on
that and um uh
well you tell us what the what's
what is being said
there's a there's a deep fear that that
it's just a question of time until
crude versions of these apocalyptic
weapons fall into the hands of groups
who are very hungry use those
let's take a few questions
uh
and we have mics so please wait until
the microphone comes in the green
sweater here
right here right here i think can you
wait please speak into the microphone
sure
hi
i think that
when we're talking about nuclear
weapons
uh the united states
is guilty of not only making them
but using them
so
to talk about terrorism
and this country is
trying to get it that country is almost
getting it that country we haven't
negotiated with
this is all bogus
for a country this size with arsenal
this big
we should set the agenda
we should say
we're not going to make any more bombs
instead of saying we're making bomblets
nucleus we're going gonna so so this way
if we can get you
i'm gonna try and get you and not maybe
you
so this is a this discussion about i
don't think anybody here disagrees with
you do you have a question you want to
have jonathan i don't think any of us
disagree with you
good
but let's let jonathan this is his area
and any
uh
my question is
do you think
that
countries
that have nuclear weapons
should all
agree
to stop making them and stop using them
and
plus get rid of the ones they have i do
yes
see i think the problem is which you
have expressed uh
is that i
as a moral matter certainly
but also as a
practical matter i don't think that a
double standard can stand i don't think
that the house divided can stand
uh so you you
can't have a world in which those who
sit on top of great piles of nuclear
weapons
are giving angry lectures to those who
are trying to climb up the slopes of
those piles and get
just a few themselves i just don't think
it's uh
it's workable so you have to go to a
single standard and i think that the
world will go to a single standard the
question is what is it going to be that
anybody who wants them can have them
that's where we're headed right now
or is it going to be that everybody goes
together after a long hideously
difficult political military diplomatic
economic process admittedly
a tall mountain to climb uh but that at
the end of the day nobody has them and
that and that is the in my opinion the
only workable regime and i say that
of course it's an idealistic thing it's
highly idealistic to imagine this which
nobody in any
uh government that i've heard of is
really thinking about seriously to be
perfectly honest about it and yet i say
that as a matter of the coldest realism
because
in addition i'm not bothered about
making it a moral statement it is a
moral statement when you're when you're
dealing with these hideous weapons but
it is also
a
a practical matter so my message to
those who say well you know we can't get
rid of them i said all right then get
used to proliferation and to this
terrorists falling into the terrorists
hands if that's your position then
accept the consequence be realistic
about it and tell us what you're going
to do about that and i think the
important thing in raising the issue of
the possibility of
uh terrorist groups using weapons of
mass destruction is that it then becomes
the excuse that we seize upon to use
weapons of mass destruction that's the
danger that we fall into in a kind of
apocalyptic nightmare where our
apocalyptic visionaries are matched
against their apocalyptic visionaries
and
and
certainly the point you make is a
correct one but we may very well be
facing
very soon
a world
where
these weapons or crude versions of them
are being used and
uh and and having lived in israel
through the suicide bombings
when people are afraid and they stop
thinking it all becomes how can we stop
the vermin out
and who can we grasp within our society
ariel sharon who will do it for us i'm
not picking on the israelis no society
is any different having lived through
the war in yugoslavia and other
conflicts
but i don't think that's something we've
stopped and thought about
and we have to begin to think about it
in the in the red sweater over here
oh go ahead
ma'am hi
oh thank you um
what can we do in terms of legal
uh
structures that exist to like promote
this for instance the non-proliferation
treaty is coming up
this april and we promised in that tree
to get rid of our nuclear weapons i mean
how can we kind of get people back to
sanity as a nation of laws i mean have
you seen
that playing out it seems like we're
kind of losing our grip on our legal
obligation
well this administration has been
against all arms control treaties from
from the beginning so really it's a
political problem it's not you know
it's a political problem in this country
it's a political problem in some other
countries as well
um
so
you know obviously the the legal part of
it is is the end process
uh honey in the glasses
hi
um
my question is for uh mr shell um
i agree with you you're saying about you
know all these all the countries getting
together
oh can you hear me now
great
that's not like they got that commercial
now but uh my question is um i mean how
do you envision that logistically i mean
how do you think that these governments
will sort of sit around together and
actually get down to the business of
agreeing uh on getting rid of their
nuclear weapons i mean i agree
in principle it sounds wonderful but how
would it work just sort of the short
version of
how you think it would work yeah i think
what frankie says is true uh the the
the himalaya that stands in the way is
the political
problem it's it's uh finding the will
developing the will the technical side
of it is quite doable
uh already we're down about 50 percent
so keep going and do the other 50 now
they're all kinds i don't want to
minimize the difficulties of what does
the world look like at 500 at 200 at
zero and so forth it's fantastically
complex and difficult i won't go into it
all but it's it's it's doable but the
problem is doing it uh is having the
having the will to do it now how might
that come about i said before that
there's scarce
but i misspoke when i said that there
are not people in governments who want
to do this because there are 182
countries in the world under the nuclear
nonproliferation treaty which alice
slater over here was referring to which
have decided as a matter of national
policy to do without nuclear weapons
that's a lot of countries and that would
be absolutely delighted the majority of
them if the nuclear powers would go down
the path that they are on all of south
america is nuclear weapon free and they
are nuclear weapon capable and they went
up the slope and then they got a little
look looked at what that looked like and
then they went down again they went back
down again so
it can be done but just to make one
final comment about
the
practicability or where that will might
come from
in the 1990s everybody just forgot about
nuclear weapons nobody thought about it
not bill clinton not the man on the
street
not the diplomats not the foundations
everybody just forgot about it
not so today
both kerry and bush when asked what was
the most important issue in the third
debate whatever debate
said it was nuclear proliferation i
would add possession but at least they
got got it half right
not only that but the thing is in play
it's in process
in many countries around the world and
it's not just iran and north korea
either they're muttering in brazil about
you know they're so they don't want to
have their facilities inspected they're
in japan you know there are few people
on the sidelines of government who are
are talking about
japan's capacity and japan is ready to
go they've got the plutonium they've got
everything anyway the point is that
there's a process underway and there are
consequences and already north korea has
crossed the finish line now how bad
the breakdown has to get before somebody
says wait a minute we're on the wrong
path
i don't know but the evidence is piling
up and will continue to pile up
there's a lot over here oh
okay in the back
in
go ahead so in the chat with us right my
name is jones
hello uh one thing that was missing i
thought in the discussion this evening
the discussion the media's role
in the attitude of the american people
that sort of came about by itself or by
reaganism or by
understanding a vietnam war and a
different light but there have been no
discussion at least from the three of
you guys
about and women sorry about the
situation
in uh in the media which is absolutely
intolerable including the new york times
mr hedges i'm very sorry to say
you know i was i worked for abc for 16
years i'm 18 years
very unproud of it there are a lot of
dreadful things there
as the new york times
has continued to do on really dreadful
things it's a high brow piece of rubbish
and
as opposed to the new york times
post which is a little piece of rubbish
but it's a piece of rubbish the same and
fools the people constantly and i
understand you need to make a living
like i needed to make a living how to
put kids through college or what have
you but anyway i'm a documentary
filmmaker all right well let's we'll
we'll address the media i'll sell the
door like you
you know and i remember some of the
reporting from el salvador you know and
it was certainly unfavorable to the
people that are trying to overthrow the
12
12 people there that control the entire
right thanks we'll we'll look we'll talk
about that okay tell us what you want
to say
let me let me go five years ago there
are other people who want to ask
questions we'll address the media issue
i'll make an issue did you know that the
new york times in
1999 in fact
the filipino annexation at the cost of
750 000 uh filipino lives did you know
that
all right thank you very much um well
let's addre i mean you know the issue of
the media is an important one and the
role the media and you know it's
something that um i wrote about in my
own book and i know
you have dealt with as well
um
you know the problem is that in almost
all wars the media becomes part of the
problem
um uh the media
um
and having reported conflicts for my own
country is not directly involved and
reported conflicts where they are
directly involved um once your own
nation goes to war there is a kind of
feeling among the media that they have
that their job is to promote that
patriotic myth that myth of glory and
honor and courage and uh
and when you walk into a situation uh
it's almost like they look for those set
uh character roles that they can place
on the stage and recreate over and over
and over um there's a
you know i think it's uh lashon and his
book talks about uh the difference
between
um
uh sensory and abstract notions of war
and that we don't get sensory war
reporting when our own nation goes to
war but these abstract
notions where we use these very hollow
abstract terms such as the ones i just
laid out for you honor glory heroism all
this kind of stuff um and that uh he
would argue that eventually the war in
vietnam became a sensory conflict where
people no longer could buy into the myth
anymore and the press was free to report
in a sensory manner which is just the
brutality of war itself but i think if
you go back all the way back to the
crimean war where arguably the first war
correspondent uh was invented um it has
been a shameful period of reporting and
i include the spanish civil war uh from
the republican side um you know and and
and the lie of war
is often the lie of omission it's all
the things they don't tell you or show
you uh and i think that uh
you know those few courageous souls um
you know i sit next to two of them who
uh go out and actually try and report on
war as it is um uh often have to work on
the on the very margins of the press
of the media itself
um
media questions always drive me nuts in
a way because because uh you know
there's it's it's not one thing it's a
vast world out there um there are an
awful lot of good reporters in it look
at seymour hirsch
[Applause]
from eli to abu ghraib
um
you know we there is a way in which we
get to know things um that uh uh
and then we criticize the media but
somehow we got to know those things
through the media so
and it seems to me that if you know
if uh if you read enough
and read is probably operative word here
um
uh
that you that you can find out a lot of
things and if you read in the in the in
the skeptical fashion and um uh look
beyond this you know you get to know how
reporting is done um
then uh it's it's out there to find um
you know sometimes
there are there are periods when it
isn't um and uh
the period before the iraq war was was
was a particular period when there was
very little but even
even at the time even at the time one
could pretty well say gee whiz i doubt
that iraq has nuclear weapons i doubt
that they have a nuclear program that's
advanced because that was
was what was
also being reported
um
i'll make just two quick comments um
one is that of course pressure of every
kind on
the media
you know nationalist popular pressure
commercial pressure governmental
pressure and all three going together
produce a very bad result and i think
certainly in my memory this period of
the iraq war has been the very worst
uh period in terms of media coverage
that i have seen
but you know if you go back uh to the
first world war or for that matter this
the spanish-american war that produced
the
occupation of the philippines uh you'll
find as chris i think is suggesting
you'll find many of these uh
same things my second comment is that
there's a solution to all this read the
nation magazine
uh
right here in the red
can you hear me
take it
i've lost my voice so i
ask you
could you talk about the economic motive
the thing that has struck me about
the recent
several years is dr khan in pakistan
many of us are remember
other times but it seems that dr khan's
motive was strictly financial that we
have a free market here that is uh out
selling these weapons to whomever wants
them
sure
um well the head of the the
international atomic energy agency
muhammad al baradai referred to the khan
that's the pakistani scientist who was
proliferating nuclear
know-how all over the world uh referred
to that operation as a nuclear walmart
um
and
i i agree with you i was very
startled to learn that someone so high
up
uh could be so much inspired by a
commercial motive now i suspect by the
way that that isn't the only one because
there's no one who believes that that
was done without the knowledge of the
pakistani government one of the black
holes of journalism right now
is or government policy or understanding
is to know really what that operation
was who is involved in the pakistani
government over a long period of time
operating in dubai and malaysia
iran iraq
libya all over the place really an
amazing operation but but to fully
understand that operation which was
certainly the most egregious example of
proliferation and of loose nukes and
everything else that you can imagine
that that story has not been uh told
very surprising to me he was building
he's been building villas all over the
middle east with the proceeds from his
centrifuges
we'll do just two more questions let's
get this gentleman back here
in the event that history goes down this
unfortunate route can you recommend a
good up-to-date source of civil defense
information that's appropriate to 21st
century scenarios most of what i've seen
was published like in the 1950s when it
was a question of massive attack by
superpowers
if we see a flash on the horizon what do
we do next
you have a good civil defense to offer
frankie no i i know and the only
actually the only thing i can think of
i'm certainly not going to say because
it has to do with probably not not being
quite so near this very building
i mean this neighborhood
yes sir
my question is what is it nor i live in
england and i'm an american
what is it in our culture
that prevents us from reporting
as clearly and as aggressively the truth
that the british press seems to handle
there is a channel channel 4 which is a
commercial channel in great britain and
it handles abu ghraib it handles
terrorism and it handles it with
forthrightness i think you're a little
too tentative for me saying well there
are commercial considerations why are we
not a bit more aggressive it is possible
to be so and tell the truth
[Applause]
well
i think
i i agree with you that the british
press has been better than the american
president and you can find out a lot
in the british press that you that you
don't find out here and it's more
prominently displayed and so on
especially with regard to abu ghraib and
the war and so forth well um but i think
that all of the pressures
that that make for bad coverage are more
intense in the united states at this
moment than they are in britain i think
everybody really knows that this is an
american war and that the british are
sort of tagging on tagging along they're
not invested in it in the same way
certainly in public opinion uh
they are not
uh
and uh
so i think that there's and also they
didn't experience september 11th which
is the
uh fuel the political fuel that the bush
administration uses
in its campaign with the american public
even down to this day
so i just think it's a uh
the pressures are just far more intense
here and probably that's the reason
i would do one one last question then
right right here
this woman in the back row
um haven't really heard is
beneath all this um
the economic
impact of the iraq war on iraq
where i understand that
the oil industries are now privatized
and in general you know it seems to be
like an avoidance of saying anything
that might smack of a marx
marxist analysis
of international capitalism of
the lack of governmental structures
to deal with any of these things with
the you know
see it in the interview with condoleezza
rice
she was interviewed
she had nothing too good to say about
venezuela
and cuba
and it was really disturbing to me
i don't remember which senator or
senators
was just that can you go right to the
police and deal with her
they were so frustrated okay what's the
question so the question is
what
can be done to address what's really
happening here
i mean we have basically taken a country
okay why isn't anything being said about
this all right you wanna
you wanna go after that nope deal
well
you know the economic
motive is ever-present
and hugely powerful
you know you were almost uh
silenced if you dared to suggest that
the iraq war had anything to do with oil
you know what
what i wanted to answer to that
facetiously is that uh oil has been a
central concern of the united states
certainly since 1945 when fdr made a
special visit to king ibn saud
to make sure that we would secure our
supplies there and you can go down
through history in many volumes showing
that the carter doctrine and
that's 1979 to preserve the persian gulf
a vital interest of the united states
and all the rest of it right down to the
red so the idea that they suddenly
forgot about oil at exactly the moment
they were heading into a country with
the second largest uh reserves is simply
absurd
it's absolutely absurd so and i suppose
in order to understand what the
motivation was and how it figures in
exactly we'd have to wait until some
pentagon papers of this period
would come out whether they were afraid
that the oil countries would put their
dollar dollars in your or you know
euros instead of dollars or whatever the
considerations there are many theories
about it i suppose we won't have the
specific answers
but to suggest that uh
the business interests and oil are are
not a powerful
impetus
here uh would just be to deny uh the
history of the last 50 years
well the irony is of course that that uh
this invasion is actually endangered oil
supplies and in in
far more than it would have been
otherwise
degradation of the iraqi oil oil fields
um
threat to uh saudi oil fields still
because uh saudis are
worried about the iranians again
possibility of a conflagration right in
the gulf um this is one
possible outcome of this war so
uh
you know it turned out not to be the
most efficient way to deliver oil no i
forgot to say my facetious thing which
was if they aren't thinking about oil
they should be impeached
one way or another
we're going to turn it over to ham thank
you very much
thanks to this wonderful panel this
evening thanks to the new school for
letting us use the facilities
co-sponsoring this event
to c-span and it's uh
wonderful audience for
helping
our american who lives in england to
realize that there's diversity in the
media in this country
and please stay tuned for future nation
institute panels thank you very much
the jonathan shell reader is published
by nation books on the web at
nationbooks.org
francis fitzgerald is author of fire in
the lake
visit twbookmark.com
for more information
[Music]
um
i want to thank you all for coming it's
it's incredibly uh heartening and
exciting to see so many people turn out
to talk about books and ideas and and in
this case press coverage
on a
beautiful saturday afternoon i think
this is one of the greatest events in
in los angeles of the year because it
brings everyone together
thank you
i will uh introduce the panelists and
then we'll have a go at each other for a
while and then we'll open it to
questions and your you will have to go
to the mics to ask your questions
because this is being filmed for c-span
so they won't be able to hear your
questions if you don't do that
so we'll start with
uh
mark bowden
i've practiced this all morning
all right two ways i know and then it
was 50 50.
mark bowden is national correspondent
for the atlantic magazine and his new
book on the iran hostage crisis guests
of the ayatollah will be out this winter
from atlantic monthly press his other
books include black hawk down road work
finders keepers killing pablo bringing
on the heat and doctor death and he's
been a journalist for many many years
terry mcdermott
has been a reporter at eight newspapers
for 25 years the last seven of them at
the los angeles times in his newspaper
jobs he's covered county zoning board
state legislatures
and the los angeles police department
with its peculiar culture
he's written on an enormous range of
subjects the financing design and
construction of skyscrapers
the search for a rare blood molecule the
california dream
he was assigned to write about the 9 11
plot within days of the attacks on new
york and washington
and that assignment uh led to his book
which will be out
next month
may perfect soldiers terry mcdermott
and chris hedges was a foreign
correspondent for nearly 20 years most
of them with the new york times and is
the author of war is a force that gives
us meaning he was part of the team of
the new york times reporters who won the
2002 pulitzer prize for the paper's
coverage of global terrorism he's
covered at conflicts in central america
where we first met
and in
the middle east africa and the balkans
his new book losing moses on the freeway
the ten commandments in america will be
out in june and he's a senior fellow at
the nation institute chris hedges
[Applause]
so collectively these journalists have
covered a lot of wars in central america
from somalia to the so-called war on
terrorism
they've immersed themselves in combat
they've stood back and analyzed
dictators and al-qaeda warriors
and the question that i would put on the
table is whether the media
has advanced at all in covering war in
uh in this war in iraq
whether
from say somalia to now we're doing any
better of a job at presenting the
reality of war
in getting at what's really happening
during a war
and
at reaching the public so that they
are able to have educated opinions about
the war so mark i'll start with you and
ask you
if you see any evolution since somalia
clearly we're able to get better
pictures and and faster pictures but do
we have any better or more information
yes we have a lot more information and a
lot better information um
uh mogadishu which is probably not a
good uh point of comparison because
there were no reporters in mogadishu for
the battle
most of the news organizations had
pulled their reporters out of somalia uh
some months before because it had become
so dangerous and also because it had
really receded as a story uh americans
weren't that interested in what was
going on there
so when i wrote blackhawk down i mean i
covered uh this is the best way to cover
a war and that is you start after the
battle is over
and uh and you find the people who are
there and you reconstruct it that way no
one shoots at you while you're uh
working
um
i in the in the case of iraq i think
that the uh
the biggest thing was the military's
decision to embed reporters not that
embedded reporters uh convey the whole
story but i think they convey
a very important part of that story and
i think that all americans and people
all over the world got
a much better feel for and a much better
understanding of what the united states
was doing whether you liked it or not in
iraq
when they invaded and i think you know a
number of my friends some very talented
very brave
journalists have covered that war
and continue to do so
in a way that we haven't seen really
since vietnam and i think it's a
tremendous benefit to society i mean we
are a democracy we need to make up our
minds about
what our military forces are doing
overseas and it's extraordinarily
helpful to have a good feel for what's
actually going on
i saw it for instance in that episode
earlier this year where the nbc
reporter was present when a marine shot
and killed a uh
an injured
iraqi um and i think that there was an
appropriate level of outrage over the
fact that that had happened but tempered
with the knowledge
of the tremendous strains
that these young men are under uh in
combat there i think that most people
who saw that both were
appalled by the fact that it happened
but also had a certain measure of
understanding
and sympathy for a terrified young
soldier
in a very difficult situation making
what apparently was a bad judgment
i think things like that are valuable
extraordinarily valuable and are only
available because of the
the opportunity that journalists have
been given to cover that war
and we've also seen you know the growth
of international uh media television uh
from arab states from
european channels who are covering the
war from different perspectives
sometimes very jarring and difficult for
americans to see but i think extremely
healthy and important so i see an
improvement it it's interesting that if
you go back to somalia you had very few
reporters or photographers very very
little press
and yet the impact of the killing of
just a few americans had was dramatic on
foreign policy it basically forced a
pull out by the
clinton administration and in fact
affected uh future deployments and
willingness or not to go into the
balkans right and here you have hundreds
of americans dying all the time right
and it seems to have very little impact
on public opinion or policy
what do you make of that
well i think it had such a huge impact
in somalia precisely because of the
deaths
in the battle of mogadishu occurred if
entirely free of context i think you
know most americans had no idea that
american soldiers were being sent out on
missions in mogadishu that were so
dangerous and so that the possibility of
a of a running gun battle over 18 hours
where 18 to 19 americans are killed and
thousands of somalis are killed was
a complete surprise and so i think
people were shocked i think there was
very little understanding in this
country of what the nature of the
american mission was in somalia so
those deaths and in particular those
grotesque images of dead american
soldiers being dragged through the
streets of mogadishu took place as they
say in a vacuum
and people reacted with the very obvious
responses why is this happening and you
know why are our soldiers there let's
get them out of there what could
possibly be
important enough in somalia for american
soldiers to to be dying
in the case of iraq clearly it's a
totally different situation and whether
you agree
with invading iraq or not
americans certainly understood what was
going on and understood what the stakes
were and what the conditions were like
and um so the fact that american
soldiers are killed in that conflict
comes in a context that either angers us
or
or uh
inspires us or saddens us but
certainly one that we uh can
can comprehend
and of course one of the changes is is
911 we're operating in a post uh
september 11th world
terry you cover the elusive war on
terror
which does not have traditional
battlefronts you can't go
see the war on the ground exactly
you can't go talk to the other side in
the war
you have greater secrecy in the united
states less access to public records or
officials
to talk on the subject
limited or no access to detainees
accused of being connected with al qaeda
um
how do you cover this war
not very well
it's extraordinarily difficult
and it's difficult in a um
often not very interesting way
it's not difficult in the the complexity
of it is so rich and you can really sink
into it
it's just basic facts are
really hard fought
i spent
i'm sure months where i went backwards
and i would lose information information
turned out not to be true
um one of the um
i think this applies to war coverage
generally the war on terror is i mean
almost not a war in some ways but
you have extraordinarily imperfect
information
uh and i think
although in iraq we have a lot more
reporters there a lot more access to the
information images i don't think we have
a broad understanding of what's going on
uh i think in in this is a problem for a
reporter covering anything but wars are
in particular it's it's everything's
messy uh it's hard to get to get a feel
for the whole the overall thing
uh it's just
you get bits and pieces
and you there's the old cliche of you
know a blind man an elephant you don't
know if you're where you are on the
elephant at all uh and you really don't
uh in a war generally i think in
covering terrorism in particular
i mean
for people covering a real war
um you can usually get access to
american through the american side of it
and rarely to the other side in in
terrorism you can't get access to either
side i mean it's just there and
so you have this real positive
information
which skews the information that you do
have
every fact is so unusual to be a fact
that it's elevated in a way that it
might not ought to be
um you'd have an example with 911
just after
the events i think within before the end
of the year
it was revealed that two of the
hijackers had been in malaysia at kuala
lumpur
in the year prior and it
had been a meeting there they were
tailed to this meeting by american
intelligence operatives
i mean
american cia stations around the world
tracked these guys to the meeting
and then they lost them after the
meeting was over and they flew to l.a
they didn't pick that part up but uh the
meeting seemed to take on
real importance but the reason is
because the only meeting we knew about
means as it turns out apparently the
meeting was was of little import at all
i myself spent six months trying to
figure out the meeting you know and it
was just
it was they met there because they
thought it would look better if they
came in the united states from
through thailand
uh it was completely
unimportant in a lot of ways so
in terrorism you're doing that all the
time you don't know you don't even know
if the people are important that you're
trying to find out about uh you end up
doing things that are probably i mean
they're certainly in retrospect really
stupid
it's it's
it's not a job i'd wish on anybody
uh many media critics say that in fact
it's not just the limited or lack of
access it's that we as the media have
been too complacent that in this post
september 11th era that we have been
too accepting of the word of power that
we you know whether it's in the case of
the the lawyer from from oregon or jose
padilla
that we uh we aren't pushing hard enough
and we aren't challenging or questioning
enough is there anything to that i think
generally there is yeah i don't think
that
um i don't think we've stayed with the
stories long enough i think that we've
kind of gone and done them and then come
home
um
i i did nothing since september 11th
except september 11th coverage and there
were periods i would go
months without seeing other reporters
doing anywhere
um you know initially afterward there
was a there were thousands of there were
too many reporters that to allow you to
do your job actually because if a source
would pop up i mean you'd be surrounded
by 30 reporters like a school shooting
but then people went away to a certain
extent i thought they had the story and
they kind of understood it and knew
enough and maybe they did i don't know
but so much of what's reported in the
early going is wrong i mean factually
wrong and so much else is irrelevant
it's like the kuala lumpur meeting
so you end up with people having a very
skewed idea of what actually happens
i don't know about
too respectful of power it's just it's
it's more a measure of the difficulty of
finding information independently
i know i've i have interviewed people
who've never been interviewed by anybody
else who have
seriously good information about this
and they've never been approached by the
reporters nobody could find them
even know their names
then you have the problem of if you're
trying to track somebody down what if
you do find them
i mean
did you really want to um
i mean that that's what happened to
danny pearl yeah
um
he he got in the car with somebody he
didn't know right in a place he didn't
know
and everybody's including me went well
that's really stupid and he was just
that was a mistake he shouldn't have
done that like two months later i was in
crotch i did the same thing
because you get so desperate for
information
that you really
you do things that ordinarily you would
like to think you wouldn't
chris in in gulf war one uh the press
was all but locked out of the war arena
the military corralled reporters and
tried to keep them away from the front
lines and we tried to do this
differently in
in the
three-week iraq war we
the the military tried to do it
differently in that they embedded
reporters
the media tried to do it differently in
that we stayed in baghdad this time and
kurdistan and then we tried to come in
unilaterally behind
uh behind the military
uh i would ask you if that was uh any
more productive in the covering of of
that war
well i look at i covered the persian
gulf war i was not in the pool system um
it was you know one of the unilaterals a
new word we invented for our job
and i think in fact that uh
the first persian gulf war was uh
essentially
the the staging ground or the
uh
we were seeing the beginnings of press
control that were were perfected in this
war
uh remember we had a we had 160 pool
reporters in the persian gulf war who
were essentially hostages of the us
military
they
couldn't go they didn't have their own
vehicles they were dependent on the
military for
transportation for foods for security
and they saw what the military wanted
them to see and they
by and large did not see what the
military did not want them to see
um
i think the pentagon looked very closely
at that experience and this evolved into
the embedding program
where uh instead of 160 we had 600
reporters who were embedded like the
pool reporters in the persian gulf war
again they were completely hostage to
the military and i think that uh in fact
the advances in technology the ability
to transmit live images decreased the
effectiveness
of the reporting in this sense
instead of actually going out and
reporting a story we now got live images
which
were a tiny corner of a battlefield and
reporters assumed the role of sports
commentators where they would be
crouching behind a berm saying and now i
see a half track going across the same
oh look there's an explo and it's it's
it's the same thing football announcers
do
um and i think that it created an
illusion uh that somehow we were getting
more information in fact i think we were
getting less
there virtually were no
independent reporters
in this war unlike in the persian gulf
war where i and a few others broke free
of the pool system
and that's not the fault of the
reporters and the photographers it's
just that it was too dangerous
and let's be very clear that the
reporters in baghdad were under the same
you know as severe constraints i mean
they were controlled by the iraqi
ministry of information so that all of
the images and all of the information
from the war came from the either the
lens provided by the us military or the
lens provided by the iraqi dictatorship
and i think in fact the outside world
had and still has almost no knowledge of
what's going on in iraq if you
uh you know anybody who's been with
armed units especially american armed
units that have access to massive
amounts of firepower the ability to call
in air strikes the ability to call in
heavy artillery knows very well that the
moment they crossed from kuwait they
blasted their way through baghdad and if
there was a mud-walled village three
kilometers away where somebody thought
that they saw somebody with something in
in in a matter of minutes that village
did not exist
and we blew our way into baghdad then
proceeded in baghdad to use incredibly
heavy weapons including tow anti-tank
missiles 50 caliber machine guns etc etc
in urban areas and you know i think one
of the things when marjorie and i
covered the war in el salvador you we
learned very quickly that the best
recruiting weapon the fmln rebels had in
el salvador were the death squads who
were when i got to el salvador in 1983
killing between 800 and 1 000 people a
month and i think what we did in essence
is become a recruiting weapon for the
insurgency remember we don't know but
but best estimates are a hundred
thousand iraqis have been killed and now
the situation is so volatile that we
don't have any voices at all i think we
know almost nothing i think we knew i
think in fact they perfected a system
and and it's why uh vice president
cheney after the war will laud the
embedding system as a big success that
should tip you off right there
that
perhaps
we didn't do our job so let me let me go
beyond the three-week award oust uh
saddam hussein at the end of that war
the international media attempted to do
uh what we tried to do in central
america and the balkans which is to dig
in and to start covering it from the
ground from all sides
that worked for a little while i mean
you actually had reporters going out
looking for insurgents until it became
clear that anybody who looked like a
westerner was a potential target for the
insurgents and so suddenly it became
impossible to cover the war from the
ground so and that was the best the only
moment of real reporting and the la
times did some very good work and i
think so did the new york times where
they actually went into villages you
know the the i think you have to be in a
war zone to understand the awesome power
of this weaponry
and uh i remember a story in the new
york times where uh you know there'd
been a couple flashes from a kalashnikov
or something and they just obliterated
the village and when the reporter went
in i can't remember where there was
burns or someone else they said oh well
we don't we don't really know because
we're still trying to put the body parts
back together
and i think that um there was a brief
window
which you mentioned uh and again that's
not the fault of the reporters and the
photographers it's just too dangerous i
mean now your choice is either you're
embedded
or
uh you're sitting in a press briefing in
the green zone that's basically it if
you can get to the green zone and let's
be very clear about the embedded process
there are very clear rules about that
you know many many iraqis are killed at
checkpoints um we we saw the incident
with the italian intelligence officer
and the the freed italian hostage um but
this is something that's happening to
iraqis every single day and but if
embedded reporters start reporting on
this they're not going to be embedded
very long there are very clear rules
about what you can say and what you can
and i think the lie of war
having spent 20 years of my life
covering war is almost always the lie of
mission
and i think that's the lie that that
were
that we're suffering from now and i
think we understand almost nothing about
what's happening in iraq mark what what
is the stomach for the truth right now i
mean if you think about the images out
of somalia
uh
we don't really have the or the images
out of vietnam the iconic images of
of war do we don't really have those
images now we first of all we can't get
a lot of them uh through embeds
and well let me say first i i want to
defend the embedding program because i
think chris overstates his point um the
embedding i think was a tremendous
success and i would be the first to
agree that there no one has figured out
a way to cover a war
uh as completely as it needs to be
covered uh giving you both the details
on the ground and the overview while
it's happening i doubt that that's ever
going to happen but
there's no question that we got a lot
more
out of the embedded reporting of that
war than the
images that appeared on television
initially during the middle of
firefights where you had reporters
crouched like sports commentators saying
oh look they just fired a horde so
howitzer from over there
um there have been any number of
reporters who've come back and written
extremely good books and and magazine
articles analyzing you know their
experience writing very candidly about
the soldiers they were with uh writing
books that in many cases uh i'm sure the
military is not real thrilled to see in
print uh
some of the reporters and friends of
mine from the la times from the new york
times from
newspapers all over this country have
done extremely good
uh
very independent work even though they
were uh embedded in a military unit and
i think that you know you are going to
continue to see
for a long time
uh
a higher level of sophistication in
writing about this war
coming from people who had the
experience of being on the ground uh
during the fighting so i think that it
uh it is un unquestionably in my mind an
improvement over the way say for
instance the persian gulf war was
covered which is i understand it
consisted of the very few brave people
like chris and my friend michael kelly
who were actually driving around trying
to do their own reporting and the vast
majority of reporters who were being who
were covering the war from a conference
room somewhere and where
in a different country
so uh we i think reporters did get a lot
closer to this war so i'm sorry no i
would agree with that in fact i think
that the embed
provides pieces of a mosaic and there
have been a number of stories like the
one you mentioned that actually
came out of embeds what you know i can
think of bill branigan of the post
during
during the three-week war uh writing a
story about killing civilians at
checkpoints and david's aquino for the
la times writing about whether it was
the finding of the money or the going
into the palaces or any number of things
or actually how how very uh difficult
and bloody it was to take uh baghdad but
uh
but i still wonder if the media in
general has the state the same stomach
it had
for publishing the kind of the
the brutal and uh and uh
death brutality and death of the war
well i think unquestionably it does i
mean it may not be the mainstream media
that publishes it but we live in a world
now with the internet of international
uh television crews i was in europe when
iraq was invaded so most of the uh tv
coverage that i watched was from
european stations and they would show
things uh on tv in europe that they
wouldn't show in the united states and
the truth is that i mean the some of the
images that we've seen from this war are
some of the most horrific that i've ever
seen in my lifetime people being
beheaded and uh uh you know shot down
and it's just it's grotesque if you
choose to look at those images you can
go find them i think that's one of the
features of of modern times so yes i
think that
it's all out there for anybody who wants
to
take it in we don't but the point is
we're waging the war and we don't see it
the rest of the world may see it but we
don't
but but you but you can see it i mean
for instance remember when um uh they
george bush and uh
condoleezza rice wanted to prevent the
networks from broadcasting osama bin
laden's statements on tv and this was
hilarious because i was in michigan
where you know you can get al jazeera
from a satellite hookup and you can
watch uh any of the stuff that you and i
was with an iraqi family who they were
watching al jazeera on tv in detroit i
mean it's the idea that somehow even if
they wanted to control
uh access to information in this country
in this day and age is
you can't do it if you make the effort
on the internet and other places
yes you can go find alternative sources
of information but the mainstream media
in this country prevents presents a very
skewed image of the war and that kind of
self-censorship is something that's
always done in war and it's not
necessarily political it's just done for
what's palatable nobody ever really sees
a war finally i think until they're in a
war
the images that come out are always so
sanitized and and in terms of the
embedding program yes while there were a
few exceptions uh to the rule uh in some
of the cases that you cited i think you
have to look at the overall weight and
also remember that most americans or a
very large percentage of americans get
their information through images
and and the print
journalists have i think less and less
impact uh
in the especially in the age of sort of
live uh
television broadcasts uh and and while
there have been some good books
generation kill and some others that
have come out again and that happens
after every war it comes out after the
war i think we have to look when we talk
about reporting that's what's coming out
during the conflict i would ask then
it's not only that though i mean
we can't talk about covering this war by
talking about the embed process because
that was three weeks no no we're still
well no everybody's still no but but
it's
it's such a small part of what the war
is but not now i mean the only way
people can get out is to embed that's
the only way you can get out in iraq now
we're getting out a little bit more but
i guess i would ask what's the
alternative
uh is it better not to embed or not to
cover the war or do you keep pushing
uh the boundaries by embedding uh by
staying in baghdad and going out when
you can go out i mean reporters in
baghdad uh test the violence like you
know we test the weather you know is it
okay
i understand too that they're not holed
up in baghdad because they are too timid
to step outside the american
uh
you know american military's control of
information it's because it's dangerous
no no it's not the people and
journalists have become targets and yeah
no it's in this case it's not the fault
of the reporters the photographers but
but the you know look i've been with
units in combat and there's a natural
kind of tendency one that i myself have
felt to protect the people who are
protecting you you build a kind of bond
with the unit and if you cover a
conflict of course you need people who
are embedded you can't cover a conflict
otherwise but when
all of your information in essence comes
from embedded reporters what you're
doing is essentially looking at a
conflict through the prism of the
occupiers and not just the occupiers but
the armed professional killers of the
occupiers and that gives such a skewed
vision of what's going on in iraq the
only way to cover a conflict is to have
people who speak arabic who understand
the culture who can which you i i
understand that you can't do it now but
i think we have to be very clear that we
uh are getting an extremely distorted
vision of what's going on i mean when
marjorie and i cover the war in el
salvador we spend you know three days
with the salvadoran army and then we
turn around and go out with the fmln
and and of course our own nation was not
involved in the conflict and this is an
important distinction i think that when
your own country is involved there
become all sorts of pressures on you to
sort of get with the team um but i think
that the the coverage out of a place
like el salvador was much more balanced
because of that because of that kind of
access and we just have to be clear i'm
not blaming it on the reporters and
photographers because we saw in that
window
at the end of
the invasion when people could travel
very good reporting and that window is
closed but we have to be clear that we
don't understand what's going on in iraq
i think that we should open it to
questions because we could go on talking
forever
please
keep your
keep it to questions and not comments if
you would and please keep it short
because i imagine there'll be a lot of
people who want to ask
uh questions
what i'd like to know we
we used to cover the foreign desk of
newspapers used to cover
foreign countries they would have
reporters there living there knowing the
culture chris just mentioned a little
bit about that that you knew the
language you knew the people over there
and and you had your sources and you
knew the government
we don't do that anymore
we we just we do a flyby
and we get the reports and we have one
or two contacts and we come back well i
would say that uh you are actually
conjuring up a idyllic vision of a world
that never existed in journalism uh
there were i think it's true there was a
heyday of newspapers where we probably
had five or six american newspapers who
maintained foreign bureaus around the
world now it's down to what marjorie
maybe three or four
so i mean that and and the networks have
really cut back but i would say by the
same token you know the growth of
international media the access to
international uh publications on the
internet
the access to international television
and radio through satellites has
probably given us all in this day and
age an opportunity to learn more about
any conflict than anybody ever had an
opportunity to in the past i would also
add that i think that is uh
unfortunately uh
the case in iraq for all of the reasons
that we've said but that isn't the case
in the rest of the world i mean we the
los angeles times has about 25
correspondents all over the world most
of them speak the language live in the
country talk to real people in real time
so
iraq is a problem but it's not
representative of how we cover the world
yeah although it is true that the
networks don't do it anymore i mean when
we when we were in central america
every network had a bureau they had
reporters they went out they reported a
story they produced it you know they
liked the bang bang too much it was
three and a half minutes but they were
doing journalism that's gone now when we
were young things were bad that's right
no but but i think that and again i
think it goes back to television and you
know i think if you just look at
people's perceptions in the united
states of the war in iraq you see how
pernicious that corrosion within the
broadcast media has been i think you
still have great newspapers like the la
times and the washington post new york
times yes
but i think in the electronic media
there's been a terrible terrible uh
erosion of of real journalistic
standards and values amen well ms
mcdermott i wanted to thank you for your
excellent article you had about the
motivation for al qaeda when we were
attacked on 9 11 how was the support for
israel and james banford confessed that
in his pretext for war book and was also
addressed on page 147 of the 911
commission report my question is why
aren't we addressing that in all these
intelligence reforms and this war on
terror we're spending billions of
dollars i mean if you remember george
washington's farewell address as
president he said avoid the passionate
attachment for a foreign country and
here we are supporting israel to the
extent that we are and we're being
attacked because of it and again i
learned this from your article my
question is how much longer are we going
to
go on basically playing a shell game of
saying we're going to pay all these
billions of dollars out to fight the war
on terror and go to war in iraq which
has actually increased our terror risk
as we spend 300 billion dollars why
aren't we going to cut to the chase that
the
our terror problem is a result of
supporting israel's depression of the
palestinians let them answer the
question okay well first of all i'm not
capable of answering the question i i'm
not the american government i don't make
those policies
okay just let's let's keep the pieces
here
um
i mean i think that
i mean i hate to say it but he has
something of a point um
in that
the political motivations of
of al qaeda have been
less emphasized than they probably ought
to have been or than we were aware
existed i think
and a lot of the motivation for
bin laden and his people
is political and not religious and we
tended to
demonize them as religious fanatics i
mean they might well have been religious
fanatics but that was not their sole
motivation i mean that this a lot of
things
go on to get somebody in a position
where they're willing to commit suicide
and kill thousands of people
uh and it isn't always just a single
cause
uh and it's true middle east politics uh
play a role in that they motivated the
guy the mastermind of the 911 plot uh
pakistani named college sheikh mohammed
it was motivated principally by admitted
u.s mideast policy he says
uh and there's no reason to doubt that
um
the
one of the lead hijackers mohamed atta
was motivated principally by politics
and not religion
so there's a point um and i and i don't
know where we lost it
uh but we did which isn't to say that
the policy is good or bad i mean what
what i don't know what america's policy
middle east ought to be
and i'm not equipped to answer it and
wouldn't if i was
but but
i mean i would i would not have a job to
go back to tomorrow
but
but it plays a large role
look i mean
i'm not a press basher as you know i'm a
former journalist and uh
the truth is you know i talked to people
all over this country about it and this
pretty much universal agreement that the
coverage of the war in iraq is pretty
terrible
and
i would tend to agree with you chris
that it's not
the reporter's fault but my question is
where is the muscle of the new york
times
in the l.a times why aren't they taking
on the government and saying look you're
not letting us do our job
why isn't there
why isn't the news
media
fighting for uh
for their place the way they did in
vietnam
well i you know i cannot be a spokesman
for the new york times
um
but
i think part of the problem is that
we play by rules
rules where we try and give everyone a
voice where there's an attempt to be
objective
and i think that we're dealing with a
government that doesn't play by rules
and i think that
the
the problem is it's you know it reminds
me of the you know the movie a fish
called wanda and kevin kline and
michael caine are squaring off and
and michael caine has the pistol and
kevin klein says fight like a real man
and michael kane drops the pistol and
says yes i used to box for oxford and
kevin kline picks up the pistol and said
well i used to kill for the cia
i think we're all boxing for oxford
um
i think that's the problem and i think
that you know
um
you know the
the very clear lies that we're told to
justify this war
the way
this administration played the press
like a violin
the fact that there were no dissenting
voices even though that there were large
numbers of people in the intelligence
community in the pentagon among
inspection teams in iraq i covered
i i covered the gulf war and then i was
in the middle east
for the uh inspection teams that
destroyed far more weaponry including
biological and chemical weapons uh than
were ever destroyed by the coalition
forces and i think all you had to do was
pick up jane's uh you know defense
analysis to realize how absolutely
impotent the iraqi military was
but you know there was
i think 9 11 contributed to it um but
yes i think we failed terribly and i
think with it in many ways the press
is been knocked off balance by an
administration
that has very little regard for i think
what we do and certainly no regard for
telling the truth to the american public
let me follow that up with a question i
think the press uh admits uh widely what
it what a lousy job we did in the run-up
to the war in
in pursuing the whole question of
weapons of mass destruction and the
justification for going to war
after the war
uh i think the press was fairly good at
going at this question and and finding
out uh more and and coming to the
conclusion that there were no
weapons
but then it seemed that the public
didn't care
why
well i think you know we have to be
frank that a large
segment of this public was complicitous
in this war
um you know the i
was i had written this book wars of
force that gives us meaning which is
sort of a diatribe against war and what
it does to culture and
individuals and because i had spent
seven years in the middle east in the
build-up to the war the iraqi issue came
up and it incited
very fierce passions very angry passions
i mean even threats on the phone and
this kind of stuff and i think that
there was
i mean if you looked at at broadcast
media especially outlets like fox um it
became a celebration of our own power or
certainly the power of our military the
power of our weaponry um you know they
would always bring in retired military
people that talk about what cruise
missiles could do and for those of us
who had been in conflicts um there was a
kind of very it was almost pornographic
i mean it was very frightening there was
never any uh even discussion about what
was happening on the other end the pools
of blood the cries of the wounded and
the dying
and um you know it it it was a very
perverse view of what war was completely
skewed and again i you know i think that
while the standards were kept in the
serious
newspapers um those standards were were
because of the corrosion of broadcast
media irrelevant and it became
self-exaltation which is essentially
what nationalism is um and and so that
self-exaltation that sense of
empowerment
informed a large part of the public and
i think that
one has to be very uh
clear about that and i think that when
you wonder why i think because it's not
just the administration that's guilty in
some ways we're all guilty
one of you mentioned
the idea that americans don't follow
certain news so then they are not
followed by the media shouldn't the
media really tell us the truth of what
is happening and any of you can tell us
what really happened in fallujah after
the election in iraq
[Applause]
i can say that i've been a journalist my
whole life and i've never done anything
but try to tell the truth in what i
write about and what i learned whether i
know everything that i would like to
know whether it's possible for me to
find out information obviously the
answer is you can't always know
everything you'd like to know but and
i'm not alone i mean i've worked a long
career in newspapers in magazine writing
writing books i have a wide circle of
acquaintanceship in this profession and
it's actually very few people i've run
across
over the course of my career who are
trying to do anything other than learn
and understand and write the truth i
actually think that one of the more
alarming uh trends in american
journalism is the are things like fox tv
the
the tendency of
television networks uh magazines
newspapers to adopt a political slant on
their coverage which is very typical of
journalism in europe and other parts of
the world i think one of the most
valuable things about the american
tradition of journalism has been
maintaining a more even-handed uh
objective standard in reporting
information and i see an erosion of that
certainly as for fallujah i only know
you know what i've read and frankly uh
what i've read in american publications
and seen on tv is that the united states
fairly destroyed fallujah you know 95
was a case of one of the military men
there said it was you know one of the
classic cases that we had to destroy the
village in order to save it uh and you
know so i mean i don't understand in all
honesty
this uh
allegation that we americans are being
deprived of information
about what's going on in this war i saw
a lot of reporting about collateral
damage and and and civilians being
killed in iraq not just in american
publications but all over the world i
didn't see it on fox i'll be the first
to agree that it was obscene you know
the way fox covered this war but
thankfully they're only one of a you
know fairly large number of uh cable
news outlets in this country uh
you know and and so
if
i know that fallujah was destroyed
over the course of uh you know what
happened after that election and i think
most americans know that that's the case
you don't think so
i mean that's
fallujah well let me tell you now
fallujah was destroyed and and it hasn't
been the same sense that it maybe it
will uh come back to life at a certain
point
fallujah is sorry well i was just going
to say that the problem isn't a
conspiracy among journalists i mean
you could cis journalists couldn't
conspire to go to lunch
the problem is that the
the difficulty is daunting uh
to get to know what the truth is is the
problem it's hard work yeah and in any
profession there are people who work
very hard and put themselves at risk in
order to get information and they are a
minority well but the problem is that we
now have an army of pseudo-journalists
who are posing as journalists that's
always been the case i mean it's almost
as though you're positing some point in
the past where there were armies of
perfect journalists that were never
armies of perfect journalists but i i've
you know over the course of my career
watched the erosion in the broadcast
media it's very real i can tell you i
mean
it that's not
you know the the the broad cbs
especially the networks it was very
different 20 years ago it was
they they were much better they were
still reporting they don't do it anymore
in addition to that i would add that
fallujah is an example of what we
described before which is that
uh even if you couldn't get the truth by
accompanying uh american military
we can't just run up there afterwards
and find out what happened because it's
too risky because we as westerners are
perceived as uh or we believe we're
perceived as the enemy so it's not like
we can run up and corner some insurgents
and get the other side of the story well
there is a solution to the erosion of
quality of television journalism and
that is to read newspapers
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it seems like a lot of
like the press seems to be rushing to
the next big story and they're leaving a
lot of big stories behind uh like there
still seems to be so much left over from
9 11 that we still don't know about and
i'm getting worried that you know masari
one of the
the terrorists that
he just admitted his uh to being
complicit
i'm getting worried that he's going to
be put to death no one's going to get a
chance to interview this guy is that a
possibility and also what happened to
the
money that was supposedly profited from
the airlines to put options that was a
story i read about
from the american airlines that there
was supposedly a lot of money that was
uh
made
profited from the
put options on american airlines and
united airlines dropping drastically in
uh in their stocks that was this is a
story that i saw on national news and
then they totally dropped it and i never
heard anything of it couldn't find
anything on the internet about it but it
wasn't true
so
so
yeah uh well it was reported after the
fact but all this these sorts of
questions come from again this notion
that we know a lot more than we're
letting on
and and in fact we maybe know a lot less
than we're letting on
much of the time um
well also i mean what part of the
question was uh
um
uh
why you know the fact that our our media
our press moves from story to story in
it and it and it's always been the case
i mean a
journalism in this country for the most
part is especially nowadays with so many
tv channels it's miles wide and about an
inch deep and i mean i wrote about the
battle of mogadishu which i think was
probably the most significant
uh
combat that a lot of american soldiers
have been involved in in a generation
and
i worked on that story for three or four
years and there wasn't a soul working on
that except me and after black hawk down
came out a lot of people said well how
come we didn't know you know about what
happened there well in fact there was a
lot of reporting about it for about two
weeks and then everybody moved on to
that to the revolution in russia and you
know to the next big breaking story but
i think it's always been the case and
i'm thankful for my own career's sake
that uh
that most journalists don't stay on a
story for three or four years and really
dig into it and try to really understand
it and it isn't just their fault it's
that their news organizations are rare
that uh finance you know that kind of
work who will pay a salary to a reporter
and has benefits so that he can spend
three or four years really digging into
a story and in my experience you need to
spend
that length of time particularly when
you're reporting from a foreign country
where
you you don't understand even some of
the basics about what's going on you
need to put in that kind of investment
in order to begin to understand what
happened
yeah for most foreign correspondents um
not to denigrate these fine people on
the panel you know spending two or three
days on a story is a long time
most of them are covering seven or eight
countries or continent
you know a con we have two people
covering africa i think or you know well
maybe we have three now but
uh and problem solved right
but you know and as marjorie said we
have the only time says 25 people and
that's i mean
there's only three or four or five
papers that have
anything like half that we try to keep
them from going on vacation
hi i'm a usc journalism student and my
goal is to become a war correspondent um
also specializing in human rights abroad
and so all this talk about the new
journalism you know the
bad journalists that are coming into
the profession um i'm a clean slate so
give me advice i just want to know what
was your first experience with
war reporting what have you learned that
you wish you knew then and um you know
what can i do to become what you hope is
a good journalist
[Laughter]
i never wanted to be a work
correspondent you know i get petrified
and can't stand it when i'm in danger
unfortunately wars keep breaking out
everywhere i i think it's not a lofty
goal
um i think that what's a lofty goal is
to be a good foreign correspondent
and uh you know to try to get to the
truth of whatever is going on wherever
you are
and to you know try to explain to
readers in this case to americans
why it is important to understand the
rest of the world and why to engage as
opposed to withdrawing
uh why don't you talk about how you got
well i i never went to journalism school
i went to seminary
and
same thing
[Laughter]
and i went to latin i went to latin
america as a freelance reporter
in the early 80s at the time of the
military dictatorships because i thought
it was as close as my generation was
going to come to fighting fascism
i really didn't have any interest in
building a career in journalism
[Music]
i
wanted to give a voice to
people who are living under the boot of
these dictatorships
my hero was orwell
remains orwell
for his honesty his ability to criticize
all sides of a movement
and i think that
those are
i i don't have a problem with those
motivations
i don't think that precludes you from
telling the truth
um i think that you know it's very hard
to sit in the midst of a war and i cover
the war in bosnia and stand over
you know bodies of people who have been
butchered and not feel anything you
can't ask us not to feel anything
i would agree with marjorie you know
being a war correspondent is a
personality type and probably not a
really healthy one
so
uh
you know and it doesn't really matter
what we tell you if you're bent in that
direction you will go
i can spend an hour giving you reasons
not to go and you'll go anyway that's
was certainly my case
um but i think that that um you know
that too much you know i
i think sometimes and i think this was
the problem with the coverage of the
build-up to the war is that yes we have
to be objective yes we have to be fair
but and i think you know the the editor
of the new york times in a speech i saw
him give also raised a very important
issue that it's not just a matter of
being objective and fair but we have a
contract with the reader or the viewer
and that is to tell the truth
and that objectivity
and neutrality without
that deep passion to tell the truth is
farce
and i think that um a passion
uh to tell the truth
means that you embrace values and that
you you do take a moral stance
it's why when the serbs would cut the
roads into kosovo in villages where they
had killed people we would put our
satellite phones in our backpack and
walk
um and and you know it didn't mean the
serbs weren't going to go in and kill
people in another village um you know
you you have to accept often your
insignificance in the midst of a war or
your minimal significance um but it
becomes a battle of light to shine light
in areas of deep darkness and and i
think that there's nothing wrong
with embracing a moral code and i think
sometimes in this sanitized world of
american journalism we're frightened to
do that
you want to talk about why you do it
well and i want to respond to your
question if you asked for advice and uh
i would say one piece of advice i would
give you is don't pretend to know more
than you know
and to realize how little you know
and realize how much power something new
has
uh a a an image a story uh something
true that people hadn't known before
has tremendous power in the world and
it's amazing how much gets said and
written and reported that doesn't tell
you anything new
so i mean if you want to be a foreign
correspondent and a war reporter it
if you get the opportunity to do that
you know you'll have
a chance to go places that most
americans don't go
you won't know anything
you ought to know that you don't know
anything that's important
and pay attention and ask questions and
try not to make up your mind about what
you're going to discover before you
discover it and tell the truth you know
and always be working on the most
ambitious thing you've ever done that
way you'll continue to grow
[Applause]
why do i do it
i do it for the money myself
well i was i was a roofer and i kept
falling off
[Laughter]
somehow safer
yeah yeah you don't get up don't get up
that high
um you know i do it because i'm
interested in in learning i mean it's
it's a you're being it's a paid tutorial
for your life you run around the world
and learn stuff
uh and it's great joy in that in that
sense and it's a chance to understand
how people work and and to i mean even
i've spent three years studying the 911
hijackers
and
even that has been
great joy in trying to understand
how those guys got there what what kind
of people what kind of world produces
people who do that
and that's been it's uh
heartening for me to be able to go out
and and come back with an image of that
the advice i would give those is much
like march i think be careful what you
believe
uh you have to be able to almost throw
away everything in your head
tomorrow
uh
if it doesn't fit you have to be ready
to be you have to hit your you have to
have a hypothesis you have to have a
theory to walk out the door in the
morning but you have to be willing to
discard it
change it to fit and you fit it to the
facts
i think we have time for one more
question
with regards to covering the war and the
kind of the new technology and video
cameras with that soldiers have access
to i've seen a lot of home videos and
whatnot and i was curious
what insights you might guys might have
and towards how that line can blur for
the soldier as a as a journalist and
or any kind of anecdotes
through experience or whatnot
well it makes it a lot harder to cover
things up uh because some of the most
significant stories that have emerged
from iraq have come from soldiers who
took pictures and who put them on the
internet
and i think that's going to be
increasingly the case
not just because individuals have the
capability now with the internet of
broadcasting and posting information but
because the as i keep saying the growth
of international media i mean you know
we are so used to in this country the
united states entertainment industry and
news industry dominating information in
the world and we are fast approaching
the end of that era we are entering an
era where you know the
international sources of information are
going to be commonplace they already are
to an extent and you know our our view
of the world will just become one voice
among many
so
okay thank you very much i appreciate
you coming
i think so
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a discussion now about the myths and
costs of war we'll hear from new york
times reporter and author chris hedges
about his experiences in war zones the
close-up foundation hosts this hour-long
event
hello and welcome to the museum in
arlington virginia for this week's close
up at the new zealand discussion of war
we're going to be talking with a war
correspondent who's written a few
fascinating books on the subject of war
and about the mythology surrounding the
concept
also joining us today are students from
mclean high school and also students or
i should not say students but young
professionals who are part of the
leadership training program at the
center for strategic and international
studies and we'll meet some of them and
hear their questions and comments in
just a moment first let me introduce you
to our guest joining us is chris hedges
chris is a veteran war correspondent who
was a member of the reporting team at
the new york times in 2001 that was
awarded the pulitzer prize for their
coverage of global terrorism he's also
written for the christian science
monitor and the dallas morning news and
has reported for national public radio
he's the author of several books
including what every person should know
about war and war is a force that gives
us meaning here are those two books
also his most recent book is titled
losing moses on the freeway which is
about the ten commandments
good morning and welcome to the
discussion thanks
let me let me ask you uh first about
your your journalistic history how did
you become a war correspondent how did
you get into that line of work
uh
through a very circuitous route i uh i
never studied journalism i went to
harvard divinity school graduated with a
master of divinity um came out of a
family my father was a presbyterian
minister but very uh involved in social
activism
and i had a hard time growing up in the
church reconciling the quote-unquote
objective nature of journalism with
the social activism that was very much a
part of my family and my upbringing
and i became very drawn to latin america
at the in the early 1980s when uh
military governments uh uh were carrying
out terrible repression against their
own citizens pinochet in chile the dirty
war in argentina where thirty thousand
of its own
citizens were disappeared by the
military junta um
and went off to latin america to be a
freelance reporter actually went off and
covered the war in el salvador when i
graduated from seminary
and certainly not because i wanted to
write on behalf of any side or any
ideology
but because the repression itself was so
severe and the
uh um
issues of social justice issues were so
pronounced that it was something i
wanted to cover and you mentioned your
dad was a presbyterian minister
additionally he's a world war ii veteran
yes and uh what kind of impact i mean
what's your earliest memory of thinking
about your father's role in that war and
then
i think i remember that he was a
protester against the vietnam war that's
correct
um my dad was in north africa
in the middle east landed a casablanca
um
uh
really hated war and hated the military
and uh and before he went into service
no i you know i think like most
idealistic young
men at the time and
i think that's true with any generation
really had no idea of what war was
um
but it was you know the the influence of
world war ii
was greater than just my father's
experience because
uh on both sides of the family all of my
uncles with the exception of one fought
in the war
and uh one uh was in the south pacific
he was actually in the army before the
war started so was in the south pacific
from 1939 to 1944
where he was
finally badly wounded and came back and
he never recovered from the war uh he
emotionally and physically um you know
of course in those days the word
post-traumatic stress disorder didn't
exist it wasn't even coined until 1974
but he um had terrible problems with
alcoholism he couldn't hold his marriage
together he couldn't hold down a job and
this was a small town in maine where he
um you know would work for one of my
uncles in the lumber mill to you know
get money as soon as he got his check
disappear for two or three days and
he was a real burden uh to the family uh
especially growing up in a mance where
there was no alcohol
and
i think that you know looking back on it
there were probably
tens of thousands of american families
who were caring for
shattered wrecks of veterans like that
but it was not spoken about publicly and
uh these people were essentially blamed
for their own trauma and shun it aside
so the war was a pervasive presence in
my life and um
uh
none of my uncles or my father were
pacifists
but they
um
they did everything they could to
deflate the myth of war uh the idea that
it was about glory and honor and and all
those abstract terms that in the moment
of combat become hollow if not obscene
so this is a notion that's been with you
for quite some time
yes
in the abstract it's one thing to hear
that
it's another thing to
walk into a firefight in el salvador and
experience it
you know in recent years we've seen
things like uh the greatest generation
tom brokaw's book the unveiling of the
world war ii memorial a couple weeks ago
here we had a couple of world war ii
correspondents at essertiere and jack
pullers and we and we had an audience
that was at least half world war ii
veterans and you would almost think it
was a good time it is that sort of uh
comradeship that you write about and
heroic memories and telling tales of
glory
it's almost the modern version of the
classics of antiquity talking about the
heroic ideal well you know we every
generation
mythologizes the war that went before
you know all those kids who went off to
world war ii
uh
had held up before them the myth of
world war one
and uh of course before that it was the
myth of the civil war the
the
uh you know wars are venal dirty
horrible
business especially in the 20th century
where we have created essentially a
mechanism of industrial slaughter where
you know thousands of
enemy combatants can die
without even seeing the people who are
attacking them um so this is an achilles
with a sword this is achilles 30 000
feet above
exactly pushing although of course you
know if you go back and read the iliad
uh
homer was very aware of this process and
there's a speech in the iliad by nestor
where he talks about you know the age of
heroes the age of the giants i mean
there has always been that and and and
it is a myth because uh world war ii uh
was
uh as brutal and horrific and horrifying
as any war
um
again let me reiterate that i'm
especially having lived in sarajevo
during the siege i'm not a pacifist but
but war is is always tragic um and
uh i think in many ways those people who
have an interest in perpetuating war uh
have an interest in maintaining the myth
but the myth itself is also what people
like it
you see it it's pervasive within the
entertainment industry and television
with movies um it's very hard for
reporters to report outside of the myth
by that i mean to report on just
the the brutal consequences of war
itself um you know there is always an
attempt to search for the hometown hero
i mean this is how we end up with the
fabricated story about jessica lynch or
pat tillman
and it's not just the war makers who
spin out those myths for public
consumption but the press that seizes
upon it because those myths
sell newspapers it's how william
randolph first of course built his
empire and they boost ratings um and
that has been true i think since the
creation of the modern war correspondent
in the crimean war when we got the
telegraph and in relatively real time
could
uh get accounts of battle doesn't that
need go beyond the the policy makers and
the press though because nobody rejects
these stories are cynical about them
they go down pretty easy it sounds like
people need that as well well people
yearn for them i mean you know it gives
wartime creates its own culture one that
uh is very destructive to real culture
and certainly to
uh honest intellectual uh and
journalistic
criticism and self-criticism and there's
that great quote by senator hiram
johnson in
1917 that you know when the first uh
casualty in war is truth
um
it's very hard with the contagion of the
crowd with that mingling of fear with
the excitement of war i mean i think if
you look for instance at the build-up to
this war at what constituted the
coverage of the war it most often
comprised
interviews with retired
officers who talked about the power of
our weapons systems and of course by
extension our own power so there is a
complicity on the part of uh the public
at large
that feels ennobled and empowered by
this myth of patriotism or let's call it
blind patriotism or nationalism is at
its core about self-exaltation
and of course with that the denigration
of the other it's why for me you know
rampant nationalism is a disease
one that always embodies an element of
racism
not only racism towards iraqis or
towards
i think in many ways the rhetoric about
muslims is in this country has tinges of
racism but even about those who share
our values and our concerns
but disagree with us and we saw this
most evidently and displayed in our
reaction to the criticism from the
french
where the kinds of things that were said
about the french uh
uh were were really you know i think
racist i mean they we denigrated their
culture we denigrated their identity
their contributions to world war ii
exactly and uh and and that is is that
that's why nationalism when it sweeps
through a country and and and i'm not
singling out america i've watched this
happen in you know six or seven or eight
nations that i've covered at war
you know
reduces the level of debate to sort of a
chant and makes any kind of uh honest
critique or self-criticism
uh
dangerous often physically dangerous
you've used the term myth differently
joseph campbell when he wrote and spoke
about mythology or myths would talk
about stories that reveal greater truths
maybe even greater than the facts it
seems as if you're using myth as a lie
yes and i've been taken to task for that
um
but i think that there is a mythology
about war
that does not reveal a greater truth um
there that that i think seals a greater
truth yes but you know but that
mythology is is pervasive uh with within
most societies the notion that somehow
going to war
uh
uh will test your manhood make a man of
you
you know i i read a study actually by
military psychiatrists who said that
soldiers who go into combat soldiers or
marines who go into combat
oftentimes walk away with the trauma
equivalent to someone who was in a car
crash where their best friend was killed
that level of trauma
is something
that is uh that mars you that
emotionally scars you and that you carry
with you for the rest of your life it is
not a matter of manhood are these war
myths essentially i i suppose what i'm
hearing you describe is that at their
best they are a survival mechanism they
allow people to live through this trauma
and continue to function at their worst
they become an enabling device to do
horrific things to other human beings
you know i think that many of the combat
veterans who are honest
[Music]
come back and are often very alienated
within the society because of course
they know reality of war it takes about
30 seconds of combat to realize that all
of those myths are untrue
it's why
wounded marines in world war ii jeered
john wayne when he visited them in a
hospital and that creates a kind of
distance and you know i go back to my
own family that you know when the
you know my father never walked in the
in the veterans parade and the fourth of
july not because he wasn't proud of his
service but because he didn't like that
uh the continuation of that kind of
culture which interestingly enough
especially with the vfw hall in my small
town revolved around drinking and he was
supposed to drink
and many of them drank too much
and i think that that there are many
many veterans who come back and
um
and don't buy into that myth but we
don't hear from them they're not the
people we trot out at the 4th of july
because they don't read from the script
so
i i think that oftentimes combat
veterans are very split and those that i
think sees most ardently
upon this myth
either had a very peripheral role in the
enterprise this is coming from my dad
or oftentimes are so troubled and
disturbed by what they saw and perhaps
what they did that it's either easier to
cloak themselves
in the flag and and patriotism and not
deal with their own demons
tell us the list of conflicts that you
covered firsthand
well i was uh in central america for
five years so i did the war in el
salvador guatemala nicaragua
then i took a sabbatical and studied
arabic went off to the middle east
covered the civil war in the sudan
algeria
the persian gulf war where i was with
the first battalion first marines went
into kuwait
uh was eventually
in the upper shiite uprising in basra
after the war where i was captured and
taken prisoner
by the iraqi republican guard
covered the
civil war in yemen
uh and uh and then went in 1995 to
sarajevo
to cover the war in bosnian later kosovo
and uh when you've written about this
and talked about this you you almost
described it as drug addiction
oh yeah war was your drug
how did you uh get off the drug well let
me let me first
you know i mean yeah and talk about this
sure please
i mean i went off to
central america as an idealist i you
know my great
sort of model and to this day room you
know remains a
writer i deeply respect is george orwell
i
you know i wanted to give a voice to
the victims whether those victims were
being
bearing the brunt of repression by the
military government in el salvador or
the sandinista government in nicaragua i
was not there to pick sides um and i
think the great that was the great
benefit of having spent so many years
studying christian ethics i was just
distrustful of all power groups and all
institutions
um
um
but once i got caught up in the milieu
of war i mean war is is is you know when
you're in combat it's it's
very frightening but it's also
uh
a very high octane existence about the
rush the rush the adrenaline rush
amusement parks yeah it's well it is
it's it's probably the biggest rush
you're going to get
mingled with some of the worst fear
you're ever going to feel
and
uh you know it is as kind of zen-like
experience where even colors are
brighter you are aware or present in
ways that you never were before and if
you can control your fear you go back to
seek it out again and again and again
and it is like a moth
circling the flame
and and and the longer you spend in a
war or covering or living in that
culture the harder it is to adjust
because you go back to a society at
peace
and not only can no one around you
grasp or understand the experiences that
you've undergone the trauma you've
undergone
but you can't find those rushes anymore
so that you will see as certainly with
war correspondence this
frightening pattern which is of course
ended in the death of several of my
colleagues where they will leave it
elizabeth neufer from the boston globe
my friend kurt shork
and miguel gail moreno were both killed
in sierra leone elizabeth died in iraq
michael kelly died in iraq
they pull away from it
but
you know nothing in the peacetime life
ever replicates that um but like any
addiction it ultimately is
self-destructive
emotionally
spiritually and finally physically and i
how did you well i too pulled back after
the war of kosovo i have children and
and um
and and uh the second intifada i'm an
arabic speaker the second intifada began
uh in the up palestinian uprising
against the israeli occupation i and i
was sent by the new york times back to
gaza and i went willingly and i got
caught on a very bad ambush at the
netserim junction where a young
palestinian teenager was shot through
the chest and killed about 10 feet away
from me
and
i realized then that you know
that i had to get out
that if i didn't stop um it was just a
matter of time before i was probably
next
or certainly the the odds were pretty
good that my left luck wasn't going to
hold out how what's been the the impact
on you personally is this the type of
thing that keeps you up at night yes of
course i mean you can't be around that
kind of
um
you know raw physical violence
uh and and not feel the trauma of it
some people claim that they can
compartmentalize it or do whatever it is
that they have to do to keep it in a
different place
not when you go to sleep
nobody has control over their
subconscious when they're asleep
and and and i have never met a veteran
who sleeps well
uh because
you know you what happens is
you
you know your your subconscious goes
places that you don't want it to go and
so you wake up with a start often and
these are very debilitating nights um
it's very hard you sort of you know
getting up and getting dressed and
shaving and just going through the
motions of the rest of the day are
difficult
uh
and and that's why i have
you know the people i have the most
affinity with are usually vietnam
veterans i mean we don't i don't have to
say much to them they get it do you
still yearn for that rush no
scares me now
let me uh we'll take your questions in a
second i want to ask you one final uh
question to comment on upfront uh the
role of the press in your writings you
describe the press as always part of the
problem yes
i mean if you go back and look um
at the role of the press at the
inception
of
any conflict at the national press let's
say of the press of the country going to
war
that
mingling of fear
fear of what can happen to us as a
country in a society coupled with
the cant of patriotism especially in the
age of the electronic media where you're
having it you know pounded uh into your
living rooms with 24-hour news cycles is
such that it makes it almost impossible
to go against the grain
within the entire society and the press
of course
is no exception i think that at the
beginning of a conflict
the press feels that its role ultimately
is to sustain civilian and army morale
and what we get is not reporting but
shameless cheerleading and if we look
back at the coverage in the lead-up to
the war in iraq when there were serious
questions that should have been asked
about
uh you know saddam hussein possessing
weapons of mass destruction or trying to
build a nuclear
device or having links with al qaeda i
mean when when the country desperately
needed real reporting we didn't get it
we got propaganda when most people look
back and analyze what happened in
vietnam
they point to the press abandoning the
war there's the famous uh moment when
lbj says we've lost cronkite yes
where are we now are there parallels
there are parallels i think that the
most important thing to remember about
the press is that it is
uh the the the main body of the press is
a reactive force uh there are very few
people in the press
who will strike out on their own i mean
thank god there are a few i f stone
being the great example but we have them
today i mean
uh
walter pincus at the washington post or
seymour hirsch at the new yorker i mean
they're there not in large numbers um
and when you know so you're also
describing elderly gentlemen where are
where's the new guard of journalists who
are willing to
step out um
well you know some of the some of the
journalists in the washington bureau of
knight ritter for instance um i mean
there was some real reporting um but
their voices were pretty much drowned
out by
uh this uh
uh by the kind of lockstep uh of
of uh
disinformation that was disseminated by
the mainstream press including the new
york times who at the time i was working
for
um
but i think when public opinion changes
when the war
moves from a mythic narrative to a
sensory narrative and by that i mean
when we're able to actually just go in
and report that there was a car bombing
without trying to
stick it within a mythic
storyline
then the press
is free to report and i think that you
know that's an important thing to
remember in the vietnam war that during
the war in vietnam if you go back and
look at the beginning of the war you
know the gulf of tonkin resolution which
again we now know was fabricated as an
excuse to get americans involved in the
war um or the incident that led to the
gulf of tonkin resolution was fabricated
the press will go along until the public
begins to ask the right questions and
when the public begins to ask the right
questions the press is freed to ask the
right questions and i think that is the
moment we're seeing now we
uh have gone through a period where the
the press
failed us
where it did not report
uh but as
the public is beginning to question the
enterprise
the press is free to question the
enterprise
hi go ahead please
hi my name is joshua gross and i am with
the center for strategic and
international studies in dc
and i was an english major literature
major when i was in college and
in moments of self reflexivity
my friends and i would sort of ask
ourselves is literature necessary and in
your book you speak about uh this sort
of redempt redemptive quality that
literature had for you personally
as you came back from some of these war
zones and were recuperating
so my question for you
mr hedges is
can literature have a transformative
power on a mass scale
and
do you have any particular works of
literature books old or new that you
think
would be beneficial to certain
conflict regions say the middle east or
the balkans if they were widely
translated and disseminated
well you're very astute i think to point
that out
because
literature for me um kept me sane
and
it kept me in touch with our common
humanity
uh great writers
shakespeare marcel proust
dostoevsky tolstoy
understand human nature including
the darkness or the capacity for evil
even atrocity that all of us carry
within ourselves
and
i think that it's only through that kind
of understanding
about ourselves
primo levy the great italian and
holocaust survivor writes about this
quite eloquently it's only by grappling
with those demons within us that we can
fully realize our own humanity as long
as we believe that all of those demons
are outside of us are external and can
be destroyed which is why i think
utopianists are so dangerous
we
we become a danger to ourselves and a
danger to others and one of the things
that disturbs me i teach at princeton
or we'll be teaching in the spring among
many of the great research universities
is the kind of withering of the
humanities
they're not economically profitable
being an english major
you know is not probably going to get
you a consulting job when you graduate
for a hundred thousand dollars a year or
whatever how much ever the financial
service sector pays these days when you
graduate um but it is deeply important
for allowing you to reflect on how to
live a life with meaning
and how to live a life where
you protect and foster
our common humanity in wartime you know
it's always interesting in wartime
societies because the first thing those
who want to perpetuate a war do is
destroy their own culture before they go
on to destroy the culture of the other
they replace that culture with
second-tier second-rate artists who are
willing to infuse the ideology of
patriotism and the glorification of the
nation into their
quote-unquote works of art
you know patriotic songs um
you know
uh
any any kind of uh um
play or theatrical production or movie
that glorifies the nation and this is an
art this is propaganda and and i think
that one sees that that art and and
great writing uh and not exclusively
great writing but artistic expression
which is really at its at its most uh
brilliant form a form of social and
individual self-criticism is very
salutory for the health of a community
in a nation so that um you know
the the the worst of the totalitarian
societies of the 20th century had of
course deep anti-intellectual strains
fascism and communism
if you look at the islamic
fundamentalist movements in the middle
east even i think the religious right in
the united states there is a a kind of
war against
honest intellectual inquiry and
and uh so
the the literature for me is is is more
than just a pastime it also allowed me
to come back i can remember coming back
from uh you know a particularly bad day
in el salvador and sitting down and
rereading macbeth and there's a scene
where they come to kill
[Music]
mcduff's children and the mother
said but i've done no harm and then uh
and then goes on to say but you know
then i realize i live in a world where
uh to to do no harm can be accounted
dangerous
folly and to do evil you know is
rewarded uh
that that line it and it's not a it's a
paraphrase um just struck me so
powerfully and it gives you through the
ages a kind of connection a kind of
continuity and a kind of comfort um that
there are people who who understand so
um and i think that if we don't go back
and look at the great works
uh that preceded us i think for instance
the iliad is probably the greatest work
on war that i've ever read i think the
odyssey is one of the greatest works i
have ever read on the recovery of war
if we don't go back and learn
from those who went before us
we end up leading lives of terrible
provincialism and narrowness
thank you thanks hi hi my name is helen
lee i go to mclean high school and you
said before that people get obsessed
they become
they
almost need the myth of war
and so what do you think that it will be
beneficial to the popularity of a strong
government to fight in the war every few
generations or so
that's a good question you know
we know that that there is a kind of
rallying around the flag and a rallying
around the government in a time of
crisis in a time of war we saw this for
instance with the
attacks of 911 where the the bush
administration the the poll numbers were
dropping the administration was somewhat
adrift and that catastrophic event uh
rallied the nation around the government
at its inception this is what always
happens at war
and um
you know
i don't want to impugn the motives of
those who let us into this war but there
are critics who believe
uh that um
especially with the elections that were
coming up uh before the war that that
this was a way to pull the country
behind the president and this does
happen in wartime and it's one of the
reasons that uh those of us who write
about war and i think of course the
press as well
must
uh work very hard to ex to shatter the
myth of war and explain the reality of
war because if we do believe that war is
glorious and noble and essentially cost
free that somehow we can walk in and
fight a war without large numbers of
dead then uh it becomes that you know
that war is a form of entertainment and
we saw this in the coverage of of the
first persian gulf war where reporters
were virtually never anywhere near the
fighting um and all we saw were sort of
neatly packaged video clips by the war
makers if we don't understand how venal
and
and destructive war is it becomes of
course much easier to wade into a war
and potentially a quagmire that we
shouldn't be in war should always be
done
with great great reluctance and of
course always as a last resort
thanks hi i want to remind you you're
watching close up at the newseum i'm
john malewski this week we're discussing
war with author and journalist chris
hedges this is one of mr hedges books
war is a force that gives us meaning and
it talks about the myths of war we're
discussing this with students from
mclean high school in virginia and also
young professionals from csis and i want
to let you know if you'd like any more
information on close-up or any of its
programs or our partners here at the
museum please visit our website it's
www.closeup.org and newseum.org
now we'll return to our discussion with
a question from this young lady at the
microphone hi my name's sarah fury i'm
with the center for strategic
international studies and my question is
considering how much work you're talking
about goes into putting to getting
soldiers and civilians to buy into the
myth of war what institutions or
elements are necessary to get them out
of the myth of war and to function again
in a society or sleep well at night who
do you look to when you're looking for
information on anything in this case war
where do you look to to garner the truth
um i mean i make sure i read multiple
sources i look at the bbc i look at the
washington post and and magazines and i
read your book as well so i try to
incorporate theory into as much news as
i can get my hands on okay
well it's very hard um
especially in the build up to a war
to find
good sources of information within your
own country it's very difficult
um
within the press
you'd be very hard
you know there were there were almost no
voices of uh
reporters anyway who were doing real
reporting
i think you know turning to
ideological outlets that always oppose
war is probably no better
in the sense that it's information not
rhetoric that you must seek
um
i think that that that probably the best
is to know those kinds of writers who
have a fierce streak of independence i
hersh comes to mind
and who are not going to get bamboozled
and swallowed up by this
and just
very closely monitor what it is they're
doing
but it's very hard it you know we used
to when i covered the war in bosnia
where everybody seemed to have gone
collectively insane whether they were
croats serb or muslim make much
difference um
you know
the joke was we'd all thought we'd found
sort of the one
normal rational
person in an interview but we but after
20 min we used to call the linda blair
effect but of course after 20 minutes
their head would begin to spin around
and all this garbage would spew out of
their mouth uh it's it's it's very very
difficult and that was a lesson i first
learned when i covered the war in
argentina for national public radio out
of buenos aires where before they
invaded the falkland islands uh the
junta the military junto which as i said
earlier it disappeared thirty thousand
of its own citizens was about to fall
the economy was in shambles there were
the whole center of buenos aires a
couple weeks before the invasion had
been shut down because of protests
but the moment they invaded the island
the the country went collectively insane
and they were literally pulling
labor union and opposition leaders out
of prison cells with the marks of the
beatings on their faces and they would
get up in front of the cameras and go
last malvino san argentinas the the
malvinas which is the term for the
falklands in spanish
belonged to argentina or argentine uh
and that was a tremendous lesson for me
that there were you know to even uh
criticize especially as a foreigner even
in any way the junta uh which
was reviled before the war was to court
physical violence
and those few lone voices in argentine
society who spoke out
and they were very few were
attacked as unpatriotic and
uh
and with great anger great vehemence and
that was a tremendous lesson for me that
is what that is what happens in a
wartime society argentina is no
exception it happened within our own
society uh it happens in every society
and and if you're aware of that uh it
helps tremendously when
this kind of collective madness
nationalist madness grips a society it
helps to keep you focused and with your
feet on the ground
let me uh let me ask you a question and
a raise hands do a little quick poll and
the choice is up front i'm going to ask
you where you get most of your news and
the choices are television radio print
internet okay those are the four choices
where how many people get most of their
news from television raise your hand if
that describes where you get most of you
and let's take a look
okay
how would say radio
i think one lone hand back there
uh how about a print source
and then the internet which i i think is
hard to quantify because you're reading
off the screen or watching streaming
video it's a little both
okay so what we saw here was probably
you would be elite by national standards
and in polls taken time after time it
shows that the majority of americans get
most of their news from television and
in following up on your question it
leads to this question about it is this
nation if you look at the 24 7 news
cycle
uh and we call calling it news as being
generous in most cases
uh
is this nation capable of having the
level of sophisticated discourse about
issues of war and peace if most people
are getting their information from
television
television isn't the problem i mean for
instance this is being televised
but as a problem to a commercial the
problem is commercial television
where
the pressures
on ratings
are so extreme
that news is judged not for its
importance as an item of news
but it's judged on its uh capacity to
entertain
and uh there you know
to exchange ideas which is what we're
doing today
is
requires a lot of concentration
and a lot of effort
to listen to two blowhards scream at
each other and insult each other which
is what passes for
discussion on many of these commercial
programs
is
quick easy entertaining funny and
mindless and that is what has
destroyed
television news you know when i began
uh in this business now
you know 20 plus years ago
all of the networks had foreign bureaus
when i covered the war in salvador every
major network had a bureau including cnn
which was a fledgling network the
reporters by and large spoke spanish
they got up in the morning
they would go out they would uh report a
story they would produce it
and they would put it on the air
you know it may have been too short
three minutes four minutes five minutes
it may have been a little too obsessed
with what we call the bang bang but it
was still reporting it was still
journalism that's gone it's vanished
those bureaus do not physically exist
anymore
those reporters by and large are no
longer employed by these networks and uh
you know the the people we uh look
at these very highly paid news anchors
uh who uh
appropriate that appropriate the title
of journalist have never reported a
story at all they interview famous
people or they interview important
people or they interview celebrities
but i i really the reporting skills are
almost zero uh and that has been a
tremendous and disturbing change so that
i think on most of the cable news
networks and most of the commercial
television stations
they no longer do news at all
it's talking heads
it's cute
it focuses on stories that you know
have the kind of lowest common
denominator something that will
you know the the sort of news equivalent
of roadkill something that will stop and
turn your head
uh you know i we saw this with the cover
and coverage of by the embedded
reporters in the in this current war in
iraq where they didn't actually report i
mean you know if you look if you analyze
what they did they they traveled with
military units uh who they were
completely dependent on for logistics
they saw what those units wanted them to
see they went where those units
wanted them to go they they knew very
well that their personal security and
fate was tied to the well-being of that
unit um and there is a a natural
tendency to protect the people who are
protecting you that's something i myself
have felt i would not immune from it but
but it's not reporting especially when
you get into a situation and and we all
saw this on the television where they
would be broadcasting in real time you
know an explosion and there goes a
humvee and i can see a bradley and and
they act as sports commentators they are
describing to you
what it is you're looking at on the
screen
but in fact there's no content
you i think we know less about this war
and no context
exactly it it is it is a verbal
description
of what you the viewer are seeing in the
same way sounded like john madden doing
work exactly that's what it was and
that's not
journalism hi go ahead please my name is
liana lim i'm with the center for
strategic international studies and my
question is that implicitly in your the
title of your book
tell me if you disagree with this that
regardless of the consequences we know
that war is deadly and brutal but
regardless of the consequences it seems
that war is still a weapon of choice by
a lot of policy maker and do you think
even by the uh population in general do
you think at the core of it war is
the spirituality of war reflects our own
search for significance and our own
insecurity and that's why war can never
be abandoned in the long term
well that's a question i've struggled
with for many years and it's a really
important one
in um
in sigmund freud's book
civilization and discontents
he writes that the two most powerful
forces in the individual in the communal
life
are
what he calls the force of eros or love
that impulse to protect conserve and
preserve life
and then what he calls the impulse
of thanatos or the death instinct that
instinct to annihilate all living things
including ourselves
freud wrote this
on
the e in the 1930s before
world war ii again but certainly
you know as a great
psychoanalyst capturing the mood of
europe at the time
and for freud these two forces were in
eternal conflict
both within the individual and society
and one was always ascendant
so that i think that if we look at
at our own country
after our defeat
in vietnam
we became a better nation
we asked questions about ourselves we
hadn't asked before we were forced to
see ourselves as others saw us and the
site was not always
an attractive one we were forced to
confront our own capacity
for atrocity
and for evil
and for this we not only understood more
about
war but we stood understood more about
ourselves
but the war makers the myth makers
worked very hard over the succeeding
years to revive the myth of war
which culminated we went through grenada
panama culminated in the persian gulf
war and in freudian terms
that moment
at the end of the vietnam war
for us as a nation was a moment of eros
and i think that in freudian terms the
moment when we
we embraced war which at of course at
its core remember war is about death it
is about
the
uh
physical
destruction of the other that's what the
enterprise of war is about
uh
and uh
i think these forces i think freud's
right i think these forces are in
eternal conflict and i think
for that reason like freud i'm i'm very
pessimistic about eradicating the
enterprise award is the type of
introspection that you describe national
introspection soul searching is that
politically viable in any way i think of
jimmy carter's famous
great malaise speech and that made him a
republican punchline right for decades
afterwards and the reaction to that was
mourning in america and ronald reagan
right
that's you know
and of course jimmy carter was right
um uh you know i've always felt that uh
he's probably one of the great
underappreciated presidents you probably
have a hard time finding a member of
congress or the administration who would
agree with that
well they know what sells and uh you
know never remember that or never forget
that
just as the advertising industry
uses very sophisticated marketing
techniques to
get us to buy items or try and achieve
positions which we believe will give us
more fulfilling and meaningful lives and
lives of happiness so now politics uses
very much those same techniques
those
that those forms of mass manipulation
to get us to support them
and if you look at political debate it
is about
how we feel or how we are made to feel
about candidates not about what they say
or what they think
so
you know i guess the the moral of the
story is that um honesty doesn't always
pay uh i i like to believe i guess as a
seminarian that in the long run it does
pay uh but clearly in the short run it
often doesn't
hi hi drew briscoe from mclean high
school
knowing everything that you know and
seeing everything that you've seen what
is your personal opinion about the war
in iraq do you think it's justified and
necessary you know with all the violence
that you're aware of
well i was um
i was always opposed to this war
uh and and and and let me say that i was
not
opposed to the first persian gulf war um
having spent seven years of my life in
the middle east
uh and a lot of time in iraq i did not
believe that in the first persian gulf
war
uh un resolutions were going to get
saddam hussein to leave kuwait
and there's all those
all that speculation that
if the iraqi forces had been
given a free hand they may well have
taken the oil fields in northern saudi
arabia and i certainly believe that
at least in my understanding of the
iraqi regime that is not far-fetched
this war was different
first of all
having lived through the persian gulf
war in 1991 and then having remained in
the middle east to cover the work of the
inspection teams
the u.n inspection teams and knowing the
stockpiles of weapons that they had
destroyed
knowing
what a shadow
of the iraqi military was compared to
what it had been before 1991. i had a
very hard time believing that iraq was a
threat
to its neighbors much less to us
i knew that the baptist
the baptist regime under saddam hussein
hated the islamic fundamentalists i mean
i i had covered uh you know they were
ruthless towards islamic movements
within their own country
uh
and
i never thought the war was necessary
and because um you know i'm i'm so
reluctant in terms because because i
know the cost on the ground of violence
um
i was very outspoken against the war
this i did at some personal cost because
uh the mood of the country was such that
many people didn't want to hear it uh i
i gave a commencement speech shortly
after
president bush landed on the aircraft
carrier and talked about mission
accomplished where i had rockford
college in illinois where i was booed
off the stage my microphone was cut
people actually tried to climb up on the
stage to push me off i was taken out in
the middle of the ceremony by
campus security
uh and then there's a memorable
commencement interest and yeah at least
they won't forget it
and and then of course the the trash
talk radio rush limbaugh and these
people had a feeding frenzy uh and and
the the paper the new york times my
employer um issued me a letter of
reprimand that coming out of the
newsroom i was i was formally told that
i was not allowed to or i would i had
impugned the impartiality of the new
york times um
that was a difficult moment for me
you know i'd spent 15 years with the new
york times it's a great newspaper
um
but
you know i really had to go back you
know into my own experiences growing up
in a mans with a very outspoken father
who spoke against the war and
was active in the civil rights movement
and worked in the gay rights movement in
the later part of his life
to understand that
you know i could pay fealty to that
institution in my career but to do so
would essentially to be muzzled on an
issue uh that i felt strongly about and
that i had a great deal of knowledge
about
and i remember after being called into
the office in new york and being
formally given the reprimand and the
physical written reprimand being put in
my file and told that i had to be quiet
which i had no intention of doing um
i walked out and i realized that that
the gift that my father had given me was
freedom
and
and that's the greatest gift you can
have because
any institution even well-meaning
uh institutions
will try and own you and they will try
and own your conscience
uh and um
and that for me is just not a life worth
living so was it that we didn't go to
war for the right reasons or
was it that war is just so awful that no
war is justified i
i think we didn't go to war for the
right reasons i mean i lived in sarajevo
during the siege
and
i fully understood why a resident of
that city surrounded by serb forces that
were dropping upward upwards of two
thousand shells a day on them i
understood why they would go out and
literally man trenches to try and keep
the serbs back
that did not save the residents of
sarajevo from the pernicious
effects of war in that you know those
people who had a penchant for violence
rose to positions of power the gangster
class organized the first militias and
when they weren't manning the barricades
they were usually off looting the
apartments of ethnic serbs who lived in
the city and oftentimes murdering them
so it doesn't save you from the poison
of war but there are times when you are
faced with your own physical destruction
the destruction of your family the
destruction of your community the
destruction of your nation and i think
at that moment uh it i don't like the
term just war but war becomes inevitable
and and and and anybody uh i think
at least in moral terms it's
understandable as to why they would use
violence to try and protect themselves
and protect those around them but that
does not save them in the end of course
from
the the evil consequences of war and the
damage that war does to them as
individuals and to the society at large
thank you hi hi my name is chelsea
peterson from mclean high school and you
talk about how
war has become a form of entertainment
in our country especially and how it has
penetrated the media and books music and
popular movies and everything and i was
just wondering if you think that the
media has changed our connotation of war
in the american soldier and whether the
necessity for war on the media
will continue to perpetuate over time or
whether it will eventually dissipate
i i think that you know when you go back
and look at
you know even all the way back to the
ancient greeks or you know you know when
you read the aeneid um
that that myth that warrior myth is just
a really powerful myth within almost all
cultures
uh especially imperial cultures and uh i
think what's different is the way we
would disseminate the myth
uh but the myth has always been there
and i think we'll always be there uh you
know there's no shortage of great
memoirs by
people who have been through combat and
have come back and written about the
reality of war
but it's painful it's painful to read
it's painful to hear it's painful to
understand and i i think when you talk
to people who come back even you know
these soldiers and marines are coming
back from iraq
they'll sit around and people will ask
them how it was and and if they really
start to tell them
most people begin to get really
uncomfortable really quickly the fact is
a lot of people don't want to hear the
only people who really
understand war
are the people on the ground who see it
because the images how however
disturbing they may be
uh
are so sanitized
uh and so and and and of course the ones
that begin to
to
uh reflect any kind of truth uh so
infrequent
um that we're spared from seeing how
horrible war is
and when people come back and try and
and lay it out for us
it's painful to hear people prefer to go
back to the myth there's a kind of
natural gravitation back towards the
myth is i'm trying to figure out the
gravitational pull for the press
assuming let's assume let's give benefit
of the doubt that this is not purposeful
propagandizing
is it is the common thread here the
narrative the need of a narrative you
have mythology the main vehicle for
dispersing mythology is storytelling the
main vehicle for journalism is
storytelling is is it looking at this
chaotic battle in front of you and
needing to impose some narrative thread
onto it that well you know that's a good
point you know and
because when you're actually in a
situation of combat
the the
most all the time you're just completely
confused
you're desperately trying to figure out
where the firings coming from uh it's
often coming from you know more than one
place or your friends friendly fire yeah
yeah and and you only see a tiny little
uh you know there's a small perimeter of
stuff that you could you're actually
seeing i mean the landscape of
of of you know even a fire fight uh is
beyond at the moment
your ability to comprehend and grasp so
what you do when when the fighting ends
is immediately try and create a
narrative to make sense of it
and that in many ways is what the press
does for you it takes what for the
individual is completely confusing
and makes a narrative well the press
knows very well
and and i and i think it's probably not
always conscience conscious but they
they they understand in a kind of
reflexive way uh what the best narrative
is and that is you know who was heroic
where are those uh you know refugees or
people who were uh repressed who have
now been liberated by our you know
heroic troops and and what are the
perfidious crimes of the enemy that fits
into a very comfortable mythic war
narrative that allows that is the
framework by which many of them seek to
understand what's happening but more
importantly
it's that framework that the people at
home expect
hi go ahead please
hi
i'm sam hedlund from the center for
strategic and international studies
it seems to me like your work on trying
to find some kind of middle ground in
how to
go forward in war if if we find
ourselves in war
without being seduced by it and
corrupted by it um
for i you could take exception to this
but i see a certain commonality between
that and certain realist
thinkers like ronald niebur
and
so i'm just wondering um what utility do
you see in
uh
philosophical reflection on war and what
where do you think that could take us
sam terrific question and i'm sorry to
do this to you about only about 30
seconds for an answer
um
reinhold niebuhr is a great of course
influence i mean you were right beside
him uh i think that we want to look at
people who understand human reality
always be wary of utopianists
and cynics
and
understand as niebuhr said that decision
in life is never between moral and
immoral but usually between immoral and
more immoral and once you realize that
is that
it becomes a lot easier to make choices
okay thank you gentlemen sorry to rush
you and your answer these are a couple
of the books from chris hedges
about war
interesting reads we would highly
recommend them i want to thank you for
your questions and comments throughout
the discussion i particularly want to
thank becky saipos and her students from
mclean high school and also dan gregory
and his well students of life i guess
you call them employees at csis thanks
to all of you for joining us next week
when we return to the newseum our
discussion will be about reporting on
religion that's our version of a holiday
program i guess hope you'll join us then
until then for all of us at barry siegel
i'm a former uh los angeles times
national correspondent the author of
both the
novels and non-fiction books and i now
direct the literary journalism program
down at uc irvine where i'm a professor
of english
we'll start we'll just go in order here
okay tom hamburger is an investigative
reporter for the los angeles times where
he has broken a range of stories
examining the influence of corporate
interests on government the role of the
white house political office and the new
strategies
political parties deploy to win
elections before joining the times in
204 he covered money in politics for the
wall street journal and before that
served as washington bureau chief for
the minneapolis star tribune
chris hedges next down was for nearly
two decades a foreign and war
correspondent uh for the new york times
the dallas morning news the christian
science monitor and npr serving in such
places as latin america africa the
middle east and the balkans he was a
member of a team that won the 2002
pulitzer prize for explanatory reporting
for the new york times
times his coverage of global terrorism
he received the 2002 amnesty
international global award for human
rights journalism he's a senior fellow
at the nation institute and also teaches
in the program for american studies at
princeton he's the author of three books
the most recent coming out last year
losing moses on the freeway the ten
commandments in america
matthew miller matt miller is a fortune
magazine columnist a commentator for
npr's morning edition the host of the
public radio program left right and
center on kcrw
and a senior fellow for american
progress a newly launched think tank led
by john podesta the former white house
chief of staff for clinton
bill clinton
well you
got to start doing that
his articles have appeared in the new
york times magazine the atlantic monthly
and many other national publications a
consultant to corporations non-profits
and governments
miller was previously an aide in the
clinton white house and a management
consultant with mckinsey and company his
first book the two percent solution
fixing americans america's problems in
ways liberals and conservatives can love
was published by public affairs in fall
203.
down there at the end is paul
wallston is a peter walston i'm sorry it
says peter here i just said paul
is a white house correspondent for the
los angeles times where he was his
written extensively on the power of the
conservative movement and the operations
of the white house political machine
before joining the times in 204 he
covered florida politics and governor
jeb bush for the miami herald and the
saint petersburg times and was
washington correspondent for the
charlotte observer tom and peter
together are the co-authors of uh is it
soon to arrive soon to arrive new book
uh
end of june uh titled one party country
the republican plan for dominance in the
21st century so a pretty good crew here
to talk about the the future of america
um what i'd like to do is just start off
and invite each of you to uh tell us a
little bit about
what your thoughts are on that topic
from your particular perspective what
you've been working on or what you will
be working on and we'll start the
conversation hopefully we can
just start to maybe get into a
discussion back and forth about them
you want to start sure barry thank you
um thanks it's good to be here uh can
you hear me okay
uh let's see how do we make this go
how's this yeah is that better
okay
um
let's see that's a broad question you
asked about the is it about the future
of america the state of america let me
tell you what i've been working on with
my colleague peter walston
our book one party country which is
coming out at the end of june looks at
um
the republican machine
that is built that has been built over
several decades and that is enhanced
dramatically we argue during the bush
administration and the book
makes an argument still relevant at
least we believe even at a time when it
would seem may as it seems to many
pundits and maybe to most of you that
the democrats it seems to us too at
least on the face of it the democrats
should have a lay down hand
in the 2006 midterm elections that are
coming up
i mean the republicans most effective
leader in congress tom delay has been
indicted
and resigned
the
let's say
the
scooter libby
hold your applause to the end
scooter living
scooter libby indicted and resigned
karl rove not yet not yet indicted not
has not been indicted but he's under a
cloud
um
the the worst of all for the republicans
and for this administration it seems is
the news we read every day from iraq
which is their best known enterprise and
is now
a poster child for
for uh misjudgment arguably
we argue the case though that despite
all of this negative news for the
republicans
the democrats do not have a lay down
hand
in fact the odds are against them even
in 2006 even with these dismal poll
numbers
now some of you may be thinking well the
republicans have a secret weapon i know
what it is the democrats
in fact that may be the case but our
argument in fact is that there are
series of structural
barriers if you will
structural and strategic protections the
republican party has put into place
some of them may be well known to you
some we think as a and as we started our
our project were not so well known to us
but we discovered them along the way
there's a list of about half a dozen of
them they're protections that despite
miserable poll ratings and as in a spate
of bad news affecting at least this
administration currently
protects the republican majorities in
congress and we think arguably has given
them a machinery uh structural and
strategic advantages as i mentioned a
moment ago
that
will keep republicans
give the republicans an edge
in 2006 and things may not go well for
them in 2006 but they'll be in good
position in 2008 and thereafter my
colleague and co-author peter walston
who's
obsessed with sports metaphors uh says
this is the new york yankees or the duke
basketball team they don't win every
game they don't win every season but
they have an advantage starting out
every season let me get let me mention
just too quickly and i'll when
and we'll let someone else
talk here
one advantage
is the uh despite these poll numbers
that would suggest presidential approval
in the 30s very high public disapproval
of both the administration and the
republicans in congress
is that the congress remain the number
of competitive seats in congress is very
low
this didn't happen by accident
one of the things that we talk about in
the book one party country is an effort
that began by lee atwater in the 1980s
at the republican national committee to
form common cause with um
african-american and latino activists
around the country who of course were
leaning democratic and the idea was to
redistrict
was to control congressional
redistricting in a way that would elect
more republicans in the future and that
would guarantee safety and reduce the
competition in these seats
our book describes that briefly and i'll
just tell you give you a brief idea of
what of what the idea was of what
atwater's idea was and we believe it
succeeded
in the 1982 the civil rights act the
voting rights act was amended to make
encourage more minority
uh uh representatives in congress and
minority districts
many republicans opposed this but lee
atwater who was at the republican
national committee at the time saw an
opportunity and the opportunity was to
form common cause with latino and black
and african-american leaders around the
country and say let's redistrict we can
increase the number of latino and
african-americans in congress but if we
draw it right this will concentrate
these voters who tend to who are among
them the democratic party's most loyal
voters
concentrate them at the heart of
districts that will elect minorities and
the adjacent districts which once enjoy
which were once gerrymandered to
in uh enjoy support from um which would
could once elect
democrats
uh more dramatically because they drew
support from these core democratic
neighborhoods
um
uh let's see uh the um
uh
the result would be
and the result was in fact in the
election of 1992 more minorities elected
to congress than ever before but also in
the adjacent districts
democrats who had held those seats were
losing to republicans for the first time
it's a redistrict it's a redistrict
redistricting strategy
and and we describe it better in the
book than i did just now
but it's an example of how when you look
at what's happening in this country now
you can look at the macro and say oh the
republicans are tr in trouble but if you
look at the micro you see that
um it's very difficult to see at the
moment how
the republicans will um lose control of
either the house or the senate
let me since we're still on your on your
book let's let peter jump in
also uh so yeah
the republicans are the yankees huh
that's the
yeah
legitimately as tom said despite what
the whole number show and uh and again
the book uh does this better than we can
sitting here but i want to give you a
few examples of
of areas that might be of interest to to
you all it sounds like from the applause
i've been hearing in this room and in
other sessions that
these audiences are largely um maybe
troubled by the idea of a republic of a
long-term republican majority
um
but what's very interesting about
these structural advantages is the is
the the way that the party the
republican party has systematically
built this built these structural
advantages these are not coincidental
some of them go back decades to the
creation of think tanks in washington
such as the american enterprise
institute the heritage foundation
cato others but others
are more recent
creations of this president and his
political team karl rove led by karl
rove a few examples uh you know the 2004
campaign was really kind of a
culmination of many of these ideas that
they had
for building this this majority and part
of what they saw is they saw that the
democratic party for decades dominated
politics in this country and that was a
a vestige of the new deal and franklin
roosevelt so they looked at ways to peel
off and peel apart that new deal
coalition
and part part of what they did was they
went after african americans and one of
the areas that we saw done where they
did it so well in o4
was the the use of a program in the
white house called the faith-based
initiative
many democrats opposed this program and
it was when bush first
proposed it
although in fact uh president clinton
and also al gore had supported uh
charitable choice and did support um the
use of federal dollars for uh religious
charities uh what president bush did was
was turn this into much more of a
political weapon and they did what they
did is they directed millions of dollars
to
african american and latino churches
that turned around and whose pastors
became supporters of the president
it was a very smart
it was outrageous to some but it was
from a political standpoint a very smart
uh use of of a government program
there's a number of examples that we
detail in uh in the book one in one
party country that uh that are similar
that show you how they used uh the
machinery of government uh and uh to
turn a political advantage uh the
faith-based
initiative was actually the that was a
story um i was in a uh an
african-american church in milwaukee
during the campaign and it was that
experience where i uh
when when i first came across the
faith-based initiative and that was part
of what motivated us to write this book
um and there were other examples of them
peeling away groups that are so closely
associated with democratic dominance uh
one another example and then i'll
let others talk but was
the republican efforts to segment and go
after the jewish vote
again not a huge vote nationally but in
certain key states battleground states
florida for example where every as we
saw in 2000 every vote can count
michigan as well and even ohio the
republicans figured out that certain
kinds of jewish
of jewish voters were more likely to be
convinced to vote republican
orthodox jews even some conservative
jews the war in iraq pro a lot of single
issue pro-israel jews might be motivated
to vote republican and so they went
about and they found these jews and a
good example was we found in cleveland
heights
a neighborhood of a lot of
russian orthodox jews uh the bush
campaign went there and they used um if
for those of you familiar with orthodox
judaism they have in every community on
mikvo list
which is a list of um the the whole
jewish community for purposes of social
services and babysitting and community
events they actually turned the mikvah
list into a voter database
they also
convinced the local rebbies to issue
what i probably shouldn't use this word
but but in a sense was a thought was a
religious fatwa to um to vote on
election day and they told not just the
men but the women to vote
and the yeshivas
had election day off so the girls could
babysit so the women could go vote
and they also helped on the final days
of the campaign an entire uh bush
campaign rally in russian
which was a pretty for the people we
spoke to who were there was a pretty
remarkable event and it was the first
time in their memory that a republican
uh political event had been uh carried
out in russia and other uh russian jews
in new york city uh uh have been have
been political players uh but this was
one of the first times that we
encountered uh kind of the tapping into
that community uh outside of new york
city those are a couple examples and i'm
sure we'll talk more
well okay we've got envisioning the
future we've got possibly a one-party
country i know that uh chris hedges is
uh looking down in the future is also
thinking about the growing power of the
christian right
um
in fact isn't your
you got in the fall you've got another
book coming out right yes american
fascism the christian right and the war
on america
um
well tell us what is your go ahead man
well that's you know that's what i've
spent the last
year and a half or so doing is is
traveling to christian right events and
interviewing people within the movement
um and i i uh i think that uh it's
interesting to watch the troubles within
the republican party which in many ways
is imploding which has been the main
vehicle for the christian right in their
efforts to take power um there's a great
deal of dissatisfaction within the
christian right with the bush
administration now a feeling uh or fear
on the part of many of the leaders of
the christian right including bob jones
uh and others uh dobson who worry that
once again they've been had uh that the
republican party has made all sorts of
promises that to them uh to carry out uh
their core agenda uh of course banning
abortion uh putting prayer back in
schools uh
you know some of the these sort of moral
hot button issues that have mobilized
their base um so this uneasy
relationship is fascinating to watch and
it's of course being played out and will
be played out tomorrow uh with the issue
of immigration uh the the the radical
leaders of the christian right uh uh
are strong supporters of bills that
would essentially expel immigrants or
and make it a federal or a felony to
assist illegal immigrants whereas the
corporate sponsors who they have made an
alliance with uh and of course
it's that mixture of the christian right
and
and uh and corporations that define the
bush administration uh of course want
cheap labor they want and that that's a
really interesting phenomenon to watch
uh so there's an uneasy tension within
the movement and and uh the christian
right of course is not monolithic but
this i think that's a good demonstration
that neither is the republican party uh
i think that this movement the radical
christian right people we call christian
reconstructionists or christian
dominionists those who would like to
create a christian state they would like
an amendment within the constitution
that defines our country as a christian
nation
they would like to strip down the
federal government to be responsible
essentially for homeland security
defense and property rights and nothing
else all social services would be turned
over to evangelical churches who would
administer uh everything from drug
rehabilitation clinics to schools with
of course the possibility of prospect
proselytizing and we see uh much of that
uh uh coming to play in the faith-based
initiative that peter mentioned where we
are giving tax dollars to groups that
will not hire jews will not hire muslims
will not hire atheists will not hire
people who they don't define as
bible-believing christians
um and and i think that that that you
know there's a kind of uh huge shift uh
within american society uh that that
those of us who are removed from those
pockets perhaps uh don't quite
understand and uh and glimpse w with a
kind of disbelief and uh
uh and uh i think puzzlement um you know
why
to to those of us who uh believe in
rational thought who believe in
uh intellectual honesty who believe in
science why would you want to establish
in public school systems uh the teaching
of creationism i mean the writers of the
book of genesis after all thought the
earth was flat
um and and i think that that what this
movement is built on is a profound
despair that has gripped uh especially
the working class in this country
remember there are 47 million full-time
workers in the united states who make
less than ten dollars an hour um the
levels of poverty uh even in california
if you look in 1980 uh those children in
this state who were living in poverty
uh it was 15.2 percent it is now 25.1
percent and remember that that the
official official level of poverty is 17
200 a year for a family of four that's
before deductions and before the cost of
getting to work et cetera there is of
course no family that is going to exist
if you if you add uh
into that if you factor into that levels
of near poverty probably 46 percent of
the children in this state are in that
category and this is replicated around
the country uh it is i spent a lot of
time in ohio as i think both tom and
peter did and they can tell you as well
as i do that you get up to places like
youngstown and
these are just absolutely devastated uh
you know former manufacturing centers
and i think that this movement is
playing off of the rage of tens of
millions of americans in this country
who have been completely disenfranchised
by the system and it's extremely
volatile they have been sucked into a
movement that is not reality based they
believe in magic they believe that jesus
intervenes in their life on a daily
basis and can heal them and has a plan
for them and and the theology that they
embrace and promote is essentially one
of profound despair because it is
wrapped around this grim apocalyptic
vision where everything on the planet
will be destroyed everything that has
betrayed them everything that they hate
and they alone it's a kind of spiritual
darwinism will be lifted up into heaven
and the rest of us will be incinerated
but incinerated with horrific torment uh
and i think that there is a
psychological
uh
uh
malaise or a psychological
underpinning to this belief system that
we begin we have to begin to confront if
we're going to confront the rise of this
very radical movement that has as its
goal the destruction of our open society
okay so now now we've got a one-party
country
and a radical christian right
in charge uh matt what do you got for us
[Laughter]
well i know you're concerned one thing
you're concerned about i don't want to
lead you you can actually give us
anything you want but i know you're
concerned to some extent about the
future of capitalism in the in the
country and the future of the american
model so
um
well you teed up a lot of things because
i hope we'll get to in conversation but
let me uh
uh let me get my own spiel first um i
guess what i think about the future
of
uh of the country
um the first thing i do is i want to
close my eyes and just wish it's two and
a half years from now because i don't
think the real debate will start on this
until the 2008 campaign i think that the
the
the you know while 2006 will be
interesting and it'll be interesting to
see uh you know i am hopeful as a
democrat that democrats gain seats but i
don't i think the kinds of macro issues
that matter in sort of shaping the
trajectory of the country only are
presidential level issues and will only
get resonance and voice in a
presidential campaign
and if we had a parliamentary system i
think this crowd would have gotten a
vote of no confidence you know uh
a little bit of a while ago we'd have a
change in government now but we really i
don't know if others feel this way
you're sort of stuck in this situation
where we gotta wait another couple of
years until we get another presidential
campaign and can revisit some of the
basic direction
uh that we have so that that's sort of
point one if you look at the 2008
campaign i think it's wide open in a lot
of ways i mean the republican field is
going to be wide open in ways it hasn't
been in i don't know how long when on
the democratic side obviously mrs
clinton has a sort of presumptive uh
lock certainly on the donations and the
political talent and you know we can
talk about that in q a um but i think
the issues there's going to be a chance
to have a real debate again in a way
that we haven't had
uh in a long time and as we approach
that moment i guess
the most interesting thing to me right
now is how alienated most americans feel
from both major parties uh even though
the polls show the democrat the
democrats uh way ahead as we head toward
the midterm elections and the
republicans as tom said in terrible
shape you know president in the low 30s
it couldn't get worse than that they're
they're not saying that they find
democrats an appealing alternative at
all and the fastest growing party right
now is people who identify themselves as
no party or independence and i think
that that suggests or reflects this kind
of um you know i don't know if people
would articulate it this way but that
most people know that what they're
getting from the current crop in power
as well as what the democrats are
talking about in opposition
aren't equal to the challenges uh
that the country faces so that's sort of
the political terrain substantively i
think there's a reason for this kind of
public alienation and sort of official
confusion by both parties which is you
know not to be too grand about it but i
think we're at a uh an interesting new
inflection point in the history of
american capitalism uh we are um
we are about to undergo and i think this
is true not just for the us but for the
wealthy nations more broadly perhaps the
severest test capitalism has faced in
nearly a century since the new deal
since the great depression and the new
deal and i think no one least of all
today's capitalists have any idea of
what to do about it i see four forces at
work uh that are shaping where we're
headed one is everyone knows is
globalization but the the main piece of
it is the fact that because of the
uh the dramatic shrinking of
communications costs and the advance of
technology the ability for jobs to be
done overseas at very distant places now
it's going to affect not just
manufacturing and traditional
blue-collar jobs but increasingly jobs
that go up the income scale alan blinder
who was the one of the key economic
advisers to president clinton did a big
piece in foreign affairs a month or so
ago saying that as many as 40 to 50
million jobs could be affected by this
new ability to outsource or to to to to
source labor uh from different places in
the world and i think we have about 140
million jobs today in the american
economy so if you're talking about 40 to
50 million potentially being exposed to
risk and i don't want to be a cassandra
or doomsayer we don't know how far that
will go but that's a different thing
than previous eras of globalization 100
years ago uh in a different dynamic for
both uh everyone's lives and for
politics than just a smaller group uh
who are unskilled who've been
traditionally affected by what can be
outsourced so that's that's force one
force two is given these dynamics you've
got corporate america in a situation
where it feels a strong desire to get
out of the healthcare and pension
business and our our welfare state is
kind of uh anomalous compared to the
rest of the world and that we've
provided health care basically through
large companies uh and uh that system i
would say is really at risk not
sustainable probably was it was a
historical accident that happened in the
first place after world war ii in ways
we can talk about if you want but
companies for reasons that are not that
they're evil and big bad companies but
because all the companies they compete
with around the world don't bear as gm
does 1500 per car in health care costs
starbucks is raising howard schultz told
me the other day for a column it raised
the price of lattes you know from four
bucks to 425 largely because of health
care costs now that works at starbucks
because it's got a customer base that
can afford to pay an extra quarter for a
latte and therefore subsidize uh nice
health care for a hundred thousand
starbucks workers in the us but not
every company obviously can make the
math work uh when they're you know
because not everyone's got products
where people can pay four and a half
bucks for a cup of coffee so again the
the health care system today uh is uh is
putting corporations under strain at the
same time the third force is that the
aging population
not just here but in the other advanced
nations is putting tremendous stress on
public budgets so at the time the
companies feel a need to get out of some
of the healthcare and pension side of
things
the government is about to be totally
gobbled up by healthcare and pensions in
ways that makes it very hard and in fact
unthinkable at current levels of
taxation to take on many added burdens
uh as companies are sort of getting out
of the business of doing some of this
stuff and then finally and this is sort
of i haven't fully wrapped my mind
around this but there is the the the
inequality factor and uh look inequality
has always been with us in capitalist
system but there's something new going
on now the levels of ceo pay in this
country are reaching levels that are so
divorced from performance and so
divorced from sort of any sort of common
sense uh uh uh sense of reality and the
gap between what happens at a very small
straight at the top and the the vast
swath of americans many of whom are
going to be in this 40 to 50 million
were talking about potentially being at
risk it just raises questions about the
coherence of a democracy when you've got
a very thin layer constantly doing
better
and more and more folks feeling stressed
it's not just here china feels the same
thing i talked to a chinese official the
other day asking them what's your
biggest worry about the reforms you're
going through now and his answer was not
the uh not the not the incredible
structural reforms they have to go to
because their banking system's a mess
you know they've got all these
state-owned enterprises they're trying
to transition to
an economy that will be more productive
and they've done more in the last 10 or
15 years to bring human beings out of
poverty than at any time in human
history but his biggest worry is the
inequality between the very wealthy
coast the shanghai you know the coastal
area where there are millionaires and
gucci stores opening up etc and the the
deep rural provinces where you've still
got several hundred million people who
haven't benefited at all from the boom
that china has been undergoing for two
decades in many ways because their
health system is very screwed up in the
rural area they're actually worse so
inequality is sort of the last factor
and i guess all of this is going to
place stress on our sort of on our
current model and it's going to force a
rethinking of our current social
arrangements in american capitalism i
think the big need is that we're going
to have to find new ways to rebalance
the risk that capitalism inevitably
brings in a market-based system with the
security that people crave and the
decent life that a society is wealthy as
ours ought to be able to create we're
going to have to find new models to do
that that aren't based on putting it all
on corporations aren't based on putting
it necessarily all on government in
traditional ways but finding answers
that combine market forces and public
purposes in ways that will set us on a
kind of new path
uh for for the 21st century and we can
talk more about it i guess as we tee it
up in q a but i think somehow we're
struggling toward what i'm thinking of
as a kind of a capitalism 4.0 uh to be
born here uh the first phase being sort
of in the beginning of industrial age to
uh to the early 19th early 20th century
uh sort of
industry booms and then you have lots of
excesses and charles dickens talking
about the dark satanic mills phase two
was sort of the whole period through the
20th century where you had this forces
for equity trying to go against the
forces of of just pure markets uh giving
us progressive movement the new deal the
great society a backlash against that
since the 70s with reagan thatcher etc
and now we're on the threshold of
this fourth phase where the old models
aren't going to work and we're going to
have to find both a new politics that
lets us have this discussion and also a
new form of public policy that lets us
update these old really timeless
concerns in a way that keeps our country
competitive in a global economy
um
[Applause]
thank you guys
i'd like to invite you to sort of
discuss each other's ideas but let me
start with one question that maybe all
of you can
might consider
um
if not answer
do you think we need a third party
what you want me to any again all of you
whoever wants to grab the mic you're all
on now at the same time get competitive
well i guess uh i mean i'm a democrat uh
but i've always been vulnerable to third
party temptation just because i'm
frustrated with uh with
with democrats ability to lay out a
vision i think that's equal to what the
challenges are today i'm hoping
democrats and i hope in 2008 whether
it's mrs clinton or others will be equal
to that i guess i think that if it
doesn't happen this election
and if the republicans can continue to
veer right and democrats end up in what
i think of as a kind of reactionary
liberalism then i think there
there will be a new kind of uh you know
uh echo of a ross perot style movement
maybe not you know with perrault himself
uh obviously but i think the us economy
generates enough high net worth patriots
to fund what it takes to fund and it's a
lot uh some kind of new force that would
probably be co-opted by one of the
parties uh because that that's what
tends to happen in in american history
richard hofstadter has this great line
that third parties the role of third
parties is to sting like a bee and then
die
uh and uh and and it's true i mean what
perot did in 92 i thought he did a
tremendous public service it totally
changed what we did in the clinton
administration in the first year on the
budget because he proved that 20 of the
public would vote for somebody who was
up there with the charts and the graphs
talking about how we couldn't go on this
way
being fiscally irresponsible so um i
would like to see democrats find the
right path on this but i think we may
need uh
we may need a third force uh if 08
doesn't
end up promising i think matt makes a
makes a good point i mean if we didn't
have eugene debs we would have never had
the new deal
you know
what we're creating in american society
is an oligarchy i mean there is a co
america in some ways is turning into a
third world nation
we now live in a country where the top
one percent of the richest people have
financial wealth equal to the combined
95 percent of the population
and
uh
if this continues uh it it's not going
to have simply social ramifications but
political ramifications as well
especially as
uh corporate interests as tom and
peter through the republican party have
pointed out
rig the system
and these well-funded
mass movements that are really about the
sanctification of rage and exclusion
and an expression of hate at their core
gain momentum and they will gain
momentum as things get worse i mean if
the housing bubble bursts um if we
suffer another catastrophic terrorist
attack and having spent a year of my
life covering al-qaeda for the new york
times there was not an intelligence
official i interviewed who didn't think
it was inevitable it was always a
question of when not if and i think we
always have to factor in that
possibility having lived through the
beginning of the suicide bombings in
israel i've seen what happens when a
populist suddenly becomes terrified and
afraid and and we are far more coddled
than most israelis
uh you know the there are many people in
the administration who have worked
overtime since 9 11 to make us afraid
and nothing of course has happened on
american soil since 9 11 but but give
them the tools to work with and i think
that we could in a very short time see a
system
that has been weakened through a series
of forces uh the the the thing that
frightens me the most is that you know
we went through a period like this in
the 1930s um and and there was a very a
flirtation by many american capitalists
with fascism fortune magazine and i
think 1934 published a cover story on
mussolini that lauded his ability to
defend labor unions and and free large
corporations uh to function but there
were powerful progressive forces in the
country especially through the labor
unions
those forces are gone now um the press
has been corporatized less than 10
percent of american workers are
unionized and i don't see the breaks
that we had in the nineteen thirties so
that if we enter a period of crisis
which you know we could enter a period
of crisis just on the mismanagement of
the economy alone uh i i i wonder where
those third party forces or those uh
progressive forces that while they may
not have assumed power have have helped
shape the social agenda helped give us
things like social security uh
and i i don't know where those forces
are gonna come from how much to jump in
here
um
peter had told me that gore vidal was
asked yesterday about the third party
whether a third party is necessary and
he said well
don't we need to have a second we do we
have a second party
and that's a question i did want to
throw
throw to matt um self-identified
democrat here and someone who has done
in his book two percent solution some
some original thinking
um and offered some new ideas
you laid out
and chris just referred a moment ago to
some serious problems um that could be
facing this country we you talked about
the kind of economic calamity we could
face matt you mentioned health care
outsourcing pensions
if we go down that list
where is the democratic party
um on those topics because
what i'd argue is that the republican
party at least can offer this a co an
answer there is we may disagree with it
but there is at least it is at least
possible for us to describe something
coherent that the party um stands for or
believes or an approach that they would
provide is there to the democrats um are
the democrats able to answer on any of
the on any of the four biggies that you
mentioned i i guess i think yes um but
but first i should say i don't think
we're headed toward a calamity like the
one chris would i think mentioned i mean
the depression was you know 25 percent
of the country unemployed for a long
period of time um i i don't think we're
i don't think we're facing something
like that and i think we know a lot
better how to manage the macro economy
than we did then there were a lot of big
errors then that made
you know the stock market crash much
worse so
i think that's good news doesn't mean
we're not going to have potential
trouble and uh
in particular the
standard of living the traditional
standard of living for a lot of folks
moving up the income scale more than it
has in the past uh being threatened
outsourcing 50 million jobs well
seriously if it ends up yes if it ends
up if if it ends up being that i said i
don't want to say that's that those are
numbers that are being bandied about
that doesn't mean it's true yet so but
it's uh but it's a threat i guess i
think the democrats do have i mean the
democrats want health care i hope that
mrs clinton will be talking about health
care for everyone in the next election i
think republicans know it's it's it's
sufficiently an issue that they will be
talking about much bigger expansions of
health care with their 2008 candidates
uh as well even in spite of what john
mccain is doing these days uh i think
when he's running uh toward the center
sometime closer to the uh the next
campaign he'll be aiming higher on
health care uh and so will some of the
other uh someone the other mitt romney
maybe mitt romney right exactly um so um
and the democrats want uh you know
decent pensions my my my quarrel with
the democrats or with the with with the
folks in my party is that if you add up
the wish list the traditional
progressive
wish list of uh you know even fuller
prescription drugs for medicare than
what the republicans did a down payment
on universal health coverage a bolstered
social security system
much more investment in education for
poor kids in particular i think and
teachers for poor kids if you add it all
up it would take taxes as a share of gdp
as a share of the size of the economy so
much higher than we've ever had in the
country and so much higher than it
you can make an argument would be good
for the economy the democrats don't want
to face the idea that we may need to
rethink the way we do medicare and
social security for this new era which i
think we do um and so i don't think that
i think the democrats values are in the
right place i think we end up in this
weird situation where a lot of folks
have to decide is it easier to teach the
democrats economics or the republicans
decency and i think it's and i think
that's a that that should that shouldn't
have to be our only choice i guess you
know the democrats though matter
vulnerable on this because i'm not sure
you mentioned universal health care is
something that all the democrats agree
on i'm not sure that's true that every
democratic candidate agrees on universal
health care at least they're they're
afraid of being tagged with that because
the republicans have managed to define
that in a certain way
and also that's why by the way what mitt
romney just in massachusetts is so
helpful because he's the republican
governor there who just passed with the
democratic legislature with
ted kennedy's support
a plan that would over several years
they argue get to universal in a
different way um and i have some
questions about whether that will happen
but that's an enormous marker for the
gop and could change the polls of debate
sorry no no that's okay uh and the other
point you mentioned how democrats tend
to support education from better
education for poor kids that may be true
but again here is where the republicans
have found a way to create doubt in the
minds of many people because if you look
at the debate over school vouchers
that's a debate that
republicans are supporting taxpayer
dollars for private education and most
of those programs are created in inner
cities which are populated by
african-americans and many of the people
who have
benefited at least many of the people
who the republicans claim will benefit
or would benefit from voucher programs
are
black kids and it's the democrats
largely because of the power of the
teachers unions in that party that have
opposed vouchers so here you have a an
an issue where republicans are able to
go to the inner cities and republicans
can go to these churches again in part
through the faith-based initiative but
other programs
and they can talk about how in fact it's
republicans who have done more for poor
kids and that's
an area that many democrats are very
uncomfortable i think that's a great i
think that's a great point and one i'm
sure you'll hear more about in the new
book one party dominance i want to i
promise you i would plug their book at
every opportunity because it is going to
be great um but the the i see i agree
with you i mean but i think and that's
part of what i mean when i say the
democrats fall into this reactionary
liberalism because i think you're
totally right i mean i'm a liberal who
is pro-bigger voucher trials i think we
should try vouchers in some places i
don't think it's a panacea but i think
it's wrong when the only thing a
democratic party can go to a a family
with kids in kindergarten latino family
in la and or new york and say
sit tight we've got a 10 or 15 year
reform plan i don't think that's a
sufficient answer and i think you need
if you spend any time in urban school
systems as i have you need both serious
top down reforms and you need some kind
of
from the bottom bubbling up
choice or competition that'll help shake
up what can be very calcified
bureaucracies in the teachers unions and
i'm friendly with many teachers i'm
friendly with a number of union leaders
but there are ways in which
they have requirements that i think make
it impossible for democrats to serve
their constituents low-income you know
poor kids um at the expense of their
biggest interest group because the
unions today send more folks to the
democratic convention than the state of
california so i think those are huge
problems and contribute to my worry that
democrats can't ever craft some an
agenda that's going to be actually equal
to some of the problems i i just you
know you mentioned the problem with the
democrats in economics and you know to
fund the social programs would
require raising taxes
but the democrats no longer raise the
issue of the fact that half of all tax
dollars go
into uh defense into the military
that you know we spend 60 billion
dollars on a missile defense system uh
that doesn't work uh we spend two
billion dollars to build uh b-2 bombers
that most people in the pentagon don't
even want
and it used to be in the old days that
there would be democratic senators who
would investigate uh you know the the
the this
huge dumping of uh american tax dollars
into the pentagon and challenge
particular defense systems missiles it's
all gone there is a complete acceptance
on the part of the democratic party as
there is within the republican party of
everything these these huge corporations
want because they're funding both
parties and i think that
i i think that we have to address the
fact that the political system has
become hostage to these corporate
interests and and we know it because on
those issues they won't challenge it and
when they get up and tell you you know
we can't fund universal health care we
can't go in and fix inner city public
schools because it would require paying
taxes they don't address the fact that i
mean how much was it for a hammer that
they had to 450 dollars remember i mean
it it it but but that's it's a small
anecdotal story but we're talking about
i don't know hundreds of millions of
dollars it's just sheer waste of
american taxpayers dollars can i toss in
one point to that
i i agree with you and i disagree with
you i agree with you that it is it is
incredibly wrong that during the the
biggest military buildup uh maybe in the
nation's history since uh bush took
office when it's gone from around 300
billion to close to 500 billion per year
the fact that there hasn't been
investigation when you know there's in
any ramp up like that there's enormous
waste and enormous abuse etc etc is is
wrong and democrats should have been all
over it like harry truman was even
during world war ii when he actually
made his name as a senator and gotten
the cover of time magazine for leading
that kind of uh
look into the industrial
military-industrial complex even during
a time of
of massive war in a way that was harder
arguably than it should be today but i
have to say i think you're wrong just in
terms of the facts the idea that we
could fund what we need to fund for a
progre if progressives think you could
fund the progressive agenda uh simply by
cutting military spending i believe i
believe that's factually wrong the
military spending is about 500 billion a
year the federal budget's around 2.2
trillion now you can't cut defense
enough to fund all of this so even if we
could agree you could trim defense you
can't deal with the aging of the baby
boom and what that's going to do to
social security and medicare adding 45
or 50 million people who are uninsured
to the roles of the unsure
recruiting a new generation of teachers
spending a lot more i think on
subsidized wages for low-income people
which we'll need to do as more folks uh
become at risk
i think you can't do it through that
alone and it's um and i just think we
need to be honest about that i think i
think matt's exactly right my point was
that they won't even challenge them i
mean i think that's a huge window into
who controls them when they won't even
raise the questions that should be
raised on behalf of the american public
and the deeper pro the reason that
happens i believe is because democrats
are in such a weak position on national
security and our party's image is so bad
on national security that all talk of
cutting defense becomes the proxy during
campaigns for are you tough enough to
lead the country in an age of terror and
they are mortified and that's what the
laws the politicians will say privately
yes we should revisit this but unless
you're bob kerry uh or somebody who's
got an impeccable uh military background
and even john kerry's turned out to be
not immune to you know being swift
boated which seems you know amazing
still in retrospect uh democrats feel
absolutely paralyzed in the sound bite
nature of ma of the modern political
campaign to talk about that kind of
stuff uh in a way that lets them be
branded uh you know soft on defense but
that's a problem let's also be clear
that they're getting money from these
people and big money too let's let's let
the audience join in too we've got
microphones on both sides here let's
let's uh you get involved with questions
and the answers because we've got about
10 12 minutes uh to go are the
microphones both on there
go ahead
um one thing that i expected to come up
in this discussion but didn't uh was
what one thing i expected to come up
here but didn't was the nature of the
tax base itself
back in the nineteen fifties
corporations paid twenty four percent of
all federal tax revenues now it's seven
percent
that's a pretty dramatic decline i was
wondering especially for matt and chris
people who talked about these problems
how much of these problems of poverty
the fundamental malaise that was being
discussed um
the disparity between the middle class
and the elites the whole oligarchy thing
how much of that do you think could be
solved if it were possible even by
restructuring the tax base to benefit
more the middle class like was the case
back several decades ago
i think that that's a huge and important
step
i think as matt pointed out there isn't
one easy solution
but certainly creating a more equitable
tax system um
and and you know what we've seen
since the reagan administration but
certainly accelerated with this
administration is that you know that old
adage that whatever is good for exxon
mobil or halliburton is good for america
and and the rest of us be damned and and
i think that you know until uh we begin
to bring people into the congress and uh
and into the federal government that
again are willing to stand up for the
taxpayer and stand up for the person who
isn't a corporation i mean corporations
are given the same legal rights as as
individuals um you know i i don't need
to spell out the whole enron scandal but
go back and look at the savings and
loans bail out i mean this is just we
you know ever since the deregulation
under the reagan years and it's only of
course accelerated under this
administration uh these corporations are
have essentially have the country
hostage and and they they in a very
pernicious and cynical way i think use
the christian right to uh essentially
further this agenda that is their
grassroots movement and and this unholy
alliance is one is one that's deeply
disturbing to the country but i think
taxation is a is a big issue just
briefly is there a second just
i
and i said i say this is a democrat to a
room mostly of democrats i think i don't
think returning to those levels of
corporate taxation makes economic sense
i think it's it's appealing in a popular
sense but i think corporations are
those taxes are paid by the shareholders
which are uh people as well as major
institutions and largely the pension
funds that all of us rely on for our
retirement and i think we'd be better
off raising taxes on things like energy
to force the economy i think gas prices
should be higher and that's i'm sure
another very unpopular thing to say and
there are ways to do that and still
offset it the impact of it on low income
people but until we have higher gas
prices for a long time we will never
change the kind of automobiles and fuel
efficiency that we have it's just the
only way and everybody else knows that
tony blair came a few years ago and said
it's you know it's hard to worry about a
country who could solve a lot of its
problems with an extra buck on a gas tax
uh you know he also knows it's easy to
say that when you're visiting from
another country and don't understand the
political dynamics here but i would be
raising taxes on energy things we want
to conserve and actually making our
companies more competitive globally and
not put them at tax disadvantages in
that way and still try and cut say
payroll taxes on the middle class
because that's a job killing tax
that's cool
how much would it cost for the american
people to buy back their government
everyone uh
just call we'll call that a comment
a rhetorical question okay
what i want to know is how can we
possibly ever have any kind of a change
of let's call it regime
when we can't have an honest election
or
do we need a new system of voting
[Applause]
well i don't know uh if you're referring
to the 2000 election or to the questions
about the voting machines uh
or to the
all of the above or to the system in
general i mean
all of the you know that's those are
that's a hard question to answer i mean
uh the on part of the reality of the
electoral college map that
one of the issues that we explore is
that it just
the nature of the electoral college map
right now benefits
republicans of
actually getting an appropriate
you know part of the issue in 2000 of
course uh many argued that uh al gore
may have made some mistake the gore
campaign may have made some mistakes in
their uh their legal approach to to uh
uh to that and uh as far as ohio um
you know there was a lot of controversy
i'm not sure i ever saw any um
proof that the uh
that the uh potential
problems in uh voting in ohio would have
led to a difference to a difference in
the outcome
let's always remember that i mean the
electoral college is a huge problem gore
won the popular vote by half a million
votes um and and addressing that
electoral college as well as uh the fact
that you know the the disparity in terms
of popular representation
within the senate where you you have
huge population senators centers like
new york state or california with two
senators and other states with very
sparse popular i mean there are there is
restructuring in a way that that we can
more adequately express the popular will
through the electoral process i mean
there is important electoral reform that
needs to be done i think the electoral
college you know certainly in europe it
was sort of the laughing stock of any
democracy it doesn't make any sense when
a candidate wins the popular vote by
that much and and isn't president it
wouldn't happen in any other democracy
that i know
it was very important for the bush
campaign to win the popular vote in
2004. so they uh so a lot of what they
uh there's kind of machinery that they
created they went out and they found
voters where voters had not been found
before
and uh they did this and uh
and i get i guess you could take that
two ways but they uh
they went out and they found uh they
found republican voters in big cities
and they found uh as well as the rural
areas and the kind of ex-urban areas
that traditionally benefit uh benefit
them so what they did you know that the
democrats uh used to be better at uh
grassroots politics it used to be the
the power of the democratic party and
the labor movement to get voters to the
polls to find them to get to motivate
them to get them out you know what the
republicans did that better this time
so uh so there yes there were a lot of
allegations of irregularities and voter
fraud but the truth of the matter is
that the republicans did a better job in
2004 than the democrats did in getting
voters to the polls and the democrats
can win elections again but they're
going to have to figure out a way to
motivate voters and get them to the
polls the way the republicans have done
and they've done this through technology
and sophistication uh the likes of which
the democrats just don't have right now
just one nanosecond on top of that just
to build what peter said i gave a talk
at um
to uh some policy folks and political
folks at 10 downing street in the in
london about two months ago and one of
the things that was most uh surprise
surprising but then not surprising to me
is building on what peter says is
because of the you know they went to
school on what clinton did back in 92
and uh you know there's always been a
close sort of relationship between the
blair wrights and the and the kind of
clinton and the in the democratic party
and um but they were because of the good
relations they have with the bush white
house because of iraq and blair's
positions on iraq they have been using
that to as a way that they're sending
people over to study the way rove and
the republicans do the election hearing
because they think they're so good at it
and so ahead of the democratic side on
this which was stunning to me for a
second and then makes perfect sense if
you're just trying to update your own
state-of-the-art in terms of of winning
elections you should see the voter
database the republicans use i mean i
wish we could see the whole voter
database they use it's it's more
impressive than probably we even
realized but you know the democrats are
way behind on that and so when you're
talking when you when you're concerned
about voter irregularities and and uh
voter fraud determining the outcome of
an election
you know you probably don't want the
election to be that close to begin with
let's see if we can get one more two
questions and let's go what if you could
uh comment on the role of or the
disappearance of the media uh in today's
political spectrum i mean
you know ever since ever since uh dan
rather has
escaped with uh bush's voting record it
seems that the media is retreated from
exposing a lot of the things that you're
talking about here i mean you know the
last election we had all these orange
alerts and yell alerts as soon as the
election was over there's no alerts and
the whole thing disappeared there's so
many situations like that where i don't
see it being printed in the paper i
don't hear it on the radio i don't hear
any anybody in the media really talking
about you know all the injustice is
going on
well i mean i
i guess i'll
there's a lot of frustration you know it
seems to be a theme i've heard in a lot
of sessions no matter what the topic is
everyone wants to know why the media is
screwing this up or that up
and there's a lot of frustration but i
have to remind you that a lot of what
everyone knows about what's going wrong
has been reported in the newspapers i
mean the the washington post did win a
pulitzer prize for exposing the cia
prisons and the new york times want to
filter for the nsa stories i mean a lot
of these things are being reported um
and you know i think that
what we have i mean the media should
canon should be aggressive maybe more
aggressive
let me just add i mean i i think that
that unfortunately
you know especially with the sort of uh
the revolution that's happening within
the media through the internet and uh
through uh the struggling you know we
see it every day played out in
newspapers it's even been played out in
the la times of course uh is that uh
there has been
uh
a a kind of um
response on the part of the media to
placate their elite their advertising
elite so that um
you know we are uh
i think that there are huge sections of
this country who have become virtually
invisible
um you know it used to be that
newspapers would
really cover labor uh cover the inner
city
you know we we may see those people in a
series or an occasional article but i
think their voices now are almost never
heard
uh and i think that's really hurt the
media a lot i think we have become i
think when they criticize us for being
elitist i think that that that is true i
think um you know as peter pointed out
uh the reporting especially on uh the
erosion of civil liberties and the war
in iraq has gotten better but a lot of
that came out of deep soul-searching on
the part of the media that acted as
cheerleaders for the war um and and and
and many of the questions that they're
asking now uh could have been asked
before and were not and so i i think
that there's um you know there's a real
crisis
within within
most newspapers and most media
organizations
and let me just put a plug for great
newspapers like the l.a times and the
washington post in the new york times
that still try and do journalism because
uh
as far as i can tell broadcast media or
television has given up
um there's you know there's virtually no
journalism done or very little anymore
can i just want to follow up with one
quick point i know we're running out of
time but it's this
response to the earlier question i think
certainly that news organizations need
to be more aggressive there has been the
kind of soul-searching that chris talked
about after the the sort of rise of
patriotic response after 9 11 i think
did
produce a too much acquiescence i guess
you might call it not enough tough
questioning but there is also i'd argue
we can come back to this later a war on
the press a war on openness that's going
on in washington right now and the two
cases that were just mentioned well the
nsa spying story and the reporter at the
washington post who won the pulitzer 4
exposing cia uh uh prisons overseas um
are both having to retain huge uh
their news organization incurring huge
legal bills because they're concerned
they're going to be
um bro dragged into court and uh and
required to reveal their sources and
their sources or potential sources those
who talk to the press and allow get
important stories like this to the
public are facing unprecedented
pressures including um polygraphs the
equivalent of loyalty oaths um uh the
war on the press is another is another
topic we should keep in mind and to add
to that point is that there's been a lot
of uh reporters will be submitting
freedom of information act request to
try to as tom has a lot to try to learn
what's going on and a lot of the
administration finds uh unique and
clever ways to reject many of those amen
tom mama and peter i agree with that
totally i hate to do this we're having a
great conversation i know we've got
great questions still to be answered but
we have run out of time thank you very
much
book tv joined the nyu professor and
contributor to the nation harper's and
the new york times for a discussion at
the heart institute in california the
u.s and latin america sunday at 1 15 a.m
eastern here on book tv
former president of the united states
and nobel peace laureate jimmy carter on
in-depth live from his home in plains
georgia sunday december 3rd beginning at
noon eastern president carter is also
the author of more than 20 books such as
our endangered values keeping faith and
the blood of abraham his latest
palestine peace not apartheid is due for
release later this month
join our live three-hour discussion from
plains georgia as book tv's in depth
welcomes president jimmy carter sunday
december 3rd at noon eastern on c-span
2.
[Music]
now an author panel on religion
featuring misquoting jesus author bart
ehrman losing moses on the freeway
author chris hedges and moderated by new
york times national religion
correspondent laurie goodstein
this event from the 2006 great read in
the park in new york city is around 40
minutes
sorry for our
time it took for us to organize
ourselves we're a big big family here a
big panel
my name is laurie goodstein i'm a
national religion correspondent at the
new york times and
i'm glad to welcome you here today this
is a panel on religion
in the quran it is written that muslims
jews and christians are people of the
book
and that's about right judging by the
amount of publishing going on in the
field of religion
as a reporter on the religion beat
i receive at least five new books or
galleys each day
and i've seen a dramatic change over the
years with of course 911
as the dividing line
before 9 11 i got a lot of self-help
titles
books on angels
on charting your chakras what i call
self-centered religion
since then
a lot of religion books are more likely
to grapple with global weighty issues
and questions like can islam
christianity and judaism coexist
or will world war three start next year
in jerusalem
are there other gospels that were left
out of the bible and if so why
do the ten commandments have any bearing
on how people actually live their lives
today we're going to hear from the
authors of four titles
that have risen to the top of the stacks
they represent the breadth and diversity
of offerings in the religion field today
i'll introduce each book and its authors
uh before they speak to you we're going
to do this in three segments
and they're going to be very brief
because i know you're going to have a
lot of questions
so we're going to start with the authors
of the faith club
suzanne oliver
rania italy and priscilla warner
they're collaborators on the book the
faith club which is what you would get
if you took the tv show the view
and had rosie o'donnell
and barbara walters talk only about
after 9 11 these three idealists set out
to write a feel-good children's book
about the similarities of their fates
islam judaism and christianity
but they soon realized that before they
could affirm their similarities they had
to confront their differences
their arguments about the crucifixion
about god the holocaust israel and
palestine they're all in the book no
holds barred
suzanne oliver the christian member of
the group grew up in kansas city
missouri where she made her first
communion at saint elizabeth's catholic
church
she majored in english literature in
german at texas christian university in
fort worth
she's worked at financial world magazine
at forbes as a senior editor and
smartmoney.com where she was managing
editor
rania idliby is a muslim american whose
family was uprooted from tiberius a
palestinian town by the sea of galilee
during the creation of israel
she grew up with a foot in the east in
dubai and a foot in the west in mclean
virginia
she graduated from georgetown
university's school of foreign service
and has a master's degree from the
london school of economics
love and marriage brought her to new
york city where she lives with her
husband and two children
priscilla warner the faith club's jewish
member grew up in rhode island
where she received something of an
interfaith education by attending a
hebrew day school and moving on to a
quaker high school
she graduated from the university of
pennsylvania with a degree in fine arts
and spent 15 years and as an advertising
art director at various ad agencies in
boston and new york
inspired by her two sons she began
writing and illustrating children's
books she lives with her family in
westchester county new york so i
introduce you to the members of the
faith
[Applause]
club thank you for being here um as you
know by now i am the muslim mother i
came to the faith club out of a deep
sense of isolation and alienation from
the public dominant voice of islam after
9 11.
as a mother i was deeply concerned and
worried about what it would mean for my
american-born children to grow
up both american and muslim i knew i
needed them to be proud with that
challenge in mind i sort of hit the
books and start reading
and it doesn't take me long to discover
what i feel is the true inner beauty of
islam the fact that muslims kneel down
in prayer five times a day and end their
prayers the salutations of peace
to abraham and this and his descendants
including moses and jesus and the
prophet muhammad the fact that muslims
believe in the gospels and the torah the
fact that muslims believe that
essentially
judaism christianity islam are but three
forms of one religion at the root the
religion of abraham with that in mind um
i'm excited and inspired to reach out to
a christian mother and a jewish mother
to try and do something to
write a children's book that would serve
to highlight the commonalities of our
our faith tradition
no sooner had we started talking though
that of course the uh the jewish and the
christian mother
started having their own conflict which
i let them talk about but um
i'll i'll leave you with this thought as
they were hashing it
between the two of them i kept thinking
they kept talking about the salient
points in the judo christian tradition
and i kept thinking why isn't it the
judo christian muslim tradition
so um
when they finally get to me and then
dialogue the dialogue centers on two
stereotypes the first one is of course
the idea that priscilla came home soon
from a cocktail party and she said you
know you say your god is our god too but
i don't know a very erudite man said to
me either mecca versus medina verses and
so on so forth the idea that within
islam within its text
the text hold holds the root to to
conflict to a religion of a sword spread
by the sword
i'm here to tell you that nowhere in the
quran does it say kill and you shall be
rewarded and that when religion is used
to justify violence or as a tactic of
war it is no longer a religion but a
human ideology and has nothing to do
with god's values
um the second stereotype is the idea of
islam being repressive and anti-women
and i'm here also again to counter that
image to tell you that 1.6 billion
muslims
in the world choose to stay within the
faith tradition of islam not because it
came to suppress and discriminate
against with against women but rather
the prophet is revered as someone who
came to advocate as a champion of
women's rights
um
two personal things had to happen i came
to the rel to the face club someone
describing herself of faith but no
religion and through our dialogue i had
an affirmation i come out a more
confident and affirmed muslim
the two big challenges for me was i
needed my faith tradition is my religion
to sustain my belief in the universal
god the good news is it does there are
many verses within the quran that
confirms the idea that had god willed he
would have made us all the same
tribe creed or religion but it was by
god's intended design that he would have
us of different religions because he
wanted us to know one another and
through our actions prove
ourselves
the second issue is the idea that i
would have to stress a certain way where
veil perhaps or live a certain way eat a
certain way drink a certain way in order
to qualify as a muslim i was helped with
that challenge um
through essentially my finding an imam
who's wonderful and he was able to
refine for me the difference between
religion and faith when he shared with
me an anecdote about the prophet
muhammad when he was asked what does it
take to be a good muslim well the first
thing is a belief in god the second the
prophecies the third is to act as if god
was with you once you have fulfilled
these three requirements you have faith
and then and only then should you choose
to you can use your rituals of your
faith tradition to service your faith
so the face up is basically a dialogue
of the common person it's a call for us
to have this dialogue we're here we're
honored to be amongst these wonderful
scholars theologians and people who are
so accomplished we are mothers who set
out to have a dialogue with um our
children in mind and we found it so
liberating and our call is that um for
you to go ahead and do the same and for
for me personally as a fellow american
citizen to ask you to ask me the tough
questions please uh don't live under the
misconceptions and assumptions don't out
me as the other and uh for muslims it's
a call to to read the quran to make it
as part of your fabric of your life
because as muslims i feel like we can
celebrate the universal um god
accessible to all we have access to the
christian god the god of passion and
love the jewish god the mixes and
actions and third the the muslim god
god accessible to all i'm very excited
because i feel that in the very near i
know i'm going to be i have i've been
asked to
summarize 60-minute presentations three
i'm
getting down to my punch line
so um this is it i'm looking i i look at
my daughter and my son's not here but my
daughter's here and i'm very
confident and secure that i know that in
the near future they'll be able to speak
of the and proudly speak of the great
american judo christian muslim tradition
[Applause]
i'm the jewish mother
um
i came to this my crisis of faith was
purely about fear after september 11th i
was basically paralyzed terrified of
terrorism i ironically had gone to
hebrew day school i was very well
grounded in my religion but i say i had
religion but no faith i answered a phone
call from suzanne oliver it seemed the
whole world was screaming about religion
and i thought well if i meet these two
women and i sit down and we talk calmly
about religion maybe something will come
of it little did i know we would not be
talking so calmly and quietly people say
we took off the gloves people say we
said things nobody says to each other we
built up a level of trust over a number
of years and i do think that it's a
conversation that many many people can
replicate but the most important thing
that i learned was the first tenant of
the faith club was honesty
um that everyone wants to be validated
for who they are a very important lesson
for me i came into it with some
stereotypes
when i walked into ronnie's apartment
i'd never met a muslim woman before i'd
certainly never met a palestinian woman
before
and later i wrote that i expected i was
shocked that ronnie would sit down and
talk to me face to face so
honestly
welcome me so graciously into her home
um i grew up you know with this notion
that
jews were going to be pushed into the
ocean and instead she fed me fed me
beautifully and fed me body mind soul
uh all across the board i had some
stereotypes about christians oddly
enough even though i went to a quaker
school and had as i say some of my best
friends were christians but i met a
woman a lot of the the um i think the
strength of this book is that we were
all strangers to each other ronnie and
suzanne met at a bus stop suzanne made a
phone call and got hooked up with me so
i met a woman who went to all catholic
schools grew up in the midwest texas
christian university who loved jesus and
spoke about jesus very openly and jesus
was kind of a stranger to me i talk a
lot in the book about how jesus is a
stranger to the jews
um
[Music]
and when we got into our discussion
about the crucifixion you have to read
the book because i've only got three
minutes and that's a good way to plug
the book but we got into a very animated
discussion about jesus and
after suzanne over the course of many
many months read to me from the sermon
on the mount and some of my very
favorite quotes quotes in the book come
from jesus i'm proud to say that i'm now
on a first name basis with jesus i talk
about jesus to my children and i
write in the chapter after
you can imagine the the conversations we
had after the conversations that divided
us we had amazing conversations about
what united us as rania says we all
begin the same way and we will all end
the same way we have all lost loved ones
we've all suffered pain one of the
important things i learned in the book
through my conversations with ronnie and
suzanne was not to quantify suffering
not to compare my suffering to anyone
else's it doesn't really serve to move
people forward everyone has pain
everyone suffers but after the painful
chapters came my favorite chapters
um and i in the end of the book started
off as a person without a definition of
god by the end of the book
after flying over the great lakes and
looking down below me and recognizing my
humility which is suzanne ranya pointed
out to me islam means to submit and that
means to acknowledge your humility in
the universe
um i shrunk myself down and
paradoxically i found
enormous power in that and my definition
of god is the one now that begins my
book and it's martin buber's definition
when two people relate to each other
authentically and humanly god is the
electricity that surges between them and
i say that when we're together sparks
fly and the current is very strong
[Music]
i might tell you a little more about
what some of those sparks were
um i am obviously the christian i came
to the faith club project after 9 11
when like many new yorkers and many
americans i was interested in learning
more about the middle east and islam in
order to assess how safe my family and i
were in new york and what was going on
so i met rani at the school bus stop our
daughter started kindergarten together
that year and when she started telling
me the story she had come across about
the connections among judaism islam and
christianity and told me her idea of
writing a children's book i jumped at
the opportunity to spread a message of
peace among three religions whose
differences were really fueling violence
and misunderstanding and hatred
um in fact she'd already invited another
christian and i grabbed the phone and
told her to cancel that other christian
right away because i wanted to join this
project
if i was going to summarize my faith
club journey very quickly i would talk
about it as one
of being from a certain amount of
certainty to doubt as i started the
faith club i was very interested in
learning more about islam and judaism i
thought of islam as a violent religion
controlled by men and filled with
mistreated women yet he was rania who
wasn't covered who didn't seem to be
mistreated by her husband whom i met
and who drank a glass of wine on
occasion i wanted to know how she
reconciled what her modern life with
what i thought of as the religion of
islam
and my knowledge of judaism that we
share the old testament was not that
much more substantial i thought of it as
an ancient and exclusive religion and
one that didn't benefit from jesus's
message of love and life everlasting
so while i was interested in learning
more it was in a more of an academic
sort of way i didn't think that what i
learned was going to sway any inner
conviction or suspicion that i had that
christianity was the superior religion
of these three
but then as soon as we started talking
everything that i thought
came into question and i started to
question language that i'd been using
for
40 years now you know how old i am and
not really
not really thinking about what that
language meant early on as rania was
talking about her temple and church envy
because she doesn't have a mosque in new
york where she feels very comfortable i
brought her to my episcopal church
and thought maybe it could be a sort of
a spiritual foster home for her a place
where she could join in our charitable
projects and we had all celebrated this
one god that we believed in so her
family came with us to easter service
and the music and the flowers it was all
wonderful and then all of a sudden we
started talking about lamb of god and
body and blood and the sacrificial lamb
and i started feeling really
self-conscious and wondered what does
this all mean that i've been saying all
the time and realizing that this was
actually something that separated us
so then there were other things that
were coming to the forefront right away
as ronnie started talking about uh
muhammad's mission on earth
i felt jesus position threatened by a
follow-up prophet that well hadn't god
played his trump card with jesus why
would he need to send somebody else
and as i was talking about the
crucifixion with um priscilla and she
heard words
differently than i had meant for them to
be heard and thought that i was accusing
jews of being christ killers
um she asked me at one point as i was
writing about uh pentecost if i could
just leave the crucifixion out of the
story
so
it shows you how far we've come
to laugh about things like that now
um i suppose as we talked about as
priscilla was talking to me about reform
judaism's idea of a god existing without
an afterlife that really made me
question my own idea of god because god
and afterlife had always come hand in
hand as we came to talk about jesus as a
symbol of love and suffering
and
i started questioning whether he was
divine did i have to believe he was
divine as he was a christian as i
started reading books like misquoting
jesus i um started
all these questions came forward i was
very lucky to have access to a fantastic
priest at my parish who reassured me
right away with the words the opposite
of faith is not doubt it's certainty
and from that point on i was really able
to embrace my doubt it kept me humble it
allowed me to open my mind i was able to
see how priscilla and rania both found
um elements in their own tradition that
fed their spirituality that brought them
closer to god
and um i quickly will sum it up then i
brought um priscilla and ranya with me
to st james my church and we were
talking to the teenagers about our own
journeys as we were having our
conversations together and i think um
one of them uh asked us well in order to
believe in your own religion don't you
have to believe that the other two are
wrong
and i think this was the nugget of what
i was wrestling with through a lot of
the faith club and i told him that no i
didn't think so that i didn't think god
differentiated between a good muslim a
good jew a good christian a good atheist
and that if god didn't differentiate
then why should i
um and i was able to find
um
certainly lots of uh quotes within the
bible that i felt
um supported that and as we have gotten
emails critical of uh the sort of
universalistic view that i've come to
even the the scripture that they put
forward i am the way the truth and the
life the only way to god is through me
is one that i see as being so open
because to me that says the only way is
by
following jesus message of love and
compassion for your fellow man
and that i know is common to all three
of our religions
[Applause]
thank you and thank you for um
keeping it tight we
i want to i want to give you enough time
to get to know these writers but also to
have a little bit of time at the end to
ask questions so
our next
our next speakers are
both going to speak on a similar topic
earlier this year the national
geographic society upset a whole lot of
people with the announcement of a new
archaeological discovery the gospel of
judas
it turned the bible's version of judas
on its head
and among the experts whom the national
geographic society called on to help
interpret the texts for the public were
these two writers i'll start with bart
ehrman who's at the end there
he's the author of the lost gospel
he is a distinguished professor at the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill
he chairs the department of religious
studies there and his specialty is the
new testament and the history of early
christianity now bart has his own
interesting personal history of
christianity i'd say in his youth he was
a conservative evangelical and he
attended wheaton college in illinois
later at princeton seminary he began to
question whether the bible is the
literal inerrant word of god
his own search for answers is reflected
in his scholarly books
he's written and edited 19 books and
among his most recent are lost
scriptures books that did not make it
into the new testament
and misquoting jesus the story behind
who changed the bible and why
i'll also introduce herbert krosny he's
the author of also the lost gospel the
quest for the gospel of judas iscariot
he's a writer and documentary filmmaker
he specializes in investigative and
historical projects and has worked for
the bbc pbs the history channel and the
canadian broadcasting corporation
he's a graduate of harvard he reported
for the albany times union newspaper and
then served in the us army and then he
moved into television working for cbs
abc and the predecessor of pbs national
educational television i don't know how
many people remember that
in 1968 he went to israel to head the
documentary department of israel
television and in 1970 he formed his own
documentary company
he's produced pieces on jerusalem world
war ii russia and iran's nuclear
ambitions
in addition to the lost gospel krosny
has written several other books
including beyond welfare poverty in the
super city and deadly business legal
deals and outlaw weapons so i give you
bart ehrman and herb krosny thank you
[Applause]
in some sense christianity has always
been in a state of crisis
because uh christianity from the very
foundations uh of the faith has insisted
that christ in some sense is the way of
salvation and yet christians haven't
been able to agree on what that way
entails
uh the gospel of judas that's just been
discovered and uh published just six
years ago six months ago now
uh by national geographic is a good
illustration of how diverse early
christianity was
christianity today continues to be
extremely diverse
if you compare what a greek orthodox
priest thinks with what an appalachian
snake handler thinks uh or an
episcopalian with a mormon or a
jehovah's witness with a seventh-day
adventist you have an enormous range of
beliefs and practices among christians
today in in the ancient world the
beliefs and practices were even more
diverse uh my my expertise in
christianity is in the first second and
third centuries
in the second and third centuries there
were christians who obviously believed
that there was one god there were other
christians who believed that there were
two gods and some said there were 12
gods we know of some christians who said
there were 36 gods we have one christian
group that said there were 365 gods
which is very convenient because then
you could have a god a day
you are god for today um
christians believe some christians
believe jesus was both human and divine
some said he was human but not divine
some said he was divine but not human
uh christian some christians said god
created this world others said god never
had anything to do with this world
different christians had different
points of view and they all claimed that
their points of view represented the
views of jesus himself as as found in
the writings of his apostles all of
these various groups had books that
claimed to be written by apostles that
represented each of these mutually
exclusive points of view
the gospel of judas is one of these
books that now has been discovered that
had that illustrates quite well the
diversity of early christianity the
gospel of judas is a product of early
christian gnosticism
gnosticism is a is a term that scholars
use for a range of religions that uh
understood that the way of salvation is
not by faith in christ death and
resurrection but by the secret knowledge
that jesus conveyed
gnostics understood that they were
alienated from this world because they
didn't really belong here this material
world wasn't created by the one true god
this material world is a cosmic mistake
created by lower divinities and the key
to salvation is to escape the material
trappings of this world
the gnostics were people who felt
completely alienated in this existence
they felt like they don't really belong
here this world doesn't make sense to
them
i felt this way since the last election
the world the world just
makes sense to other people well they
belong here but some of us don't well
how do we get out of here well we need
to get the knowledge necessary for
salvation and escape this world the
gospel of judas conveys this secret
knowledge it's a complicated book in
some ways because the knowledge that it
gives the revelation that it conveys is
secretive and mystical and hard to
understand but those who are on the
inside the gnostics are the ones who can
understand what this truth is
this this gospel was condemned as a
heresy in the second century and was
eliminated from consideration from the
canon of the new testament
luckily though a copy of it was made in
uh in egypt in the early 4th century or
the late 3rd century it got buried in a
tomb and luckily it turned up in 1978
the uh the story of how it was
discovered uh and uh and how it was
handled by antiquities dealers until
finally we got a translation of it six
months ago is uh summarized for me in my
book on judas but really uh the the
entire story is told at great length in
her crosny's book on the lost gospel
[Applause]
working with bart was a pleasure because
in addition to anything else he wrote
the introduction to my book and i
uh and and he was a great great
uh scholar of early christianity we
really didn't know much about the second
or third century almost everything that
we know about the second and third
century which is the formative periods
uh when the church developed uh uh come
from the people who were representing
the church particularly eusebius who
lived in caesarea in what is modern-day
israel uh
the
one of the things that has fascinated me
in terms of the early history of the of
uh the gospel of judases
uh and and impressed me was the
closeness
uh in the first second and third
centuries of judaism and christianity
and how the gentile peoples in in in
essence adopting the old testament were
really adopting
a history which was foreign to them
and uh which had to be sold to them in
many ways and a lot of this was
represented and and brought to fruition
in the city of alexandria which three
centuries before in the third century
when it was founded by alexander the
great actually gave a charter to the
jews saying you will be treated equal to
the macedonians and it's a little-known
history but actually alexander is a
revered figure uh in uh jewish history
uh and gnosticism in many ways uh there
were two
severe repressions of uh jews in
alexandria and gnosticism is believed
partly to have developed out of that and
a lot of what you see in the gospel of
judas is a reaction a criticism of uh
the whether the fall of the temple or
there uh there is a reaction against uh
the god of the old testament uh in other
words there was good news for the jews
and and the gospel of judas and freeing
up who the jews were and the
responsibility for the
uh crucifixion of christ but also it was
a severe rejection of uh the god of the
old testament and and in fact the gospel
of judas is a
highly polytheistic uh document
nonetheless as we come into the present
day
uh we've had a extremely interesting
reaction the vatican
people there's been some journalists who
have written that the vatican has been
extremely critical of
us of the gospel of judas in fact the
vatican has not
commented in any official way in
over the last 15 centuries or so on what
is believed to be apocryphal literature
but i found myself on a number of
television programs
not arguing with catholic priests but
finding that that certain catholic
priests were were re-establishing the
early christian wars that bart writes so
ably about and fighting against
agnosticism which they thought that they
had defeated as a dissident movement
within christianity between the second
and fifth centuries then the negative
reaction uh the
we've had extremely
great interest in in the entire project
among all the catholic and orthodox
countries meaning russian orthodox and
greek orthodox
we
have had certain letter writing
campaigns by certain
evangelicals against the gospel of judas
as if we were responsible somehow for
this historical document which came out
of the desert uh
what did what i think um uh i've brought
away from it is the
the the sense of reverence uh that many
people have the need the need for a
defining uh deity and the closeness
nonetheless with all with all these
conflicts nonetheless the closeness
among
men of wanting to find
answers to their condition
[Applause]
thank you herb
chris hedges is the author of losing
moses on the freeway
the book is an indictment of how far
americans have fallen from following the
ten commandments
the book's ten chapters reconsider the
commandments through chris's reflections
and vignettes of people's lives very
inventive vignettes
chris's best-selling first book is war
is a force that gives us meaning
it was drawn from his experiences
reporting on wars in central america in
africa and yugoslavia
it was a finalist for the national book
critics circle award
he's also written what every person
should know about war
chris grew up the son of a circuit
riding minister in a small town in
upstate new york he and his father
talked bible and morality every sunday
while driving the churches where his
father was to preach
he graduated from colgate university and
then harvard divinity school but he
eventually decided not to follow his
father into ministry
instead he pursued a higher calling
journalism
he worked for the dallas morning news
the christian science monitor and
national public radio he joined the new
york times in 1990 and was a member of
the team that won the 2002 pulitzer
prize for explanatory reporting for
coverage of global terrorism
he lives in princeton new jersey and has
a new book coming out in january
not at all controversial the title is
american fascism the rise of the
christian right
chris hedges
uh thanks
i uh
i just wanted to comment briefly i mean
as somebody who did grow up
[Music]
in the church and then spent almost 20
years abroad seven of those years in the
middle east uh in israel and
the muslim world uh
h richard nieber the theologian had a
great line that you know religion is a
good thing for good people and a bad
thing for bad people
there are passages for instance in the
gospel of john that are very
anti-semitic
in the letters of paul
uh you know denouncing homosexuality
uh you know there are moments in the
hebrew bible when god can be a bigoted
cruel
uh tyrant that seems to bless acts of
genocide if one looks for instance when
moses leaves egypt
and i think that and of course the book
of revelation or the book of daniel
which are used extensively by the
religious right in our own country to
justify and yearn i think many ways feed
a yearning for apocalyptic violence uh
and these passages have to be dealt with
because they are within the canon the
quran also has very virulent passage
not in the early part but in the later
part against jews
and how do we deal with these
i think in in some ways we have to
accept that
those darker elements and those people
that perhaps hate richard nieber would
define as bad people can find scriptural
uh sanctification for their hatred and
bigotry uh and i think sometimes we who
who reach out and and embrace a more
whole or uh humanistic approach
can ignore those passages in the bible
just as assiduously as i think the
christian right will ignore uh the
sermon on the mount
how do we cope with that how do we deal
with that um i think us and we're
entering an age where
um
the
there are powerful forces fundamentalist
forces not
both the jewish
islamic and christian and of course even
hindu
that get scriptural sanctification for
bloodlust violence uh there has to begin
i think a more concerted response on
those of us who uh
believe in in the religious tradition
but i think embrace the values of the
enlightenment and a kind of humanism to
denounce these passages within our own
uh scripture uh to denounce uh the book
of revelation for instance uh i i
i think too often uh we skirt that issue
by pretending that it's not there and i
think we're reaching a point even with
an american society um where
we we have to confront
uh the fact that um you know even in a
unitarian universal church pew in boston
uh there are uh
within the canon uh passages that
uh
uh that fuel movements that i think are
not only anti-religious but anti-human
thank you
[Applause]
our panelists out of respect for you
really and respect for each other have
really been very disciplined in their
presentations and that's to give you
time to ask questions so
i open it up to
questions from the audience
yes
i'm just curious about the degree of
confidence
in our understanding of what is it that
causes
violence of course we know
it's cliche that it's caused by
perversion of religion but i'm afraid
that it's far from us
so how you know what sort of percent ten
percent fifty percent nine percent that
we understand what actually is going on
okay uh should i repeat the question yes
okay okay he is asking i'm not sure
which panelist you're asking maybe you
throw it open to the whole panel okay uh
if we really understand what are the
causes of religious violence is it
well let me just begin as somebody who'd
covered so-called religious wars in the
middle east or in yugoslavia which i
think fundamentally are not religious
wars they're they are wars born out of
collapse societies and despair
um
and i really agree with freud that
people will find uh ideological
structures uh whether they're religious
uh you know i think one could look
generically at communism or fascism uh
as
in generic terms a kind of religion um
i think they share in common many
elements including that yearning for
apocalyptic violence that belief that
violence can cleanse the world purge the
world make the world a better place
and then of course in this weird kind of
spiritual darwinism uh all the believers
will be lifted up their clothes left
behind with the rest of us who will rot
and burn and
and so i think that that that and i
think freud wrote about this very well i
think that what we're dealing with is is
those dark currents that what freud
would call the love of thanatos or the
death instinct
which is really what these so-called
religious systems are about it's about a
yearning for death i think it's
something within human nature and i
think it's wrong if if there wasn't you
know
canonical passages in uh
you know in the book of revelation or
the book of daniel to justify it they
would find something else i i think it's
false to blame religion
anybody else want to
respond to that that's a it's a very
good
good question somebody
okay ronya
i think um very well put
again i i don't believe the source is uh
religion and i feel that i should
probably say something because islam
suffers from that it's a stereotype that
somehow within its texts it's some more
prone to this type of uh violent
reaction i think that yes we are seeing
a manifestation of this whether
but it's a minority and i think it's
more a problem of the condition of the
state um channels of opposition we have
it islam is is a religion in in
countries for the most part that we do
not have
um
opposition
confirmed
pathways and and and education and and
civic society and and i think that's
really where the root of the problem is
rather than looking at it i mean few
people would think that one should just
look at the bible to really understand
the inquisition or the crusades and
sometimes in our readings here of
how do we understand this violent
reaction we tend to so be so
tunnel visioned and just to look at the
quran which i don't think is is the one
problem
guilty of that after all our push west
in the 1840s and 1850s
and
gave us the justification to do whatever
we want in the interest of
doing god's will
uh essentially we victimize the native
americans essentially
we
use that as a justification for opening
up the votes here in mexico
a comment
uh okay he's asking for a comment on his
comment which is uh isn't the united
states guilty of something similar with
uh using manifest destiny um
okay
anybody want to respond to that
yes okay
it's it's very easy to to
kill another or to uh to justify
violence or education of people so and
so forth when you make them other you
demonize the whole entire people culture
population that's where what we have to
watch for
[Music]
[Music]
church and state
from what i read there's nothing in the
quran which indicates the same thing
that they comply with the state and
religion
as one unit for instance
he's asking about the separation of
church and state he's saying in the
bible there is a passage that can be
understood as uh
the foundation for the separation of
church and state and is there anything
in islam which which does that and he's
asking that of rania
um
[Music]
very much believe in separation church
and state i think that there's nothing
inherently within islam that would
require otherwise indonesia is the
biggest muslim state and it is a secular
state
um uh what else can i say i do not
believe that you know this
most um
studies that i've
as a student um was very much under the
impression that somehow islam was an
exception it was different but you know
i from a common person point of view or
i sort of feel like well
judaism has a lot to say about how you
carry your personal life too how you
consummate a marriage or you maintain a
kitchen
the catholic church has a lot to say
about
birth control so i feel that these are
all issues that can pretty much be
handled
nothing that's particularly a muslim
that would otherwise
um prevent us from separating church and
state
do you want chris do you want to speak
today
well there's the concept of sharia in
islam and it is a belief at least among
certain uh muslims or the small radical
wing if you want to call it small
that does believe in a unified and
imposition of islamic law over entire
societies and they are fighting for that
and uh
uh you know i'm not
i'm not even being judgmental but it's
just a absolute fact that
that
that is one of the tenets of certain
elements within islam well you know john
calvin believed the same thing i mean
you can find it in
you know christianity as well so islam
is hardly exclusive at that point yeah
in fact i mean
christianity uh historically has not
advocated the separation of church and
state uh
the uh
i mean as soon as the roman emperor
converted to christianity nobody wanted
there to be a separation of church and
state so it's really it's a post
phenomenon uh this whole idea that has
nothing to do really with with uh
having any religious impetus
okay one last question
yes
a lot of religions are like always
saying that they're for like peace and
they don't want like violence and how
come there's so much racism i'm like no
everyone's always fighting about
religion okay
all right a good question a good way to
wrap up our panel um
he's saying
so many religions preach about peace so
why is there so much racism and why is
there so much violence
within religion or within
i think in the world this is what you're
asking right why is the world the way it
is please please people need to start
people need to start talking
when you talk about peace and religion
rania suzanne and rania came with me to
a yom kippur service at my synagogue gom
kippur is the holiest day of the year
for jews day of atonement and when we
fast and we pray for another year of
life and to be forgiven for our sins and
when we sat shoulder to shoulder in that
synagogue it was